Intro/Outro
So ist der August und wir haben beide TechNet gesehen.
Aber ich tatsächlich mit P2 Maske saß ich in der Pressevorführung in Köln.
Pflicht.
Die Kollegen mussten nicht und alle sind zu ihrem Platz haben sie natürlich sofort abgenommen die Maske und ich hab gedacht Na ja ich weiß ja nicht. Ich lasse lieber mal auf.
Und wenn man da ruhig sitzt ist es eigentlich auch kein Problem.
Ich durfte ohne Maske die haben mich auch gleich gefragt Wollen Sie noch Popcorn kaufen.
Aus Mitleid kaufe ich jetzt Popcorn meine Maske ohne Maske aber es waren auch nur ein bisschen traurig ins Kino zu gehen. Sechs Leute glaube ich.
Aus Mitleid kaufe ich jetzt Popcorn. Da ich meine Maske hatte als ich doch ohne Maske aber es waren auch nur traurig ins Kino zu gehen.
Sechs Leute es ist ganz ganz dramatisch. Ich war am Wochenende nochmal im Kino sondern in einem Film vollkommen irrelevant.
Aber ich habe dann als ich rauskam war 20 Uhr und ich kenne diesen Parkplatz ja sonst wie das ist es ist eigentlich so dass ich Freitag Samstag nicht dort ins Kino weil es so voll ist dass man nicht mehr vom Parkplatz wegkommt.
Und jetzt sah ich dort naja vielleicht ein Viertel belegt. Und da sprechen wir jetzt von 14 Kinosälen in denen jeweils zwei drei vier fünf Leute sitzen.
Ich saß in einer Vorstellung allein da brauche ich dann kein da brauche ich dann keine Maske. Werbung haben sie gezeigt aber da hab ich dann auch die Maske ausgezogen.
Es ist schon sehr traurig. Ich habe allerdings durch TechNet jetzt auch wieder Lust bekommen ins Kino zu gehen.
Ich werde natürlich diese großen Stoßzeiten wenn sie dann doch kommen sollten meiden sondern eher am Nachmittag. Das habe ich immer schon gern gemacht.
Aber ich habe richtig wieder Lust im Kino Filme zu sehen und werde das schon jetzt in zwei drei Tagen wieder machen sich mir irgendetwas an was neu ist einfach nur um mal wieder dieses Gefühl zu haben das ich doch vermisst habe.
Ich habe es erst geglaubt Naja wir werden mal sehen aber irgendwie habe ich jetzt gemerkt was mir eigentlich dann doch wohl gefehlt hat.
Ging mir ganz genau so ich bin ja nicht so ein typischer Kinogänger wie du. Ich bin ja durch Familie auch zuhause gefesselt und warte.
Finde es gut dass die Filme dann so zuhause geliefert werden.
Allerdings Ein Film bei dem ich auch meiner Frau sagte Ich geh heute ins Kino.
Ich hab es ein paar Tage zuvor angekündigt. Ich gehe ins Kino mit wem ich sagte Ich geh alleine und ich habe mich daran erinnert in Inception vor zehn Jahren war ich auch alleine. Filme alleine alleinige Interstellar weil sie es nicht mehr genau. Für mich ist das jetzt auch so eine Trilogie irgendwie.
Vielleicht hätte Christopher Nolan das nennen können.
Stella ein Wörtchen irgendwie. Keine Ahnung das heißt der Film Tenet okay. Und ich sage es dann so im Kino. Und es kam auch Werbung für Sex.
Und dann gibt's ja diesen Moment wo man sieht okay die reguläre Werbung endet der Bildschirm wird ein bisschen größer.
Die gehen nochmal auf den Film jedoch noch nicht los.
Ich hab gedacht das ist alles Schrott außer der James Bond ist spektakulär alles Schrott nur gedacht Oh Gott ist das das Kino Gevgelija ist das die Einladung jetzt ins Kino zu gehen.
Und dann ging aber Tenet los und ich hätte auch nichts dagegen jetzt einfach jeden Monat einmal Tenet zu gehen um irgendwie die Kinolandschaft zu unterstützen oder so..
Es war ein Spektakel sondergleichen.
Ich bin dann so auf dem Fahrrad alleine durch Frankfurt nach Hause gefahren. Ich denke noch sowie den Film nach und ich war wirklich wie damals bei ihm.
Ich fand es ganz hinreißend. Diese ganze Erzählweise Es war auch zwischendurch ein bisschen zu laut im Kino. Aber dann liest man wieder nach nee das muss so sein es war aber auch schon dass die Orgel so eintrüben.
Das fehlte mir ein bisschen diese musikalische Akzentuierung. Ich glaube da hätte Hans Zimmer nochmal einen großen Unterschied gemacht.
Findest du das. Ich finde das Sounddesign sehr interessant ich glaube dass es ein bisschen schwierig ist wenn man nicht Muttersprachler ist das auf Englisch im Original zu sehen.
Ich glaube schon.
Ich war ganz dankbar dass es Untertitel gab denn.
Ich habe ihn bis jetzt nur auf Deutsch gesehen.
Ich habe dann ja noch ein zweites Mal gesehen. Auf Deutsch hab ich ihn gesehen und es ist wirklich sehr sehr beeindruckend Man achtet nochmal auf ganz andere Dinge und das Tolle aber ist dass es doch bei der deutschen Synchronisation so ist dass man es offenbar,
ein bisschen mehr angehoben hat bisschen ein bisschen lauter,
während das doch so scheint mir das zumindest,
in der englischen Fassung mitunter etwas schwierig wird weil das Sounddesign so dominant ist dass man dann Schwierigkeiten mit den Dialogen mitunter bekommt.
Kommt jetzt aber auch nochmal drauf an in welchem Kino mit welcher Soundanlage man es vielleicht im Original sehen kann mit Untertiteln ist es gut aber auch die synchronisierte Fassung ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ich bin da auch kein Purist und sage Das muss immer nur alles im Original sein.
Ja bei den richtig guten Film. Da denke ich jetzt an alle von Michael Bay und alle von Christopher Nolan um mal alle in einen Topf zu werfen.
Die gibt's ja doppelt im Grunde einmal wenn man sie noch nicht gesehen hat also wenn man sie wirklich das erste Mal sieht alle überraschung drin und dann beim zweiten dritten vierten Mal wenn man so überprüft nochmal genau hinschaut und eigentlich weiß was sie sagen.
Die gibt's ja doppelte Gründe einmal was ich noch nicht gesehen hat. Haben Sie wirklich das erste Mal als überraschung drin und dann beim zweiten dritten vierten Mal überprüft.
Nochmal genau weiß was sie sagen darf man ist bei Interstellar ganz bezeichnend dass besagte Dolinen gleich an seine sozusagen Wiederholungstäter gedacht hat mal meine ich jetzt mal richtig.
Und davon ist bei Interstellar ganz bezeichnend dass Christopher Nolan gleich an seine sozusagen Wiederholungstäter gedacht hat,
und meinte ich die jetzt mal richtig zu dieser Sorge die sich dann London ausgesucht haben und,
den Text kennt man eigentlich schon in dem Moment wo die entsprechenden Textstellen sind okay da ist dann gar keine Musik sondern die kommt dann erst wieder.
Den Text kennt man eigentlich schon.
Gar keine Musik sondern kommt dann erst wieder alles gut abgepasst.
Also alles gut abgepasst aber dann bin ich mal gespannt auf die englische Version. Jedenfalls kam ich dann nach Hause und habe dann jetzt am Wochenende.
Ich mal gespannt auf die englische Version. Jedenfalls kam ich dann nach Hause und habe dann jetzt am Wochenende am Mittwoch für drei Tage am Wochenende Kino plus KAZ gehört. Die waren ja wirklich nicht überzeugt.
Ich war am Mittwoch und der Film wirkte dann schon drei Tage in mir und da habe ich am Wochenende Kino plus und Kaz gehört und die waren ja wirklich nicht überzeugt von dem Film und deswegen.
Und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht wir machen jetzt noch mal so kleine aber ohne jetzt zu groß zu spielen.
Habe ich mir gedacht wir machen jetzt nochmal so ein kleines Tennet Handbuch,
ohne zu groß zu spoilern.
Also wer jetzt noch nicht gesehen hat der kann jetzt weiterhin dran bleiben das wird kein Problem sein.
Ihr könnt dranbleiben und sagen wir es mal so.
Sagen wir es mal so. Dadurch dass es in der deutschen Landschaft dokumentiert ist dass Menschen in den Film reingehen und irgendwie sehen kann man ja durchaus ins Kino gehen sich mal kurz von uns anhören.
Dadurch dass es in der deutschen Podcast Landschaft dokumentiert ist dass Menschen in den Film reingehen und irgendwie die Hälfte übersehen,
kann man ja durchaus bevor man ins Kino geht sich mal kurz von uns anhören auf was man achten sollte ohne dass man jetzt weggeschleudert wird.
Vielleicht sollte ohne dass es so dramatisch.
Bei Christopher Nolan ist es mit den Spielern eh nicht so dramatisch denn wenn man den Deutschen Podcast hört wen interessiert der Plot im Detail. Es geht ja nun wirklich um andere Sachen.
Und so weiter geht der auch im übrigen gut ausgearbeitete ist wie ich finde.
Ich habe dann noch ein zweites Mal überprüft weil ich dann auch bisweilen irritiert war.
Das kommt dann dazu.
Auch in einigen Zeitungen waren das ja zu lesen und ich war da sehr überrascht davon weil ich einfach sagen muss dass es von großen Klarheit eigentlich zeugt dieser Film.
Vor allem ist es halt einfach mal auch ein Film und diese Idee von Christopher Nolan.
Man sieht Sachen die man erst durch Zuschauen so erleben kann.
Wie soll man sagen wenn jemand eine große Erzählung darbieten will kann er sich überlegen welches Medium will da eigentlich Buch Podcast Audio only oder halt alle Sinne ansprechend filmen.
Und dieser Film ist ja nun mal wirklich einer der klappt so nur im Film denn da fahren und das kennt man aus dem Trailer Autos rückwärts.
Aber sie fahren nicht wirklich rückwärts sondern sie sind invertiert sie fahren vorwärts.
Aber die Physik funktioniert rückwärts.
Man sitzt im Auto und fährt vorwärts aber wenn man lenkt schlägt das Heck zuerst aus.
Und solche Sachen. Das ist jetzt sozusagen ganz klein heruntergebrochen was Inversion so bedeuten kann.
Mit denen spielt der ganze Film die ganze Zeit. Aber an den Autofahrten zum Beispiel sieht man es insbesondere und da sieht man auch wie viel Sorgfalt Christopher Nolan da reingelegt hat weil die mussten ja dann beim Drehen wahrscheinlich wirklich rückwärts fahren und es dann vorwärts abspielen und lauter solche Spielereien.
Und da sieht man so ein bisschen wie viel Mühe gegeben hat und diese Mühe geht aber für alle Ideen die in dem Film drin stecken wirklich wahnsinnig.
Tolle Kampfszenen bei denen man sich auch noch fragt Wie kann das überhaupt sein.
Ja das hatten wir noch nie gesehen.
Man muss dazu sagen Es ist ein Film der ohne viel CG auskommt. Das hat ja nochmal ganz klar betont dass man in jedem gewöhnlichen Hollywoodfilm mehr erlebt.
Und das sorgt dafür dass man besonders fasziniert ist davon.
Man sieht es hier nicht einfach so ein bisschen getrickst wurde mal.
Ja genau. Es ist so eine.
Ich will nicht sagen naturalistisch das wäre ein bisschen zu da käme man auf so eine Druckmaschine.
Das ist gar nicht richtig aber es ist,
schon so als fact checker drin irgendwie denkt sich müsste das jetzt so aussehen wie es sich gedacht hat und dann kommt man aber so schnell wie die Szene dahinter nicht mal drüber nach müsste das wirklich so aussehen wenn,
die Zeiten aufeinanderprallen aber deswegen ja dieser Punkt den man wirklich mal machen muss.
Es wird in Deutschland zu viel. Keine Ahnung man lässt sich von Theiler beeindrucken. Christopher Nolan macht ein großes Werk und plötzlich denkt man Es ist ein Film über Zeitreisen.
Ich habe auch viel über Zeitreisen so aber nee die Idee ist nicht die Zeitreise sondern es ist tatsächlich diese Inversion und unter anderem wird in dem Film Die Zeit invertiert.
Aber es werden auch ganz viele andere Sachen invertiert zum Beispiel die Idee der Liebe liefert man sich aus und verliert die Kontrolle oder was bedeutet das eigentlich invertiert bedeuten.
Die Idee von Freundschaft Menschen gestalten so eine gemeinsame Beziehungs Biografie und erleben ihre Freundschaft.
Oder wie lässt sich eigentlich investieren. also eine der besten Pointen überhaupt in so einem Kinofilm unterbringen konnte.
Ja in einem Film Analyse über diesen Punkt gemacht das ist eigentlich der Film zum Klimawandel. Ich würde sagen es geht noch.
Man kann es so thematisch eingrenzen auf Klimawandel aber es geht dann doch noch ein bisschen darüber hinaus. Man fragt sich zum Beispiel Wir reden viel über Silicon Valley was bedeutet eigentlich macht.
Und wenn man Macht investiert der Macht wird ja immer so mit gestalten verbunden. Und wenn man das eigentlich investiert was hieße das eigentlich und wie.
Wie weit könnte man in seinem Film um so eine Art von Macht darzustellen. So ganz viele Sachen.
Ich finde auch ein großer Kommentar für Trump.
So was Narzissmus eigentlich bedeutet ist ganz auf die Spitze getrieben.
Steckt da so viel drin in dem Film dass man es ehrlich gesagt noch ein bisschen schade finde wenn man in so einem Podcast sitzt und sich fragt ob da jetzt ein Fehler ist.
Da gab es ja zwei Pistolen Kugeln und die eine und dann die andere und irgendwie so.
Das sind auch nicht die Fragen die mich da überhaupt beschäftigen würden denn es ist ja so klar dass,
ein Konstrukt hier geschaffen hat und man kann jetzt dann noch dreimal überprüfen ob dieses Konstrukt an sich auch,
stichfest ist aber man kann davon ausgehen dass er lange daran gearbeitet hat und ich würde jetzt mal sagen da entsprechende Fehler oder sowas zu finden wird dann auch sehr eigenartig und wozu auch. Warum.
Ich glaube es gibt ein ganz großes Problem bei der Rezeption des Films dass man es gar nicht so leicht hat aus Linearität,
aus der Linearität rauszukommen und das merkt man auch selbst wenn man dann zum Beispiel eine Analyse macht wie sehr man auch wieder sofort in einen linearen Modus kommt und sich dann wieder bremst.
Moment das ist ja so gar nicht und das ist auch beim zweiten Mal sehen.
Tatsächlich ist dieser Effekt noch so stark weil wir immer alles als linear wahrnehmen und auch unsere eigene Biografie in Form von Linearität immer verstehen.
Es ist sehr schön die Biografie Forschung und Autobiografie Forschung Literaturwissenschaft die hat ja schon in den 70er 80er Jahren immer wieder hinterfragt warum wird eigentlich eine Lebensgeschichte so linear erzählt und immer als,
Entwicklungsroman immer als ein Roman. Wie hätte Goethe schreiben können.
Es gibt von Alma Mahler Werfel der der berühmtesten Witwe überhaupt in ihrer Autobiographie am Ende das Fazit.
Und so stellt sich mein Leben da wie ein Roman.
Ja das hast du dir so konstruiert wie ein Roman und man kann es eben auch ganz anders betrachten.
Und aus dieser Linearität rauszukommen das ist eigentlich auch glaube ich nochmal ein Anstoß für das Kino generell.
Also ich muss jetzt nicht Fortsetzungen von Tennet sehen.
Ich hoffe er hütet sich und macht das nicht. Aber das nichtlineare das nicht lineare Erzählen das hat ein riesiges Potenzial.
Er ist ganz erstaunlich dass man so eine Idee sieht im Film und dann mal 2020 ist das erste Mal diese Idee aufgekommen.
Das Einfachste was wir haben auf das sich alle einigen können nämlich wie die Zeit verläuft.
Damit zu spielen auf der anderen Seite passt wieder 2020 sehr gut weil wir haben jetzt schon festgestellt dieser Spruch Wir leben alle in unserer eigenen Welt.
Den kann man jetzt irgendwie durch Social Media und der ist total präsent. Aber die Idee von Wir leben in unserer eigenen Zeit,
dass man da ein paar Synchronisierung unabhängig aller Inhalte und so weiter dass man da ein paar Synchronisierung feststellt Das liegt jetzt offen.
Wenn man solche Filme sieht wo er am Ende es gibt dann am Ende eine ganz große Szene wo man wirklich die Referenz verliert zwischen vorwärts und rückwärts wo nicht mehr entscheidend ist.
Wer ist jetzt hier gerade rückwärts und wer es vorwärts sondern wo man einfach je nach Perspektive grad sieht für die sind die gerade rückwärts und für diesen Deal gerade rückwärts aber was jetzt rückwärts und vorwärts in echt ist ja das ist schon völlig aufgehoben und irgendwie macht der Film doch noch einmal weg.
Man fragt sich auch Zeitreisen wozu eigentlich in dem Film war es ja eindeutig begründet warum Zeitreisen.
Klar es gibt da einen Bösewicht der sehr virtuos mit Zeitreisen umgeht.
Aber man stelle sich mal die Frage wo Zeit ist Geld und wissen es macht.
Was bedeuten diese Sätze eigentlich weil da kommen wir auch beim Silicon Valley nach was erkauft man sich wirklich mit sehr viel Geld Zeit Wissensvorsprung durch Zeit Vorsprünge und so.
Man kann Sachen beschleunigen andere Sachen verzögern.
Dieses machtvolle Eingreifen in WELT Das sehen wir aber im Silicon Valley nachher ganz deutlich und Christopher Nolan hat das wirklich nochmal auf die Spitze getrieben.
Diese ganze Idee hat natürlich keine Pointen. Aber es geht ja um alles in dem Filme. Und so muss man sich auch anschauen.
Und er hat auch wirklich sehr gut überlegt Wie kann denn das auf allen Ebenen durchexerziert Du hast die Beziehung schon angesprochen.
Es geht noch um Kunst um Original und Fälschung. Da wird nochmal mit gearbeitet.
Auch sehr sehr komplex wie er das macht. Und ich habe einen Clip mitgebracht über ein Schauplatz nämlich ein ganz wichtiger Schauplatz in dem Film sind sogenannte Freeport.
Das sind also zollfrei Häfen in denen wird Kunst gelagert und bei diesen Freeport ist es so dass die ursprünglich,
eine sehr praktische Funktion hatten für Sammler Händler und so weiter aber inzwischen doch sehr zweckentfremdet sind und das ist jetzt ein Bericht von 2015 Reports vom Bayerischen Fernsehen.
Und der ist bei YouTube zu finden. Ich hab denn jetzt gekürzt auf knapp drei Minuten und haben sich bislang angesehen 550 Menschen.
Dann schauen wir mal rein.
Singapur der größte Feind Port für Luxusgüter weltweit so sicher wie Fort Knox.
Singapur der größte Freeport für Luxusgüter weltweit.
Der größte Flippern für Luxusgüter weltweit so sicher wie.
So sicher wie hier lagern kunstfertig Gold Diamanten.
Hier lagern Kunstwerke Gold Diamanten edle Weine was genau und wie viel. Niemand weiß es.
Kunsthaar Diamanten.
Der Freeport funktioniert wie ein Schachtel System. Die Betreiber vermieten die Lagerräume an Speditionen die diese wieder weitervermitteln teilweise.
Funktioniert wie Wirtschaftssystemen. Die Betreiber vermieten die Lagerräume die diese teilweise über mehrere.
Die Betreiber vermieten die Lagerräume Speditionen die diese wiedervereinte.
In den Freeport lagern ungefähr für 4000 Milliarden US-Dollar Kunstgegenstände.
In den Freeport auslagern ungefähr für 4000 Milliarden US-Dollar Kunstgegenständen.
Lager ungefähr für 4000 Milliarden US-Dollar Kunstgegenständen.
Davon sind 105.
4000 Milliarden also 4 Billionen.
Das ist ein Experte der das mal so einschätzt.
Milliarden mit kriminellem Hintergrund behaftet.
Das heißt Sie sind hinterzogen oder gestohlen besonders wichtig die perfekte Lage neben dem Flughafen die Wertgegenstände werden direkt aus dem Flieger in einen der zehn Lagerräume gebracht.
30 bis 300 Quadratmeter groß.
Ideale Bedingungen konstante Luftfeuchtigkeit von 55 Prozent gesichert durch Laser Netze mit repräsentativer Lobby.
Eine gigantische Skulptur des britischen Designers Ron Arad Sicherheit.
Das Wichtigste aber man bietet hier höchste Diskretion.
Besondere Kunden an wen diese Räume weiter vermieten dazu kann ich nichts sagen. Ich will es auch gar nicht wissen. Ich habe keine Ahnung wer die Mieter sind.
Ursprünglich waren Free Ports für Waren gedacht die sich nur kurze Zeit im Transitbereich befinden.
Aber man hat festgestellt dass das sehr ausbaufähig ist.
Kunstwerke können hier dauerhaft gelagert werden ohne dass Einfuhrzölle bezahlt werden müssen.
Auch Handel ist möglich. Mehrwertsteuer frei in eigenen Showrooms.
All das zeigt man uns bereit für.
Das ist eigentlich ganz schön was wir hier über Tennet reden.
Es wird hier spekuliert hier auf die Zukunft. Es geht jetzt nicht darum Ich sammel Werke eines Künstlers und hängen die bei mir zuhause auf sondern ich sage ich investiere in Kunstwerke,
schaffen mir eigentlich so ein Aktiendepot an mit Kunstwerken nun ist es ja so dass wenn man Aktien hat man wenn man sie wieder verkauft und das alles,
hier in Deutschland tut dann muss man das Ganze versteuern und man wartet eben dass die Aktie steigt dann steigt sie vielleicht um 50 Prozent und dann verkauft man sie wieder.
Mit Kunst ist das ja ganz ähnlich. Man sagt ich investiere in dieses Werk von Jeff Koons lass das drei Jahre liegen und dann verkaufe ich es wieder.
Wenn man sie nicht transportiert kriegt.
Man muss aber nichts am Zoll jetzt zahlen muss er muss dann auch die Steuern nicht zahlen kann also warten bis es da an Wert gewinnt und verkaufe es dann wieder.
Und entgehe so dem Steuersystem.
Es ist unglaublich dass es eigentlich Offshore wie man das aus der Welt kennt ja so.
Outer Space Waltraut Theorie das ist gar nicht von dieser Welt auf dieser Welt sondern man hat nur so ein Planet besitzt Titel also solche Dinger gibt wusste ich gar nicht.
Gibt es auch in Genf und jetzt kommt und auch hier bei uns in der Nähe.
Ich habe das Internet einfach nur gesehen.
Doch auf die Frage ob der Zoll wisse was hier gelagert wird reagiert der Geschäftsführer erstaunlich nervös.
Auf die Frage ob der Zoll wisse was hier gelagert wird reagiert die Geschäftsfreund.
Der Zoll hat Zutritt was er wissen will. Das erfährt er kommt er auch wirklich zum kontrollieren.
Der Zoll hinzutritt. Was wir wissen will das versehrte ja auch wirklich zu kontrollieren.
Sie kontrollieren also so genau weiß ich das nicht ich bin schließlich nur der Geschäftsführer.
So genau weiß ich das nicht ich bin schließlich Geschäftsführer.
Aber ich habe hier schon mal den Zoll gesehen sagt.
Nur der Geschäftsführer.
Der neueste Freeport steht mitten in Europa in Luxemburg vergangenen Herbst eröffnet.
Es werde jedes Kunstwerk vom Zoll registriert versichert man uns. Doch auch hier alles sehr intransparent wer die Mieter sind wissen die Betreiber genau wie in Singapur nicht. Auch nicht ob hier bereits Handel betrieben wird.
Dass Superreiche angelockt werden dafür hatte Jean-Claude Juncker noch als Luxemburger Ministerpräsident persönlich gesorgt. Er brachte ein Gesetz auf den Weg Das Freeport Steuerfreiheit gewährt.
Die Frage Wie organisiert man es denn juristisch.
Landfläche zu finden Ich kenne es ja sonst nur von Botschaften aber das ist ja auch wieder im Film mit der Frage Wir können ja auch einfach so Freeport.
Naja die Vermögen die da liegen das ist ja alles nur Buchgeld. Welche Bedeutung so eine Investition in Zukunft kann es denn schon haben.
In dem Film wird ja auch wieder mit der Idee gespielt habe ich so ein Bild anscheinend ziemlich viel lernen.
Es hört man draußen gerade das Müllauto aber wir lassen das Fenster offen,
sagen sonst reden wir über das Klima.
Wir reden erst einmal über das Klima. Es geht auch ums Klima.
Oder ganz wichtig würde ich sagen ums Klima. Aber dazu habe ich auch viel Analyse gesagt deswegen reden wir jetzt über das Klima aber wir steigen etwas anders ein.
Nämlich. Es war ja so dass die Futura Louisa Neubauer und Oberg und noch einige andere bei Angela Merkel geladen waren.
Und sie haben mit ihr diskutiert aber bevor wir jetzt dazu kommen würde ich sagen Wir hören uns erst mal einen Clip an aus einem legendären Gespräch nämlich Günter Gaus im Gespräch mit Hannah Arendt.
Und da schildert sie jetzt warum denn eigentlich zum Beispiel eine Angela Merkel sagte Ich empfange mal die Future. Was hat Sie denn überhaupt davon.
Wir haben uns alle.
Sie kommen zu dem Schluss dass die ich zitiere eigentlichen Welt orientierten Erfahrungen gemeint also Einsichten und Erfahrungen höchsten politischen Ranges sich mehr und mehr dem Erfahrungshorizont der durchschnittlichen menschlichen Existenz entziehen.
In diesem was menschliche Existenz anlangt wichtigsten Aspekt so sagen sie ist heute das Vermögen zu handeln auf wenige beschränkt.
Was bedeutet dies in der praktischen Politik Frau Arendt. Wie weit wird unter diesen Umständen eine Staatsform die theoretisch auf der Mitverantwortung aller Staatsbürger beruht zu einer Fiktion.
Ich will das mal ein bisschen einschränken.
Sehen Sie. Erstens besteht diese Unfähigkeit des sich wirklich gemäß orientierende nicht nur für die breite Masse.
Es besteht ebenfalls für alle anderen Schichten.
Ich würde sagen selbst für den Staatsmann der Staatsmann wird umgeben eingekreist von einem Heer von Experten.
Und eigentlich wäre hier die Frage zu stellen zwischen dem Staatsmann und dem Experten der Staatsmann muss er schließlich die Entscheidung treffen.
Er kann sie sachgemäß treffen Er kann ja all das gar nicht wissen er muss es nehmen von Experten und zwar von Experten die sich prinzipiell immer widersprechen müssen nicht jeder.
Das ist ganz wichtig Man nimmt sich Experten die sich prinzipiell widersprechen müssen.
Merkel wird ja nicht nur wie wir erfahren haben jetzt durch ihr politisches Wirken offenbar.
Sondern auch Leute die erzählen wie große Autos auf den Straßen haben.
Aber erstmal interessant was sie jetzt sagt dass sie zeigt dass die Ausgangslage für einen Staatsmann eine sehr sehr diffuse ist nur durch Expertenwissen versuchen muss zu einer Entscheidung zu kommen.
Und jetzt bringt sie das nochmal auf den Punkt was das eigentlich bedeutet für uns alle weil wir auch ständig Entscheidungen treffen müssen und auch eine übersicht gewinnen müssen was es denn eigentlich,
bedeutet diese Entscheidungen zu treffen bzw. kann man sie überhaupt so richtig treffen.
Denn es ist ja jetzt keineswegs so bei Merkel gewesen dass sie gesagt hat ab sofort reiße ich hier das Ruder komplett rum.
Vernünftige Staatsmann holt sich die entgegengesetzten Expertisen ein. Denn sonst kann er die Sache ja von allen Seiten sehen.
Dazwischen muss er urteilen.
Und was dieses Urteil ist ein höchst mysteriöser Vorgang nicht in dem äußert sich dann der Gemeinsinn. Was nun.
Sagen wir mal die Masse der Menschen betrifft so würde ich nicht sagen wo immer Menschen zusammen sind,
ganz egal in welcher Größenordnung bilden sich öffentliche Interessen nach und vor bildet sich öffentlichkeit und Amerika wo,
es ja immer noch diese spontanen Vereinigungen gibt die dann auch wieder auseinandergehen.
Nicht diese Assoziation von denen schon Tocqueville gesprochen hat.
Können Sie das sehr deutlich sehen. Irgend ein öffentliches Interesse betrifft jetzt,
eine bestimmte Gruppe von Menschen eine Nachbarschaft oder auch nur ein Haus oder eine Stadt oder eine anders gelagerte Gruppe.
Dann werden diese Leute zusammenkommen und sie sind sehr gut imstande in diesen Dingen öffentlich zu handeln. Denn diese Dinge übersehen.
Das heißt was sie sagen gilt ja nur für die allergrößten Entscheidungen auf allerhöchster Ebene.
Und da glauben Sie mir da ist der Unterschied zwischen dem Staatsmann und dem Mann von der Straße prinzipiell gar nicht.
Weiß ich ein paar Asymmetrien sind schon da. Wir sind angewiesen auf Drosten macht ein Podcast für uns alle. Merkel kann die Rückfragen stellen bei Bratton.
Das mit Sicherheit. Aber ich glaube es geht doch bei den grundsätzlichen Entscheidungen doch auch,
wenn man sich hier Beispiel fragt Brauchen wir eine Umgehungsstraße oder nicht. Sollen wir die verhindern.
Sollten wir Kohlekraftwerke vom Netz nehmen oder nicht sicherlich mehr Faktoren mit zu bedenken.
Sie schildert wie mysteriös diese Entscheidung dann ist Churchill und Kennedy immer mal wieder beschrieben Das ist doch was sehr,
eigenartiges denn man fragt sich ja tatsächlich wenn man,
die Informationen die nach außen gedrungen sind über das Gespräch mit Merkel,
was denn eigentlich ein solches Gespräch bewirkt und wenn man sich jetzt mal das Fazit anhört von Louisa Neubauer die bei der Tagesschau 24 interviewt wurde.
Naja ernüchternd.
Sie waren heute Mitglied der Trümmerberg bei der Kanzlerin. Wie ist es gelaufen.
Wir hatten eine sehr intensive Debatte über 90 Minuten.
Das hat viele Themen angesprochen und sehr klar über die Wissenschaft gesprochen und auch über die große Diskrepanz zwischen der politischen Debatte und der geophysikalischen Realität die wir jetzt überwinden müssen. Welche Themen waren das.
Naja insbesondere haben wir über den deutschen Beitrag die deutsche Rolle in der Klimakrise gesprochen Deutschland als Vorbildfunktion aber eben auch,
was jetzt in der EU passieren muss da ist Frau Merkel gefragt Sie ist EU-Ratspräsidentin gerade und hatte einen großartigen Job zu tun.
Uns muss Nägel mit Köpfen machen und sich festlegen und im Zweifel eben ungewöhnliche Wege gehen und unbequeme Entscheidungen fällen.
Und es ging aber auch grundsätzlich um den Planeten und die Lage weltweit und was dort gemacht werden muss. Bei welchen Punkten waren Sie denn einer Meinung.
Nun Frau Merkel ist Physikerin und hat uns bestätigt dass sie die Wissenschaft versteht. Das ist ein erster Schritt definitiv.
Grundsätzlich sehen wir natürlich haben wir alle auch in diesem Gespräch die Notwendigkeit zu handeln schon gesehen nur eben mit sehr unterschiedlichen Perspektiven.
Und wir haben auch gemerkt dass das Verständnis wie dringend es ist zu handeln und wie wenig Ausreden Es gibt im Endeffekt sind wir da nicht immer gleich schmissig.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Zusagen erhalten.
Frau Merkel hat zugesagt dass sie überprüfen möchte ob sie nicht ambitionierter und mutiger weiter gehen kann.
Hannah Arendt klick klick klick ja noch mal. So impliziert den Fokus auf die Moderne.
Es gibt noch ein Herrscher aber der ist schon sozusagen seien Experten ausgeliefert.
So manche Idee Modell von der überwachten nicht seine Experten sondern die Experten unterbrachen ihn und am Ende kommt noch eine Beschlussvorlage wird dann erarbeitet.
Das unterscheidet sich ja von dem Macchia berlinischen Modell das der Herrscher im Grunde ein eigenes Interesse hat so seine eigene Biografie Gestaltung und eigentlich nur noch,
so Audienzen gibt um Intrigen zu spannen um irgendwie den einen oder anderen dazu übervorteilen oder so.
Und ehrlich gesagt dieser Neubauer Clip der mehr in dieser Macchia Linie als hätten sich die Herrscher schon entschieden.
Und man hätte sie noch einmal vorgeführt für eine Foto-App Merkel mit Greta oder so.
Das ist so das Resultat was hier so bleibt.
Sie wird überprüfen ob sie ambitionierter handeln könnte.
Mal gucken ob ich für mehr Lust und Laune habe als das Resultat das Foto was da Seibert dann twittern kann von mir und Kreter oder.
Ja
genau. Und es ist auch sehr schön dass Sie noch mal sagt dass Merkel Physikerin ist und die Wissenschaft versteht.
Und da denke ich muss man jetzt bei der gesamten Bundesregierung sich keine Sorgen machen dass sie den Klimawandel leugnen nicht wissen.
Man hat ja jetzt doch nochmal einige Publikationen in den letzten Monaten und Jahren gehabt die auch darauf hinweisen wie lang diese Debatte da ist.
Ich hatte ein Buch gelesen von Daniel Ridge.
Das schildert die Klimadebatte von 1979 bis 89 und man ist erstaunt was man dort liest und jetzt gerade wiederfindet.
Es ist keineswegs so dass es unbekannt ist.
Man muss ja nicht als Angela Merkel deswegen ist.
Na
Richtig sich Experten holen in Form von Future die einem sagen das ist ja so mit dem 1,5 Grad Ziel sondern das weiß sie ja selbstverständlich.
Ja
Aber,
in der deutschen Klimadebatte schwingt ja auch immer dadurch dass sie Futura Schüler und so weiter.
Wir müssen die älteren Boomer Generation die entscheiden noch inhaltlich überzeugen im Sinne von Demonstration auf der Straße als Akt der Aufklärung oder so etwas.
Und das ist ja ein ganz anderer Modus als wenn man jetzt feststellt Okay wir reden mit den Reichen mit denen mit den Mächtigen mit den politisch kapazitiven.
Nur die haben gar kein Informationsrecht sondern die haben einfach nur andere Interessen.
Also müssten wir auch unseren Modus ändern. Es reicht jetzt nicht Frau Merkel noch ein Buch,
bewohnbare Erde als Geschenk mitzubringen oder so. Sondern wir müssen jetzt auf dieser politischen Interessen Schiene Machiavellis. Ja wir müssen auch in diesem Modus.
Da muss man sich natürlich auch selber korrumpieren oder sieht schnell korrumpiert aus weil man halt doch anders arbeiten muss.
Auf der einen Seite kann man das immer wieder schön färben indem man sagt Demokratie ist der Kompromiss.
Man kriegt es dann immer wieder hin gebogen aber ist schon eine Neuware zu hören ist schon sehr ernüchternd Ehrlich gesagt.
Das findet auch Hajo Schumacher. Ein Journalist mitunter ganz gerne ein paar launige Kommentare von sich gibt er in der Sendung Thadeusz oder so ist er zu Gast der langweiligste Sendung der Welt.
Die habe ich aber nicht geguckt sondern er war bei Radio Eins und wurde dort gebeten um eine Einordnung dieses Treffens das keineswegs historisch war schon morgen.
Schon Morgen guten Morgen die ist Bewegung hat vor einem Jahr mit Blockaden und Streiks die Politik noch vor sich hergetrieben mittlerweile sind Talkshows und Treffen mit Politikern wie Angela Merkel gestern die wichtige Bühne ist die Bewegung zum zahnlosen Tiger geworden.
Die weißrussischer Bewegungen vor einem Jahr mit Blockaden und Streiks die Politik noch vor sich hergetrieben mittlerweile sind Talkshows und Treffen mit Politikern wie Angela Merkel gestern die wichtige Bühne ist die Bewegung zum zahnlosen Tiger geworden.
Das muss man glaube ich genauso sehen Marco sagte ja gerade dieses Treffen da gestern im Kanzleramt habe eine große Aufmerksamkeit gehabt. Ich behaupte das Gegenteil.
Das muss man glaube ich genauso sehen wie Marco sagt er gerade dieses Treffen der gestern im Kanzleramt eine große Aufmerksamkeit gehabt.
Ich behaupte das Gegenteil Sie ist auf keiner Nachrichtenseite um keinen Trends irgendwo was davon.
Du siehst auf keiner Nachrichtenseite keinen Trends irgendwo was davon ist sind ganz andere Themen die die Agenda beherrschen.
Es sind ganz andere Themen die die Agenda beherrschen.
Ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck mit dem Besuch bei Merkel sind aus den harten aktivistischen jetzt endgültig nur leider nette junge Frauen geworden und nett ist wie wir alle wissen ja nicht die kleine Schwester von ernst zu nehmen.
Ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck dass dem Besuch bei Merkel sind aus dem harten AktivistInnen jetzt endgültig nur leider nette junge Frauen geworden ist wie wir alle wissen ja nicht die kleine Schwester von ernst zu nehmen.
Wurde sehr kritisiert dann mitunter auf Twitter würde sich da so ein Boomer äußern aber ich finde man muss das sehr ernst nehmen was er hier sagt.
Das mag ja sein dass er auch ein Buruma ist und ich glaube man muss es gerade deshalb ernst nehmen wenn man eine große Solidarität mit den Fall,
hat denn man sieht ja tatsächlich dass die Proteste nicht mehr so wirksam sind dass eben jetzt vieles eingehegt wurde von der Medienöffentlichkeit aber auch vom politischen Diskurs.
Jeder lässt sich jetzt doch mal ganz gerne sehen und debattiert mit den konstruktiven Gesprächen interessiert.
Schumacher holt dann noch weiter aus.
Beide erinnern uns mal mit dem Rennbahnen diesem Sondermüll Ackerboden BoD Malika 2 nach New York zu den Vereinten Nationen der Haut der EU.
Wir erinnern uns echt nur noch flüchtig Man hat den Eindruck Kreter ist so ein bisschen überspielt.
Das kennen wir eben von Instagram Post Pop Phänomen also.
Es ist alles so folgenlose Aufregung gefangen dass ja alle toll dieses authentische unschuldige schwedisch Pippi Langstrumpf hafte.
War auch so ein bisschen Chance für uns alle das schlechte Gewissen abzuarbeiten aber es war eben auch eine Inszenierung.
Und jetzt mütterlich abgewürgt worden. Ich meine von Frau Merkel umarmt oder vorgelassen zu werden ist ja kein Zufall dass die Kanzlerin auch Karsch steckt.
Wir kennen die Schlange aus dem Dschungelbuch bis sie mit der Kanzlerin auf dem Foto Gössi zum Talk Inventars sind Muppets.
Da gibts dann auch immer die quengelt Rolle Bosbach Lauterbach jetzt Luisa Neubauer die sind immer besorgt. Immer dagegen alle nicken aber in Wirklichkeit gehören sie doch zum Inventar.
Und weiter geht die wilde Fahrt dann zwischendrin noch eine Goldene Kamera zurückgeben und ja vielleicht gibt's dann irgendwo auch noch eine Kolumne auf focus.de oder so. Damit geht Friis vor Futura den Weg so aller jüngeren Jugendbewegungen.
Leider muss man sagen ob das Extinktion Rebellen war Occupy Wall Street diese Europa Demos weiß man gar nicht mehr wie die hießen.
Alle diese wohlerzogenen Abiturienten mit Betroffenheit Hintergrund die wahnsinnig engagiert sind ohne und das ist das Problem Es passiert halt nix und man hat den Eindruck so nach zwei drei Jahren Kampagne sind die jungen Menschen genauso ausgebrannt wie ihre Eltern.
Da bin ich mir unsicher Ehrlich gesagt Das ist jetzt klassischer Hajo Schumacher. Aber.
Rundumschlag aber es gibt schon so etwas wie eine Aktivisten Müdigkeit die sich irgendwann einstellt man ihm übrigens auch,
ein bisschen zu begrüßen bei den neurechten Jugendbewegungen erleben konnte die haben das auch mal zwei drei Jahre sehr forciert und dann ist irgendwann gut dann ist das ausgepowert.
Ob es nochmal eine Erneuerung geben wird das würde ich jetzt auch nicht ausschließen.
Ich glaube ein ganz ganz großes Problem ist dann tatsächlich diese sind die Repräsentanten die jetzt eingehegt wurden.
Und ich glaube dass die Basis viel stärker sich von denen jetzt lossagen muss.
Vielleicht muss man hier wirklich ein bisschen Französische Revolution machen.
Ich muss die Revolution dabei auch das eine oder andere Kind der Revolution fressen um sich zu erneuern.
Denn ich weiß sehr wohl dass keine Bewegung ohne Gesichter auskommt.
Irgendjemand muss auch ein Interview geben können muss Standpunkte irgendwo vertreten können.
Ich glaube aber tatsächlich dass dieses was Schumacher jetzt so als Instagram Marble beschrieben hat dass das ein großes Problem ist dass man dadurch sehr leicht,
anpassbar ist für einen Diskurs der nicht mehr auf den radikalen politischen Prozess hinausläuft.
Vielleicht muss man hier auch ein bisschen dreidimensionales Schach spielen denn wir wissen von Hajo Schumacher dass er manchmal auch gerne bewusst provoziert in eine Richtung um dann doch wieder ein paar Sachen zu aktivieren.
Manchmal auch gerne bewusst provoziert in eine Richtung um dann doch wieder ein paar Sachen zu aktivieren.
Wir sehen ja ein paar Buruma im Mediengeschäft die sich sehr auf die Seite von freilässt geschlagen haben. Das war bei den Piraten damals schon mal so.
Wir sehen ja Harbou mal im Mediengeschäft die sich sehr die Seite geschlagen haben. Es war bei den Piraten damals schon mal so.
Da hat ja Schirrmacher auch mal so einen Tweet gemacht.
Gemacht interessant Journalisten auf die Reise schickt die Piraten zu begleiten während sie selber welche.
Das Interessante an Journalisten ist immer wenn man sie auf die Reise schickt die Piraten zu begleiten werden sie selber welche weil sie plötzlich die ganzen Defizite die natürlich zu Recht angesprochen werden irgendwie sehen und ja das digitale Leben macht auch ein bisschen mehr Spaß als dieses alte Lotterleben.
Fünfzigerjahre ja alles da muss man schon Steampunk sein um das noch toll zu finden.
Wenn er jetzt aber hier sagt am Ende passiert ja nichts in Sachen Klima passiert nicht nichts.
Das kann man nun wirklich nicht sagen weil man ja auch hier den Green New Deal oder den Green Deal den ein bisschen thematisiere Corona fast so ein bisschen als Katalysator.
Also wir sind in Europa wirklich kurz davor dass wir hier 80 Prozent Zollschranken für Stahl aus China und so weiter. Da passieren schon einige Sachen.
Vielleicht. Du sagst jetzt die sollten so im Sinne einer Französischen Revolution in ihren eigenen Köpfen ihrer Köpfe entledigen.
Lisa Neubaur mal links liegen lassen und einfach machen das halt die Frage inwieweit.
Und deswegen wollt ich sagen ist das noch der beste Vorwurf ja dass man diesen Wert hat weil die Frage ist ja wirklich wenn man sich wirklich engagiert also wirklich so wie Greta aus dem Inneren heraus,
sagt Ich kümmere mich jetzt ums Klima.
Ist dann der politische Anker wirklich die Bundespolitik sollte man sich dann um den European Green Deal kümmern oder gehts da nicht tatsächlich um,
was ich die Solarthermie auf dem eigenen Vereinsheim oder irgendwas mit der Schule oder so um die eigene Universität weil da hast du ja unglaubliche Möglichkeiten,
die Sachen dann doch anzuschieben.
Schon allein weil sie sich betriebswirtschaftlich rechnen.
Große Gebäude mit riesigen Flachdächern einfach mit Solarzellen auszustatten.
Das dauert dann zehn Jahre und das Ding hat sich amortisiert und das kriegt man auch wunderbar durch argumentiert.
Ich bin sehr froh dass du es ansprichst dass nämlich etwas was Jonathan Franzen vorschlägt am besten daran zweifelt dass das Ziel 1,5 Grad Ziel erreicht wird tatsächlich.
Zu bedenken gibt dass sehr viel Naturschutz vernachlässigt wird man gar nicht mehr daran denkt und dass es dann doch auch sehr viele lokale regionale Gruppen sind die großartige Arbeit leisten.
Er beschäftigt sich ja unglaublich intensiv mit Vögeln und kann da auch zeigen was da eigentlich gerade ein ganz großes Problem ist und bei denen ist das nicht in 1,5 Grad Ziel sondern Nistplätze,
abschoss Möglichkeiten die Länder bieten weil es einfach irgendwo ist dass man,
all solche Dinge.
Das kann man sich vorstellen. Er schildert das in seinem Buch sehr sehr deutlich wie katastrophal das ist und es gibt jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten sagt Hajo Schumacher was zu tun ist.
Die eine Möglichkeit ist die folgende.
Zum Schluss vielleicht noch eine kleine Anarchy Beratung vom Bua Es gibt zwei Wege wirklich etwas zu verändern.
Beide sind keine leichten der eines der Kevin Kühnert weg.
Da macht sich ein junger Mensch auf den amtlichen demokratischen Weg durch die Institutionen und Gremien zu marschieren mit Mehrheiten und Nerv um dann oben angekommen vielleicht noch einen Rest Idealismus in sich zu tragen und.
Das ist die.
Frage ob Kevin Kühnert dann noch irgendwann aufzufinden ist.
Olaf Scholz mitgetragen und Kevin Kühnert hat ja dann ein sehr langes Statement rausgehauen und noch Fragen beantwortet.
Ich habe mal einen Auszug daraus mitgebracht und diese Art,
der Kritik an der Kühnert Kritik die es ja in erster Linie ist die ist doch sehr sehr erstaunlich und steht in einem großen historischen Zusammenhang wie wir erkennen. Wir hören jetzt Kühnert selbst.
Kühnert selbst in dieser allerersten Stellungnahme nicht.
Ich weiß auch nicht warum sie das immer da aufnehmen wo der Ton am schlechtesten ist aber wir hören.
Weil er Willy Brandt im Hintergrund steht.
Diese Kultur der berechtigten Kritik leben zu können.
Das ist für mich fast die wichtigste Erkenntnis des gestrigen Tages und die wichtigste Botschaft auch an die eigenen Mitglieder für die nächsten Tage und Wochen um diese Kultur der Kritik weiter konstruktiv leben zu können,
ist es zwingend notwendig sich von einer teilweise verbreiteten destruktiven Art von Kritik abzugrenzen.
Es gibt eine Kritik gerade in manchen linken Kreisen im Umgang mit der Sozialdemokratie.
Sie ist zerstörerisch weil sie davon ausgeht dass die Sozialdemokratie nicht endlich ist.
Es gibt Menschen die haben es sich in einem Weltbild bequem gemacht indem muss die SPD falsch liegen muss sie der Trottel sein darf sie nichts richtig machen weil sonst das eigene Weltbild in seinen Grundfesten erschüttert ist und plötzlich nicht mehr stimmen kann.
Das ist keine produktive Form von Kritik.
Wenn Politikerinnen und Politiker auch 20 Jahre nach politischen Entscheidungen als Karikatur ihrer selbst bezeichnet werden wenn ihnen nicht zugestanden wird Erkenntnis Prozesse durchzumachen.
Realitäten wahrzunehmen und ihre praktische Politik daran auszurichten und auch zu ändern dann sind wir nicht mehr in einer zutiefst demokratischen sondern einer misstrauischen Debatte.
In einer der Kompromisse die in diesen Zeiten so wichtig sind nicht mehr möglich sein werden dann werden wir auch keine Mehrheiten links der Mitte finden.
Das ist für alle die sich konstruktiv und gerne auch links in der Sozialdemokratie einbringen wollen die wichtigste Botschaft Kritik ja aber immer in der Erkenntnis dass Veränderung möglich ist und auch mit langem Atem erstritten werden.
Kühnert durchschaubar.
Ich finde auch und ich finde es auch ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen,
feige jetzt nicht die Kritik an sich zu trennen von der Kritik an der Partei.
Die Kritik dass er der großen Rebellen markiert hat und auch gute Interviews und all das gegeben hat will man ja überhaupt nicht leugnen.
Und jetzt entsprechende Kritik dafür einstecken muss dass er diesen,
Kandidaten Olaf Scholz mitträgt der überhaupt nicht für das steht für das Kevin Kühnert bislang vorgab zu stehen und dass man das jetzt eben den Linken in der Partei,
zurück spielt und sagt Ihr seid eigentlich die die,
die Partei zerstören.
Mit dieser Form der Kritik und auch dann eben nicht die Verdienste von Olaf Scholz nicht alle auflisten können.
Ihr habt das ja im Fernseh Podcast getan. Ihr wisst um die großen Verdienste und ich habe noch die rennst,
von Jani im Ohr dazu wunderbar aber ich habe auch Olaf Scholz von Kindheitstagen eigentlich so vor Augen immer wieder unddes ist aber da schon immer gewesen er war früher der Parteisoldat.
Wenn keiner raus wollte musste Scholz und jetzt wird er quasi für diese Pflichten die er damals übernommen hat Speth belohnt.
Aber man kann hier bei Kühnert glaube ich sehr klar sehen wie viel Idealismus da dann am Ende noch vorhanden sein wird.
Ich kannte dieses Statement noch nicht. Mir schwingt aber noch im Ohr wie die Deutschlandfunk Journalisten im Deutschlandfunk Politik Podcast wo man ja auch so ein bisschen freier Rede,
hier wieder Bewunderung für Kevin Kühnert weil er die Situation mal wieder gedreht und war überzeugend.
Und dann kommt ja immer unter Journalisten so das dumme Volk fand das bestimmt überzeugend.
Wir haben es durchschaut aber die finden das bestimmt alle total überzeugend. Das Problem mit dieser Argumentation wie Kühnert sie ja jetzt gerade gemacht hat ist ja auch.
Er appelliert an die Kritiker darüber nachzudenken was passiert wenn ihr mit eurer Kritik nämlich die SPD aus dem Recht habt.
Dann füllt die Lücke die CDU.
Und darauf reagiert die Linke schon die ganze Zeit mit. Naja aber wenn ihr die SPD einfach nur als Filler Block,
ins politische Spektrum stellt und das dann ununterscheidbar ist von der CDU dann kann man es auch drauf anlegen und dann lassen wir die CDU diesen Block mal füllen so wie jetzt mit 38 Prozent oder so.
Und dann bauen wir halt die linke Kritik mal neu statt einfach nur mit dem Argument Na Hauptsache nicht die Schwarzen nehmen die Roten Schwarzen.
Und dass er dieses Argument eigentlich kennt und hier aber bewusst wegwirft weil wir bleiben mal weiter weil ich gehört zu dem Block.
Wir bleiben mal wieder. Wir bleiben mal weiter bei der Argumentation.
Lieber ein rot schwarzer Block als ein rein schwarzer Block obwohl ununterscheidbar ist.
Da hat man wirklich die jahrzehntelange Geschichte von Olaf Scholz seit damals Gerhard Schröders Generalsekretär war dann Sozialminister unter Merkel und jetzt Kanzlerkandidat. Das ist ja wirklich.
Das zieht sich ja durch diese Verteidigung von Hartz IV die Ablehnung von Vermögenssteuer die Drangsalierungen von Arbeitslosen und so weiter bis jetzt wieder.
Ich glaube heute haben wir dann im Podcast einen kurzen.
Ton wo wir auch keinen direkten O-Ton von Scholz haben wo er sagt Jaja die Leute die über 100 000 Euro verdienen sie sollten mal mehr Spitzensteuersatz zahlen und denken ja es ist Wahlkampf das haben wir ja auch verstanden aber das zählt jetzt nicht.
So ein Punkt zu machen sondern da ist Kühnert auch eine tolle Szene wie Kühnert Bei Lauterbach sitzt und bei Lanz setzt diesmal und wechselt sich schon so oft wie Lauterbach bei Markus Lanz ist.
Er sitzt bei Markus Lanz und Markus Lanz quält ihn so mit diesem. Da weiß er auch wie man wie man so ein Gespräch dann führt.
Und kommt dann am Ende darauf zu sprechen Ja es jetzt bei G20 Polizeigewalt oder nicht. Ich denke das ist Jahre her.
Es ärgert auch den jungen Politiker nicht so aber Künast zeigt auf die Frage ein beginnt dann so ein Halbsatz mit Aber natürlich ändert das den zweiten Halbsatz ab und dann kommt ganz drauf.
Aber wie wäre der Satz Denn weitergegangen gerade so und ärgert einen so richtig wo man so richtig sieht in diesem Moment kommt dann auch Kevin Kühnert ins Schwitzen weil auch er nicht in der Lage ist unter einen Hut zu bringen.
Das sei natürlich gegen die Große Koalition und gegen Olaf Scholz gearbeitet hat und jetzt plötzlich jeden verteidigen muss.
Er fällt sozusagen wirklich ein Kartenhaus zusammen.
Sehr schön ist ein Begriff dabei den er verwendet. Konstruktive Kritik.
Das lässt mich doch als Literatur Liebhaber aufhorchen und vor allem als Literaturkritiker aufhorchen.
Das war immer das was Marcel Reich-Ranicki wirklich auf die Palme brachte wenn man mit konstruktiver Kritik kam nämlich das ganze geht zurück auf Goethe der hat das eingefordert in einem,
Text der heißt Grabkammern Jola noch einmal und wir hören da jetzt einen Auszug nicht von Goethe sondern von mir gelesen.
Es gibt eine zerstörende Kritik und eine produktive jene ist sehr leicht denn man darf sich nur irgend einen Maßstab irgend ein Muster Bild so borniert sie auch sein in Gedanken aufstellen.
Sodann aber Kühnl sich versichern vorliegendes Kunstwerk passe nicht dazu tauge deswegen nichts die Sache sei abgetan und man dürfe ohne weiteres seine Forderung als unbefriedigte erklären.
Und so befreit man sich von aller Dankbarkeit gegen den Künstler die produktive Kritik ist um ein gutes Teil schwerer.
Sie fragt Was hat sich der Autor vorgesetzt.
Ist dieser Vorsatz vernünftig und verständig. Und inwiefern ist es gelungen ihn auszuführen.
Werden diese Fragen einsichtig und liebevoll beantwortet,
so helfen wir dem Verfasser nach welcher bei seinen ersten Arbeiten gewiss schon Fortschritte getan und sich unserer Kritik entgegen gehoben hat.
Und so möchte doch eigentlich Kevin Kühnert jetzt dass wir liebevoll Olaf Scholz unter die Arme greifen ihm eine Hilfestellung bieten und dann produktiv konstruktiv vorangehen.
Und das ist eben das was Archangelsk immer sagte Nein.
Kritik muss nicht konstruktiv sein.
Dergestalt dass man jetzt versucht dem zu helfen der das fabriziert hat sondern die Kritik ist dazu da eben eine Außenpositionen zu formulieren.
Sie ist in erster Linie auch an das Publikum adressiert und nicht an denen jenigen der es geschaffen hat. Und natürlich gibt es diese und was er auch macht das ist auch wirklich exakt Goethe.
Dass er jetzt eben diesen SPD-Linken vorwirft sie hätten so ein Bild von der SPD das nicht unantastbar sie hätten da gewisse Dogmen.
Und genau das ist was Goethe jetzt eben Leuten vorwirft die nicht konstruktiv gehen mit Dogmen an Kunstwerk ran und wenn die denen nicht entsprechend dann machen sie eben ihre vernichtende Kritik und sind nicht produktiv.
Ja da gibt's eine sehr schöne Analogie die jeder schon mal erlebt hat wahrscheinlich nehme ich einfach aus einer ganz einfachen Erziehung.
Man unterscheidet ja sehr hart zwischen den eigenen Kindern und anderen Kindern.
Spielplatz Sonne und diese Form der konstruktiven Kritik gilt ja vor allem den eigenen Kindern.
Man will ja nicht nur wenn sie gerade lärmen. Abhilfe aus einer Situation die einen nervt sondern man will ihnen ja noch etwas mitgeben.
Also geht man besonders konstruktiv vor wenn andere Kinder ein bisschen nerven auf dem Spielplatz sind die Folgeschäden egal dann sorgt man einfach für Abhilfe und das Kind muss dann selber damit klarkommen mit dieser,
destruktiven Kritik sag noch so um die Unterscheidung beizubehalten und relativ früh stellt dann aber fest Diese destruktive Kritik von anderen,
ist gar nicht so schlecht für das Kind.
Manchmal muss man das Kind auch ein bisschen alleine lassen.
Völlig zu Recht. Und ehrlicherweise haben wir das in der Moderne auch institutionalisieren,
schicken nämlich die Kinder woanders hin wo sie von Erziehern erzogen werden die gerade nicht die eigenen Eltern sind also die ganze Zeit mit konstruktiver Kritik und so weiter weil diese Idee konstruktive und destruktive Kritik Die gibts wirklich nur im eigenen Kopf.
Kann Kevin Kühnert nicht für sich irgendwie klar Die kann er uns vorgaukeln aber das kann er nicht so benutzen weil wir jetzt jetzt muss es auch mal Districts,
kritisiert werden und sei es dass die SPD mit ihren 14 Prozent und dann das bayerische Modell unter 10 und dann einfach mal so ein bisschen verschwindet,
damit keine Ahnung die Lücke dann von Grünen Linken oder wie auch immer wer da ihm neu Partei neu entstehen kann haben wir ja gesehen.
Da braucht man jetzt nicht die allergrößte Angst haben wenn man sich das linke Spektrum anguckt da kann man durchaus mal neu gründen.
Da muss ich also dieser Moment in dem wir jetzt gerade sind in Deutschland mit der SPD da ist ja wirklich erschreckend.
Das muss man leider so sagen. Wirklich herunterbrechen kann auf die Figur Kevin Kühnert in der wir das alles ablesen und an der uns abarbeiten können.
In der Tat. Immerhin Er steht in Goethes Tradition aber in keiner guten Goethe Tradition Goethe ist mit Kritikern nie gut umgegangen.
Es gibt ein Gedicht von ihm Schlag den tot den Hund. Er ist ein Rezensent.
Goethe stelle ich mir vor wie so ein Lauterbach.
Könnte sein könnte sein.
Auch Artzt.
Wir wollen aber noch einen Kopf frei für Future uns anhören und zwar Jakob Blase der immer so ein bisschen im Schatten von Luisa Neubaur oder Clara steht er aber auch in Talkshows und so weiter vertreten ist.
Und der macht jetzt eigentlich auch ein bisschen den Kühnert der ist mal gerade 19 oder 20 Jahre alt und möchte jetzt für die Grünen in den Bundestag hat über Instagram wie sich das für junge Menschen gehört,
ein Video aufgenommen hat es dort gepostet und erzählt jetzt dort in furchtbarer Tonqualität und rhetorisch sicherlich Ausbau ausbaubar was er da vorhat.
Hi ich habe mich entschieden für den Bundestag zu kandidieren und ich möchte erklären warum das für mich der nächste notwendige und logische Schritt ist.
Ich glaube das ist auch eine riesige Chance um die Diskrepanz zwischen den Forderungen auf der Straße und den Forderungen im Parlament zu verringern.
Und offensichtlich können wir das offensichtlich kann ein Parlament das Altersdurchschnitt von 49 Jahren hat diese Interessen gar nicht widerspiegeln und will es auch nicht.
Deswegen muss diese Kandidatur grundsätzlich verändern wie Politik gemacht wird und das kann.
Das kann ich nicht alleine schaffen und das ist auch gar nicht mein Anspruch.
Deswegen müssen sich alle engagieren für diese Wahl und für den gesamten politischen Prozess darum und wie wir das alles schaffen wollen darüber möchte ich mit euch in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten diskutieren.
Deswegen wenn ihr Infotafel ihr fragen Habt ihr Ideen habt dann schreibt man einfach eine private Nachricht auf Facebook oder Instagram und ich versuche auf jeden einzugehen.
Das ist unsere letzte Chance. Wir haben die letzten vier Jahre erlebt Es waren die vier heißesten Jahre seit der Wetteraufzeichnungen und,
wir müssen immer wieder erleben schon heute überschritten werden und dass Menschen im globalen Süden ihr Zuhause verlieren.
Das ist die letzte Wahlperiode wo wir das Pariser Klimaabkommen noch umsetzen können.
Und deswegen brauchen wir einen Platz am Verhandlungstisch.
Wir haben eigentlich nichts mehr zu verlieren aushalte unsere Zukunft und über die entscheiden wir selbst.
Ja was soll man sagen. Ihm fehlen jetzt schon die Worte.
Ja er ist eigentlich jetzt schon desillusioniert Es klingt ein bisschen so als hätte er 30 Jahre Politik hinter sich. Es hätte alles nichts gebracht.
Ich glaube auch ehrlich gesagt dieser Rhetorik nicht wenn man sagt Das ist unsere letzte Chance.
Dann sage ich nicht Ach ich glaub ich kandidiere mal geh mal gucken ob ich am Verhandlungstisch mit den Grünen zusammen Platz nehmen kann.
Selbst wenn die Grünen eine absolute Mehrheit in Deutschland bekämen.
Wenn man sagt das wäre jetzt die letzte Chance und wenn man diese Dramatik wirklich mal beim Wort nimmt dann müsste man ja sagen dann sind die Grünen ja weit davon entfernt genau das zu machen was nötig wäre um diese letzte Chance zu ergreifen.
Das heißt man muss aufpassen wenn man diese Rhetorik bedient dass man dann,
irgendwann so abgenutzt hat dass man die letzte Chance ist so wie wenn Politiker laufend sagen Ja ich muss noch mal Bürokratieabbau da lacht ja auch jeder.
Wenn so ein Satz kommt dann so eine Floskel werden und ich glaube dass es für ihn eine Möglichkeit ist eine politische Karriere zu beginnen.
Aber es ist denke ich auch klar dass da jetzt bei rauskommt beziehungsweise der Rebellentum.
Ich glaube hier gibt's eigentlich schon dass sofort das Anschmiegen an den Apparat.
Ja es gibt wie soll man sagen wenn man zu viel Soziologie Kram liest,
dann kommt man ja so langsam irgendwie drauf dass es vielleicht stimmt wenn der Luhmann sagt Inhalte in der Politik gar nicht so entscheiden nicht einmal für den Wähler.
Also man geht eigentlich sehr selten in eine Wahlkabine und wählt dann aus inhaltlichen Gründen die man sich selber gut erklären kann oder anderen sondern anders bedient.
Donald Trump hat wieder ganz wunderbar kein Parteiprogramm nichts. Er dreht einfach nur anmelde.
Ich nehme euch die Angst die ich euch geschürt habe. Und es ist auch völlig auf dieser emotionalen Ebene und es funktioniert dann anscheinend immer noch bei 43 Prozent der Amerikaner keine Ahnung und man braucht.
Inhalte werden überschätzt. Die Frage ist worum gehts dann in der Politik und nach meiner Erfahrung jetzt auch so mal was weiß ich Elternbeiräte Vereinsleben. Dieser ganze Kram irgendwie.
Es gibt einfach Menschen die können gut mit anderen Menschen selbst wenn sie eigentlich im Widerspruch sind oder so. So Vermittlerrolle oder keine Ahnung.
Das kennt jeder so aus den Stammtischen der eigenen Oma oder so.
Es gibt immer so die paar Personen die haben es irgendwie drauf dass die Stimmung besser wenn sie anwesend sind wenn es am Anfang heiß ist heute leider krank ist Stimmung Tod und so.
Es gibt gibts ein paar Leute die können einfach aus so einer völlig befreiten.
Die können einfach für gute Stimmung sorgen und am Ende kommt doch was bei rum und so.
Und solche Leute braucht man eigentlich eine Politik dass man inhaltlich aus inhaltlichen Gründen ist es gibt für mich eigentlich nur ein Beispiel das jemand wirklich aus inhaltlichen Gründen und das dann auch eiskalt durchgezogen hat am Ende dann trotzdem gescheitert ist.
Eine Sahra Wagenknecht kann aber auch gut reden ich stand auf einer Bühne die stets auf der Bühne und es ist sehr abgedroschen das Wort aber die rockt halt einfach ja die macht halt nur die Macht halt Programm auf der Bühne.
Die wäre mir ja auch gleich eingefallen.
Ist ja abgedroschene geworden aber die rockt einfach Handy-Markt halten und,
und das Erstaunliche bei ihr. Ich hab diese Doku über sie gesehen die jetzt nicht so überragend besser aber doch ganz erstaunlich ist.
Sie hat ja extrem viele Fans richtig. Also wenn Sie dann die Bühne verlässt dann sind da auch ganz viele junge Männer die sie einfach großartig finden und was sie aber nicht tut.
Nähe. Sie macht nicht anfassen sie macht nicht Gerhard Schröder Kurt Beck mäßig.
Ich umarme Euch mal sondern gerade diese Distanz die sie ausstrahlt sorgt dafür dass sie ganz fasziniert sind aber auch gebotenen Abstand wiederum halten denn sie wollen eigentlich.
Sie sind nah dran Ich glaube es ist bei manchen wirklich auch schon fast so ein erotisches Verhältnis das sich da entwickelt.
Aber es bleibt ohne ebenso eine Anbiederung.
Irgendwann kam er dann mal raus dass sie mit Oskar Lafontaine zusammen ist habe ich auch so gedacht.
Aber sie ist ja schon so eine Politikerin wo viele und wir haben hier Spaß Podcasts können wir auch über diesen körperlichen Aspekt reden.
Sie ist ja schon von so einer Gestalt die grundsätzlich als attraktiv gilt.
Und sie sucht sich dann aber so einen alten Knacker als Lebensgefährten fragt man sich ja,
bis dahin schlägt sich durch ja dass sie sagt Ich nehme nicht irgendeinen Mann sondern mein Mann der musste mit 15 Jahren Bürgermeister werden und mit 23 Ministerpräsident und dann eine eigene Partei gründen und einmal den Finanzminister Posten räumen,
ich raus stürmen dann ist er so qualifiziert und das schlägt sich so auf allen Ebenen irgendwie durch.
Und ich finde da geht's aber das ist wirklich so selten. Und wenn ich hier bin. Es ist halt leider dieses Gestammel.
Wir haben alle diese Bücher gelesen die er gelesen hat und es ist ein bisschen so ein Politiker braucht auch so ein bisschen Zauber der kann nicht einfach kommen.
Also ich bin genauso besorgt wie er.
Er hat mich erst mal tief Durchwahl Ich finde es auch so krass wie ihr und das können wir nur gemeinsam und.
Schreibt man mal direkt nach.
Gib mir mal Input weil ich bin jetzt schon ausgedünnt Ja ich weiß jetzt schon nicht was ich sagen soll wenn ich dann am Tisch Platz nehme und es geht nicht.
Ja ich bin jetzt schon ausgedünnt. Ich weiß nicht was ich.
Wir haben aus guten Gründen so Nachwuchsorganisation wo man auch schon mal mit 16 Jahren eine Rede halten muss die länger als fünf Minuten auf einer Bühne und sich da bewähren muss und so weiter und es ist vielleicht nicht das Schlechteste.
Aus guten Gründen Organisation auch schon mal mit 16 Jahren Rede halten muss.
Mich wundert das auch Vergleiche mit Leuten von der Grünen Jugend oder auch mit Jusos oder so.
Ja durchaus Kontakt habe und reden ein bisschen anders aber naja die werden aber dann vielleicht keine richtigen Persönlichkeiten in der Partei sind die dann zu kritisch.
Wir lassen noch einmal Hajo Schumacher zu Wort kommen denn wir haben ja noch eine zweite Möglichkeit wenn man nicht diesen parlamentarischen Weg gehen möchte dann gibt es den anderen Weg der weniger.
Dann gibt's den anderen Weg das ist der weniger amtliche Lehrer der harte wütende radikale Prozess.
Radikal ist nicht ohne Konsequenzen sondern sich auch nicht von der Kanzlerin.
Der Protest der nicht auf Konsequenzen guckt sondern sich auch nicht von Talkshows und Kanzlerin einfangen lässt sondern einfach wuchtig wütend ist und der einzige.
Die einzige die zum Handeln auch wirklich bereit sind Opfer zu bringen.
Weg den die Politik wirklich zum Handeln braucht nämlich Angst Angst vor Bürgern die es wirklich ernst meinen bereit sind für ihre Ziele Opfer zu bringen.
Diesen Eindruck hat Frau des Vorfluter nicht so richtig erzeugt ist auch ein bisschen schwer so in satten Wohlstands Demokratie.
Diesen Eindruck so richtig erzeugen ist auch ein bisschen schwer.
Demokratie muss so richtig Beispiel aufragende sind.
Da muss es vielleicht wirklich so richtig doll mies laufen wie derzeit in Belarus zum Beispiel.
Was wir hier Auffahren das sind halt eher so Simulationen von Protesten das übliche Instagram Feelgood Zeug fürs Gewissen halt schade für Greta.
Aber auch den Klimawandel über die nächste Generation.
Aber auf den Klimawandel ist Verlass er wird die nächste Generation protestierender Kids hervorbringen und die werden sich vielleicht nicht so schnell von den Haien einwickeln lassen.
Vielleicht nicht so schnell von Leben lassen.
Asylrecht.
Absolut und weißt du an was mich erinnert an das Ende der eindimensionale Mensch von Herbert Marcuse.
Dort geht es auch darum Wie kann Aktivismus aussehen und Herbert Marcuse sieht er auch im Wohlstands Westen wenig Möglichkeiten blickt aber dann in andere Teile der Welt und blickt auch auf so etwas was Hajo Schumacher da geschildert hat.
Aber der Kampf um die Lösung ist über die traditionellen Formen hinausgewachsen.
Die totalitären Tendenzen der eindimensionalen Gesellschaft machen die traditionellen Mittel und Wege des Protests unwirksam,
vielleicht sogar gefährlich weil sie an der Illusion der Volkssouveränität festhalten.
Unter der konservativen folks Basis befindet sich jedoch das Substrat der geächteten und Außenseiter die Ausgebeuteten und Verfolgten anderer Rassen und anderer Farben.
Die Arbeitslosen und die arbeitsunfähig.
Sie existieren außerhalb des demokratischen Prozesses.
Ihr Leben bedarf am unmittelbarsten und Realisten der Abschaffung unerträglicher Verhältnisse und Institutionen.
Damit ist ihre Opposition revolutionär wenn auch nicht ihr Bewusstsein.
Ihre Opposition trifft das System von außen und wird deshalb nicht durch das System abgelenkt.
Sie ist eine elementare Kraft die die Regeln des Spiels verletzt und ist damit als ein aufgetankt altes Spiel enthüllt.
Aber das ist nichts als eine Chance die Kritische Theorie der Gesellschaft besitzt keine Begriffe die die Kluft zwischen dem gegenwärtigen und seiner Zukunft überbrücken könnten,
indem sie nichts verspricht und keinen Erfolg zeigt bleibt sie negativ.
Damit will sie jenen die Treue halten die ohne Hoffnung ihr Leben der großen Weigerung hingegeben haben und hingeben.
Nochmal pathetisch zum Ende die Große Weigerung wirklich zu sagen nee wir reden jetzt nicht miteinander.
Ich komme nicht aufs Podium Ich komme nicht ins Kanzleramt.
Das ist etwas was er jetzt aber kanalisiert outsourcen zurast könnte man auch sagen.
Er blickt da auf andere Völker.
Man muss sagen dass sein Text in den Sechzigerjahren entsteht.
Da passiert dann eben auch in den antikolonialen Bewegungen ganz ganz viel.
Das ist vielleicht mal nicht so leicht zu übertragen aber zugleich ja auch plausibel angesprochen haben wir es ja,
mit entsprechenden Klimaveränderungen im globalen Süden zu tun die ganz ganz erheblich sind und wo Menschen in ihrer Existenz direkt bedroht sind wo es nicht nur darum geht dass man sich eine zweite Klimaanlage wohl leisten muss weil der Sommer wieder so heiß war.
Das heißt Von dort aus kann das natürlich ein ganz neues rebellisches Potenzial geben,
die Flüchtlinge Klimaflüchtlinge werden ja auch ein ganz großes Thema werden ob daraus dann eine progressive Entwicklung wird das sagt Herr Marcuse ja auch noch einmal sehr schön dass ihr Handeln zwar revolutionär ist aber ihr Bewusstsein nicht das ist ja eben auch der.
Fall jetzt zum Beispiel auch bei den Flüchtlingen die nach Deutschland gekommen sind.
Das ist hier ja keineswegs sich um revolutionäre Subjekte in dem Sinne handelt dass die jetzt irgendwie den Klassenkampf oder so beginnen.
Das ist ja manchmal so die Illusion der Linken dass man das immer sofort glaubt aber in Wahrheit waren sie dann einfach froh hier zu sein und sind jetzt nicht in erster Linie daran interessiert hier die Linke zum Leben zu erwecken.
Vielleicht gibt es ja für die Freiheit im Sinne von Hajo Schumacher eine Rettung wie wir das Internet lernen.
Die Zukunft ist schon da nur noch. Es vergeht nur noch Zeit bis sie da ist und man kann das vielleicht auch verändern.
Es gab ja jetzt am Wochenende in Berlin diese große I-Mode von den ganzen Neurechten.
Und gleichzeitig gab es ja noch andere Nachrichten aus Berlin nämlich dass die Friedrichstraße jetzt für Autos gesperrt ist und da lauter Bäume aufgestellt wurden. Da habe ich mich gefragt.
Das ist eine tolle Sache das kriegt man bundesweit mit. Aber wer holt sich denn dafür jetzt den Ruhm.
Niemand. Man hat einfach nur Bilder gesehen von Leuten die völlig vorbei Bäume.
Solche Sachen sind gibt's ja nicht freies Berlin die dann einfach frühzeitig sagen kein tolles Anliegen unterstützen wir damit wir danach wenn es diese Party wie wir jetzt hier zur Eröffnung feiern.
Das ist auch sozusagen das einheimst eines Erfolgs der vielleicht gar nicht so sehr von freilich verführte Anhängern abhängt aber denen man dann trotzdem einstreichen kann dann kann man da nicht auch ein bisschen so politisch kalkulatorische.
Man sieht ja jetzt wie wichtig zahlen. bei Coruna sind und so weiter.
Kann man da nicht einfach Lebenszufriedenheit beziffern von Anwohnern an der Friedrichstraße oder denen man beobachtet wie So jetzt der Einzelhandel da aufblühen wenn da plötzlich die Leute nicht mehr vorbeirasen sondern einfach zu Fuß unterwegs sind und,
warum da so wenig strategisch im lokalen,
gemacht wird das verstehe ich nicht warum man das so links liegen lässt immer dieses Mega große,
globale Argument Im Grunde machen ja die kleinen Sachen dann immer vergessen denn ich meine,
diese Aufklärungs Schiene ist ja nicht ganz verkehrt.
Von der Hitzewelle 2018 in Japan eine Ausarbeitungen bekommen.
Da gab es damals tausend Todesopfer und Zehntausende im Krankenhaus haben ein echtes medizinisches Problem eigentlich.
Es war ja nicht nur so ein Klima ist ja nun durch Erhitzen sind ja nun mal länderübergreifend und haben die erste Studie die eindeutig nachweist dass das Klimawandel war das ist nicht ohne den menschengemachten Klimawandel nötig möglich wäre.
Und wir haben da nichts zu Olympia. Solche Sachen. Rico Grimm hat auf Twitter mal so einen kleinen Ronda gemacht jetzt im August im Amazonas wissen alle noch letztes Jahr,
haben wir uns ja sehr beschwert dass Botsuana oder alles abfackeln da gibts ein Drittel mehr Brände als letztes Jahr und es wird gar nicht groß thematisiert war ja irgendwie schon eingepreist.
Alte nachrichten.at in Spanien in San Sebastián hat man jetzt erstmals 42 Grad gemessen das gabs in Nordspanien noch nie.
Man kennt das aus dem Süden mit 45 Grad. Bagdad hat mal wieder ein 50 Grad Sommer erlebt Waldbrände in Kalifornien wie nie zuvor.
Selbst in Argentinien gibt es gigantische Brände und Hochwasser in China.
Woran liegt es dass diese Region gerade in Nachrichtenquelle alles überflutet ist.
SPIEGEL ONLINE Hat jemand einen Fachartikel vom August referiert.
Der IPCC hat 2005 verschiedene Szenarien entwickelt,
wie das so weitergeht mit der CO2-Konzentration und die tatsächliche Entwicklung in den letzten 15 Jahren liegt ein Prozent mit einer ein Prozent Abweichung an dem krassesten Modell das damals entwickelt wurde.
Das ist ganz anders. Korona ist ja wieder so ein Ding wo großer Stress und dann na gut vielleicht doch nicht so schlimm.
Bei Klimas genau umgedreht. Da machen alle schon Stress. Aber es ist dann nochmal schlimmer als man dachte es geht ja nur sehr viel langsamer.
Aber wenn diese Zahlen die sich jetzt gerade bestätigen das ist eben nicht eine Modellrechnung sondern man echt nachgemessen.
Wenn das so weitergeht dann ist Jahresende 3,4 Grad Durchschnittstemperatur Erhebung was halt wirklich bedeutet keine Permafrost mehr.
Und dann frieren halt wirklich die alten Berge auf.
Die bestehen überhaupt nur weil die vom Permafrost zusammengehalten werden und dann rutscht ganz österreich einmal in sich zusammen.
Kann man sich noch nicht ganz vorstellen aber das ist halt das was jetzt ansteht.
Und ich glaube auch da gibts noch einige politische Argumente zu machen die im Sinne von Hajo Schumacher nicht so sehr auf den Einsatz im Bundestag abzielen sondern die einfach wütend.
Wir haben jetzt gesehen wie viel Wut vom Bundestag wohin das führen kann.
Da ist doch noch einiges Potenzial das irgendwie schon ausgeschöpft ist.
Ich glaube es sind diese faktischen Auswirkungen die sehr viel bewegen können wir haben das ja bei Coruna gesehen dass wir auch von Bildern stark geprägt waren die unser Handeln sofort verändert haben.
Das Problem ist natürlich wenn jetzt wie jetzt mit dem brasilianischen Urwald dass die Bilder dann nicht präsent sind in den Medien dass wir da unsere Aufmerksamkeit gar nicht darauf richten.
Ich glaube was wir momentan nicht so stark forcieren müssen oder was die Futuro nicht so stark forcieren sollten ist diese ständige Berechnung vom Weltklimarat und sonst was jetzt schon zu viel Emissionen und Krad und hin und her.
Dieses Wissen ist an sich bekannt dass es jetzt irgendwelche Detailfragen kann man dann noch die Aufklärung.
Es gibt in diesem angesprochenen Buch Losing ganz erstaunliche an die Anekdote.
Da geht es darum dass 1981/82 Anhörungen im Kongress stattfanden zum Thema Klimawandel und man hoffte dann damit irgendwie auch mal die Abendnachrichten zu kommen.
Und das Erstaunliche ist dass man dann nach einigen Sitzungen einen Republikaner zu Wort kommen ließ der dann sagte er hätte sich das alles angehört.
Es wäre jetzt mal gut wir wissen jetzt genug darüber um zu wissen Es ist eine Katastrophe die auf uns zukommt.
Jetzt hören wir mal auf mit diesen ständigen Anhörungen von Emissionen und all das.
Wir müssen jetzt handeln und das sagt 1981 und jetzt ist noch immer eigentlich nur der Modus Ach ja wir lassen uns mal nochmal von irgendeinem Experten erzählen was in 15 Jahren so kommen könnte.
Und dann sagt man nochmal ja da müssten wir auch bald mal was tun. Aber der sagt 82 schon Wir brauchen jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr ständig die Fakten sagen die Experten zu den Experten zurück.
Wir müssen jetzt politisch handeln ist aber nicht geschehen.
Es ist ein bisschen wie bei Crooner wo sich die Politik immer nur Wir haben morgen noch mal eine Sitzung mit den Virologen also morgen haben wir nochmal eine Sitzung und dann morgen haben die Virologen so ja sie müssen jetzt auch mal was entscheiden,
hier noch drei Jahre was erzählen aber sie müssen jetzt mal schreiben denn so hat man es wieder.
Es ist halt grundsätzlich die große Herausforderung ein Thema zu haben das halt nicht so einfach runter gebrochen werden kann aber ich glaube genau das ist die Herausforderung es dann tatsächlich herunterzubrechen.
Beispielsweise sollte das Umweltbundesamt das Umweltministerium keine Ahnung wer auch immer irgendeine Behörde wird sich schon finden dort führen über Tote.
Es gab ja wieder Hitzetod und wir kennen aus Frankreich diese Zahlen mit 110 000 Hitzetod pro Jahr.
Und wir haben die Berechnungen dieses Jahr der erste Kongress aus wenn er nächstes Jahr stattfindet wollen wir als Thema mal Hitze nehmen um Hitze auch als Krankheit Gehzeit nicht aber Hitze als Ursache.
Und man kann das volkswirtschaftlich durchrechnen was drei Wochen Sahara Hitze in Europa bedeuten nämlich so viel Es ist quasi wie ein Lottogewinn.
Leute arbeiten dann sind einfach nicht produktiv stehen morgens aufstöhnen und tun alle Gelenke weh und so weiter.
Das kann man ja alles mal kalkulieren.
Vielleicht Disentis Future dann auch mal ein bisschen helfen bei solchen Sachen.
Aber da ist doch sehr viel Potenzial das Potenzial der ein oder andere in den Bundestag will schön und gut.
So ein großes Thema im August war ja auch die amerikanische Wahl die ansteht im November.
Und ich habe einen sehr langen run down über das eine oder andere was jetzt im August passiert ist.
Fangen wir mal an bei Joe Biden. Seine größte Herausforderung ist nicht zu präsidial zu wirken.
Die Wähler deren interne Kommunikation worauf Joe Biden achten soll die Wähler müssen verstehen dass du der Herausforderer bist und Trump der Präsident damit sie die Verantwortung für ihren Lebens. Zustand gerade richtig zu rechnen können.
Ja.
Das ist die größte Herausforderung der beiden Kampagne da sie nicht dass sie nicht,
Trump in die Falle gehen dass Trump weiterhin gegen Joe Biden im übermächtigen Washington die das amerikanische Volk verteidigt sondern dass man es jetzt umdreht.
Joe Biden soll darstellen. Die Angst die Donald Trump schürt die hat er bei euch hervorgerufen.
Er ist für das verantwortlich was jetzt passiert auch wenn die Städte unsicher sind.
Er ist der Präsident nicht weil ich irgendwie super das mal so zu sehen.
Aber NBC News weist darauf hin Es wäre durchaus rechnerisch möglich.
Es liegt dann an Kalifornien und Texas dass Joe Biden mit fünf Millionen Stimmen Vorsprung im Popular verliert.
Clinton hat es ja schon auf dreieinhalb gebracht wegen Kalifornien Texas kippelt ja so ein bisschen aber wenn die Swing States nicht mitziehen da kommt es dann sehr auf den Wahlkampf an wo man den dann am Ende für,
Texas tatsächlich demokratisch wählt könnte es durchaus sein dass mit Kalifornien und Texas,
ist egal wie viele in Texas wählen wenn es einmal gekippt ist kann es durchaus sein dass es fünf Millionen Stimmen Unterschiede gibt und trotzdem Donald Trump Präsident bleibt.
Es waren jedenfalls die beiden großen Parteitage darüber muss man nichts.
Ausgemachte Sache oder das gewinnt.
Dewinter.
Ich wage mich hier nicht so weit vor und bitte auch dann im November nochmal hier rein zu hören was ich damals gesagt habe dass ich mich jetzt hier nicht festlege.
Weiterhin ein Szenario wie es gelingen soll für Trump,
deswegen.
Gut dass wir es nochmal hier fest haben.
Die Parteitage fanden ja statt und man muss im Grunde nicht viel darüber wissen wir noch mal einen Clip von Michelle Obama der aus stilistischen Gründen ganz ist aber Trevor Noah hat die,
Republican National Dingsbums mal ganz wunderbar in seinem ganz kurzen zusammengefasst.
If you get Selected.
Città Suburbs Church schon als eine Kopie von The Police Schulheft Prison.
Kämper.
Business School Nause Around the streets das,
Original ist,
ernst. Ein Giorno.
Die Republikaner haben kein Programm aber für jeden inhaltlichen Punkt den sie machen widersprechen sie sich genau einmal komplett selbst.
Man hat ja auch sehr schön gesehen dass sie sogar das Ehepaar nochmal akquiriert haben. Dieses verrückte das mit Sturmgewehr und Pistole gegen Black Lives Matter auf die Straße gingen.
Und das ist ja sowas von kurios weil sie auch nochmal ganz deutlich machen. Black Lives Matter das sind Marxisten das sagen sie an diesem Video ist es absurd.
Sollen wir den Bogen mal auf denn ja es wird ein neuer Präsident gewählt.
Aber es gibt schon sehr mächtige Menschen in Amerika denen es auch völlig egal wer regiert.
Das sind die ganzen Silicon Valley Milliardäre und da gab es doch ein paar interessante grundsätzlich Digital News.
Z.B. Eigentlich ganz unscheinbar aber es ist nicht ganz uninteressant bei Hacker News das ist so eine Seite die listet so,
attraktive Texte die von vielen als attraktiv gelten so eine Hacker hat einen Text relativ lange nach oben geschafft mit der überschrift,
produktive Fragezeichen maybe you stop thinking.
Denkt doch nicht so viel Nachtmensch macht doch lieber fanden sehr viele von diesen Hackern ziemlich toll und dann stellte sich heraus Ja da hat jemand einen Spaß erlaubt und hat seine Texte Generator künstliche Intelligenz losgeschickt diesen Text zu schreiben.
Dann alle Hacker mal vorgeführt mit einer Maschine Text der den Menschen empfiehlt doch nicht so viel nachzudenken.
Also so weit geht's. Große Nachrichten aus England.
Sowohl das Abitur als auch die mittlere Reife also das Level und das Gisi das die Mittlere Reife wurden jetzt in einem U-Turn.
Man hat von heute auf morgen entschieden wenn man es jetzt ganz anders Teacher gemacht.
Fragt man sich wie kommen die Noten nicht vom Lehrer Nee die Noten kamen nicht vom Lehrer sondern es gibt tatsächlich einen Algorithmus der Firma Q.
Wie Qual geschrieben auf deutsch. Irgendwie kann der verwirrte plötzlich nachdem man die Noten ausspuckte 40 Prozent aller Abiturienten und Mittlerer Reife den Schritt,
auf die Universität Man hat man festgestellt der Algorithmus funktioniert irgendwie nicht und die Standardisierung ging über das ganze Land spannen und hat dann festgestellt,
Wir müssen wir wieder zurück Die Lehrer müssen entscheiden weil der Algorithmus hat dann plötzlich für Prüfungen Noten ausgespuckt bei einzelnen Schülern die gar nicht belegt worden und so mega digitales durcheinander was Thema Bildung und so,
gab es auch eine sehr lustige Szene wie,
Boris Johnson in einer Schule auftrat vor Schülern und die Lehrer im Hintergrund noch Buchtitel entsprechend ins Regal stellten um eine Botschaft mitzugeben.
Naja Instagram wird gerade verklagt weil sie nämlich die biometrische Daten z.B. für diese Gesichtsmasken die man so in der Story unterbringen kann.
Haben Sie einfach verarbeitet die Biometrie Daten der Gesichter und nirgendwo die nirgendwo geschrieben und jetzt gibts Milliarden Betroffene und entsprechende Gesetze die dann sagen Ja das sind pro Person tausend Dollar und so.
Haben sie sich echt was ausdenken wie sie sie da wieder rauskommen weil der Rechtstexte einfach so eindeutig ist und auch nicht zu übersehen ist natürlich die Kandidaturen von Olaf Scholz und Pamela Harris wurden auf Twitter bekannt gegeben als Allererstes.
Die SPD hat jetzt einen riesigen jetzt ist es raus. Olaf Scholz hat es auch auf Twitter geschrieben bevor dann die mediale Welle losging.
Bei Olaf Scholz war er sogar ganz witzig. Mein erstes Sommerinterview abgewartet hat lava lava lava und zack Unser Kandidat ist übrigens Olaf Scholz auf Twitter.
Es ist gar nicht so schlecht Bernie Sanders.
Die SPD ist jetzt bei Telegram offenbar. Es gibt ein Video von einem jungen Menschen in einem Hemd und erinnert ein bisschen an Achim aus der CSU.
Aber das habe ich gesehen dieses Video habe ich im schwarz weißen Hemd.
Das ist wirklich peinlich das ist unglaublich.
Es ist ganz gruselig.
Und richtet sich an die junge Community damit man kann bei der Reise jetzt,
ihre Sommerreise da kann man mit dabei sein und dann wird noch einmal aufgerufen weil man sich an ein junges Publikum wendet an was das erinnern soll.
Ja wir haben die Bilder ja nicht vergessen von Gerhard Schröder und dann wird sogar noch von Helmut Schmidt am Brahmsee oder was gesprochen.
Ich dachte Na ja wer soll das noch wissen.
Es ist traurig auch traurig ist dass ein Gesetz nicht kommt nämlich das von Bernie Sanders hat eine one time Text vorgestellt die ganz auf Crone abzielt und zwar soll bei jedem Milliardär.
Auch traurig ist dass ein Gesetz nicht kommen nämlich das von Bernie Sanders.
Er hat mir einen Text vorgestellt die ganz auf Kohle abzielt und zwar soll bei jedem Milliardär der Wertzuwachs zwischen 18.
Der Wertzuwachs zwischen 18.
März 2020 und 1.
Januar 2021 mit 60 Prozent besteuert werden im Wertzuwachs und nur von Corona locker bis nächstes Jahr sollen es das Duo kurz raten.
Januar 2021 mit 60 Prozent besteuert werden.
Es gibt ja nur von locker bis nächstes Jahr soll es.
Auf wie viel summiert sich mittlerweile wenn's so einen Text gäbe der die Abgabenlast von Jeff Basars.
Auch nicht viel summiert sich mittlerweile wenns ohne Text gäbe die Abgabenlast von Cheb Basis also nur der Wertzuwachs während Coruna Jahren werden das wohl 60 Prozent.
Nur der Wertzuwachs während Coruña wie viele Milliarden wären das wohl wenn man nur 60 Prozent wegnimmt richtig zwei und vierzig komma acht Milliarden Dollar 30 Milliarden.
Ich hätte jetzt 30 Milliarden gesagt.
Es ist unglaublich dass es alleine 60 Prozent Wertzuwachs seit März summiert sich auf 42 mehr.
Naja so gesehen wo die Aktie steht. Die Aktie stand heute Morgen glaube ich.
Als.
Ich habe gestern ich geguckt bei 2800 Euro stand die Aktie ist runtergefallen als der lock down kam mal ganz kurz auf 1500 1600 war dann bei 2200.
2000.
Runtergefallen,
bei,
2200 und dann schon wieder.
Und dann gab es schon wieder so Kommentare überhitzt sollte man auf keinen Fall zusteigen so wie das.
Jetzt ist sie inzwischen bei 2800. Wir haben ja bei Tesla bald dass die gesplittet wird.
2800.
Epple.
Apple wurde jetzt gesplittet muss man vielleicht sagen Man kann Aktien splitten wenn sie zu teuer sind.
Zum Beispiel könnte jetzt Jeff Bezos sagen Okay eine Aktie ist zu teuer das heißt für Kleinanleger zum Beispiel ist es dann schwierig,
einzusteigen weil man gleich für eine Aktie 2800 Euro ausgeben muss also man macht aus einer Aktie fünf Aktien und dann kostet die Aktie jetzt,
600 Euro und in der Regel werden es gibt eine ganz berühmte Aktie die nicht gesplittet wird.
Soweit ich weiß von Berkshire Hathaway.
100 000 Dollar oder so.
Genau die kostet 200 000 Dollar oder was von Warren Buffett Man kann dann Anteile daran aber trotzdem kaufen aber die ist nie gesplittet worden.
Ja das ist ganz interessant. Es gibt nämlich auch Veränderungen im Dow Jones.
Da ist nämlich Exxon Mobil rausgeflogen im August weil Apple die Aktien gesplittet hat.
Da wird nämlich der Wert der Anteil des Unternehmens im Index wird nach Aktienpreis und nicht nach Marktkapitalisierung gewichtet.
Jetzt hat Apple den gedrittelt. Jetzt gibt's für jede Aktie drei Aktien und dadurch sind sie in der Bedeutung gesunken weshalb,
ein anderes Technologieunternehmen Aufstieg so sehr politisch geregelt aber trotzdem ganz witzig dass jetzt Salesforce aufgestiegen ist und ExxonMobil,
als der Große.
Die waren ja wirklich rausgeflogen.
Ganz beeindruckend Disney Quartalsverlust 4,7 Milliarden durch Kronach keine Freizeitparks keine Kinos und nichts. Einfach komplett rausgeschmissen.
Naja Schwenker mal ein Facebook hat Compact von einer Seite geschmissen wir verbieten Organisationen und Personen unsere Dienste zu nutzen wenn sie Menschen aufgrund von Merkmalen wie Herkunft Geschlecht und Nationalität systematisch angreifen.
Das gilt natürlich insbesondere für Handlanger Publikationen der AfD.
Jürgen Elsässer und der ganze Kram und Casey Newton hat nochmal aufgeschlüsselt Facebook hat einen großen Coup Cragg down gemacht der vielleicht zu spät kam.
Das ist so schon ein paar Mal hier behandeltes dieser tolle Autor mit einem täglichen Newsletter.
Es geht um 800 Seiten. Wir lesen im Salon ausführlichen für einen Text wo man das mal so richtig auf. Um was es da geht.
1500 qm bezogene Werbung. Da steckt viel Geld dahinter.
Für einen Anhänger irgendwie macht und es gibt eine Reichweiten Begrenzung. Da müsste man auch mal gucken was das genau bedeutet.
Man hat 10000 Instagram Seiten mit Inhalt und 2000 Facebook-Gruppen nicht ganz gelöscht aber in der Reichweite beschränkt sich die Taucher nicht mehr in Empfehlungen auf.
In der Hinsicht aber ist es nicht schon zu spät sind an den Seiten nicht schon zu unabhängig im Sinne von auf eigener Domain eigenes Web Forum Keine Ahnung das man immer eine eigene Präsenz schafft.
Da spricht er was sehr sehr Wahres an denn das kann man ja beobachten Es sind ja auch sehr viele neue Rechte von YouTube entfernt worden jetzt aus deutschland oder österreich und die sind jetzt auf anderen Kanälen,
aktiv auch manche die ich noch gar nicht gehört habe Messenger-App Kanäle aber auch Plattformen für Videos oder Podcasts und solche Dinge.
Man kann doch sehen dass sie offenbar im Mainstream Plattformen wie YouTube und Facebook und Twitter geschafft haben genügend Leute hinter sich zu sammeln die jetzt sehr schnell sich weitersagen wo die jetzt zu finden sind auch diese ganzen.
Ableger die es alle gibt wo man sehr sehr präsent ist wo man solche Open Space Räume macht wo man sagt Hier ist keine Grenze KaZaA,
einlädt und ich glaube wir haben ja eine extreme Monopol Entwicklung Wir kommen ja auch dann noch zu zahlen.
Aber was man sagen kann Es gibt noch so einen neuen Unique Selling Point kann man zwar nicht nennen aber doch eine neue Marktlücke Das ist nämlich genau diese dass man sagt wir lassen alles zu.
Und damit kann man sich sehr viel Raum im Netz gerade verschaffen und das ist im übrigen etwas was Martin Sellner der,
von der Identitären Bewegung in Wien genau so schildert in seinem Buch Identitäre von 2016 ist.
Da gibt es am Ende einen Ausblick wie wird österreich 2032 sein.
Und das ist wirklich ganz furchtbar was er da schreibt aber er hat doch keine Ahnung von der Digitalisierung aber was er doch dort ausmacht ist dass sich Plattformen bilden werden die unabhängig sind von der,
vom Silicon Valley und der,
Liberalen öffentlichkeit und so weiter.
Das ist etwas was er dort schon ausmalte und was wir jetzt gerade erleben.
Wir hatten ja in deiner Region da oben schon am Main dass sich am Rhein das sich ein rechtes Ehepaar einen alten Bunker gekauft hat um so ein Datencenter zu betreiben.
Und dann kam auch die Polizei nicht mehr rein und man konnte nur noch den Strom abschalten und wir sehen ja Christ Church und hãlle.
Die haben dann zwar auf Facebook gestreamt aber die Radikalisierung lief komplett über Ford-Chef und der ganze Kram der da komplett unabhängig schon funktioniert,
hat da wohl recht und man darf nicht überschätzen. Es fanden jetzt in Amerika die Vorwahlen statt und die Republikaner müssen jetzt im November nicht nur mit Trump antreten sondern auch den Kongress und Senat die Wähler ein bisschen überzeugen.
Und da gab es doch diese kleine erschreckende Meldung hier.
Peking.
Die werden hier.
So funktioniert halt. Das ging mit mir auch schon mal so los dass es jetzt hier,
in Google den höre ich seit Jahren im Podcast weil die da einfach nur so rum lachen aber das wird da solche Sachen die man als dort elf in elf republikanischen Vorwahlen haben sich offene,
Anhänger durchgesetzt in den Vorwahlen.
Das kannten wir schon mal von der Tea Party dass sie dann auch die Partei übernommen haben und Trump distanziert sich auch nicht an Sonne sondern geht halt voll auf diese Linie ein.
Gegen da war ja die Tea Party. Leute waren ja dagegen sachlich und vernünftig.
Also reden wir im Salon ganz ausführlich das ist wirklich gruselig wenn man sich das mal im Detail Nassfeld hat hier ein ganz ganz langen Text wo man sich fragt welche überschrift wird man sich dann für diesen Text es wirklich wahnsinnig lang. Die überschrift war.
Facebook feiert ein Employer Connected Evidenz auf Right Wing Pages Skating Treatment also ein Facebook-Mitarbeiter hat intern,
wollte sich als Whistleblower schon mal ein paar Daten zusammen sammeln um aufzuzeigen dass Facebook dieser Rüge wegen Pages aktiv unterstützt dass sie wirklich Spezialbehandlung bekommen,
und Kevin Ruiss Wir haben ihn alle mal kabellos sozusagen der Ketzin Newton von der New York Times der auch dieses Tool und so weiter gemacht hat.
Text Facebook ist real silent majority.
Also was ist wenn wir wenn ich sozusagen diesen Trugschluss unterliegen.
Was ist wenn die bei Facebook einfach die Mehrheit dann tatsächlich so organisieren gegen die ganze mediale öffentlichkeit dass das klappt haben wir 2016 schon mal gesehen.
Ob man es auch gegen FoxNews und so weiter schafft steht jetzt zur Frage aber deren Sicht ist es wirklich bezeichnend und erstmals dann doch jetzt auch bei Facebook gelöscht wegen falschen Informationen.
Da hat Chris Cuomo der Bruder von Dinks Cuomo die New Yorker Familie bei CNN hat diesen kurzen Kommentar dazu gemacht.
Denn es,
ist so wie wir sind sie.
Trumps Kampagne postete sie bevor er der Kern des Social Media handelt. Kao He.
Sehr dramatisch aber der Hinweis auf Trump schafft es nicht mal den Social Media Standard einzuhalten.
Da muss man sich wirklich überlegen Was ist hier los. Naja Influenza tum ist ja nicht ganz unbedeutend und wir wissen wie sehr das mit dem Silicon Valley zusammenhängt.
Und wir gucken jetzt mal in kurzen Ausschnitt von Jimmy Fallon.
Der nimmt mittlerweile wieder in seinem Studio auf was ich sehr gut finde Colbert sitzt immer noch zuhause aber mittlerweile,
ist mal wieder ein bisschen in die Expertise gegangen was Aufnahmetechnik angeht. Die bei Fällen spielen sich mal Michel Obama vor.
Ihre Rede von.
Ja da. Klein Wie soll man sagen Unterstützungs Talk für.
Üblicherweise ist haben es ja die Republikaner nachgemacht.
Üblicherweise ist ja ein großes Publikum im großen Saal Sportstadion oder so eine Bühne und dann einer nach dem anderen weil das Publikum ist redet man.
Und jetzt musste man sich ja etwas Neues ausdenken weil das Publikum ja nicht da die Republikaner sind ja dabei geblieben sagen dass eine Bühne hinstehen die Kameras halt einfach kein Publikum da die Demokraten haben es sehr anders gemacht und,
wir hören es jetzt erst mal an wir beide sehen es auch.
Aber das kann man glaube ich doch nochmal ein bisschen tiefer gehen einschätzen.
Donald Trump Country. He he.
He he he,
Kerner,
be.
Also wir sehen hier diese neue Realität bei den politischen Reden gar kein Publikum und bei den Fernseh Betrachtung nur so ein paar lachende Stimmen Hintergrunds oder der Kameramann nochmal.
Das ist schon als würde man sich als hätten sie sich hingesetzt. Was macht man jetzt Wir dürfen kein Publikum.
Wer hat denn noch kein Publikum. Die ganzen YouTuber also hat man in diesem.
Sie spricht ja auch gar nicht viel anders. Influenza.
Sie sagt ja tatsächlich in diesem Video auch,
YouNow Politics. Und ich dachte naja,
warst du nicht irgendwie First Lady und so. Das ist total absurd eigentlich. Und das fand ich dann aber auch wieder von der deutschen Presse so toll wie das dann hochgejubelt wird so ein Video was ja Gottes ist Wahlkampf Klepp.
Es ist nicht so schlimm wie Achim von der CSU aber naja.
Aber es funktioniert halt komplett über diese. Man hat sich dann doch sehr an YouTube orientiert Fernsehen komplett links liegen lassen.
Ich hätte nur noch gefehlt dass man so den Kamera Ton nimmt und sie gar nicht noch Mikrofone da sondern dass man es komplett authentisch macht.
So jedenfalls hat sich Charles seine Gedanken machen.
Plump vor The Porree 2 KP,
in
China.
YouTube kennt.
Obama YouTube.
In
Ja.
Obama.
Bears.
Beide Pferdemarkt.
Totalem.
Er
ist Professor für Journalismus. Er muss jetzt seinen Schülern irgendwie einen Weg zeigen wie man noch zwischen den Politikern und das Publikum kommt. Wozu braucht man jetzt noch.
Weil es ja auch schon ganz bezeichnend ist dass er gar nicht versucht hat mich beeindruckt fand ich ganz toll.
Wir haben bei The Daily das ist vielleicht nicht ganz unbedeutend denn die Frage ist halt wirklich kommt man,
als Fernsehmacher Ja oder auch beim Kino kommt man da wieder raus weil die reinen Social-Media zahlen. Es ist wirklich beeindruckend.
Social Media.
Screw.
Facebook Hollis beide Pfänder Merck Erbs.
70 Prozent mehr Facebook in Ländern wie Spanien oder zuhause bei der New York Times Taylor Lawrence kümmert sich um diese,
Berichterstattung und so weiter. Die haben glücklicherweise.
Immer diese Frage gestellt. Das sollte man sich dann wirklich das bedeutet was für die Zukunft.
Facebook.
Ein,
Fakt.
Ist Facebook Quiring.
Umso mehr Influenza Kultur umso weniger Politik scheint da so eine Eins zu Eins Entwicklung zu geben.
Genau das was ich auch beobachte bei Instagram. Blicke ich mir mal.
Nehme ich in den Blick diese anderen Profile mit diesen Millionen Followern.
Nehme ich im Blick diese anderen Profile mit diesen Millionen Followern und wenn du siehst was für sie Politik ist dann ist das eigentlich nur was hab ich auf meinem Teller.
Was für sie Politik ist nur Was habe ich auf meinem Teller.
Was mache ich unter der Gürtellinie.
Mache ich unter der Gürtellinie.
Kann ich es nochmal wiederverwerten. Das sind irgendwie die Fragen die sich noch maximal gestellt werden. Aber sonst ist das.
Wiederverwerten sind irgendwie die Fragen die sich noch maximal,
aber.
Es gibt da nochmal die eine oder andere.
Die ein oder andere,
emotionale Themen irgendwo Flüchtlinge auf Moria wenden sich gerade irgendwie ein entsprechendes Bild viral ergeben hat und an denen vorbeigekommen sind dann springen sie ja noch auf diesen Zug auf.
Emotionale Themen irgendwo Flüchtlinge auch wenn sich das Bild viral ergeben hat und an dem vorbeigekommen sind.
Aber sonst ist da überhaupt nicht zu erwarten sondern es ist eigentlich eine große Entpolitisierung Eismaschine.
Aber sonst glaub ich überhaupt nichts.
Obwohl es immer so anders wirkt demokratisiert jetzt alle Themen und,
Polski.
Wir fragen uns ja jetzt keine Politik und nichts. Was ist denn Influenza Kalka.
Es ist einfach eine Break up.
Es darf.
Bei deutsche Tore.
Budget,
Pause.
Issey Miyake. Das Einfrieren ist Kaperung.
Money Experience.
Wie die Holzstab als die Endgame fucking ueber,
Arme.
Ging covert Bosek,
der Parke.
Influenza Kalka ist nur noch Kapitalist kalter nur kapitalistischer Logik.
Die Teller Lawrence stellt das auch so wunderbar dar wie jetzt wo alle so ein bisschen Angst um Ihr Tick Torque haben.
Da Trump da so ein bisschen rum wütet wissen sie nicht wie sie damit umgehen sollen.
Und sie stellen fest Ich kann mein tickte Eckfahne nicht übertragen zu Twitter oder Instagram oder sowas überhaupt erst einmal die Idee von,
wenn die Plattform nämlich die nächste Plattform von den Plattformen so eine Plattform Hopping macht um da dann weiter Influencer zu sein sondern die stellen auch fest.
Nee ich bin ja komplett in der Logik gefangen.
Ich kann ja gar nicht woanders das ist ja wie wenn ich im Baseball. Ich bin ja nicht einfach nur Sportler sagte geh ich halt schwimmen oder so. Sondern Ich bin ja hier gefangen.
Jetzt stellen sie so fest dass sie Ich bin ganz frei ich bin mein eigener Chef und so dass sie da so richtig eingekerkert sind.
Aber das ist sehr schön wie du das mit dem Sportler exakt so Aja.
Das hat die Fans so beschrieben dass man einfach nicht den Sport wechseln kann nur weil das eine.
Instrument Geige nicht mehr geht dann mache ich halt Klavier.
Das ist so erstaunlich und es ist ja auch in Deutschland zu beobachten gewesen damals bei den,
Protesten gegen Artikel 13 da gab es dann eine ganz kurze Politisierung aber die ging ja auch nicht weiter über das dass man dort diese Knallchargen,
von Politikern noch vorführte oder dass man generell Kritik an gewissen Konzernen wie Springer oder so übte.
Aber diese Frage des Urheberrechts die ja eine ganz grundsätzliche nochmal ist wenn man daran denkt dass wir einen Kapitalismus haben der eigentlich,
Kapitalismus immer mehr wird dass weniger Urheberrechte besitzen und sich dies dann monatlich durch Abos Services oder sonst was alimentieren lassen dass das eigentlich die Kernfrage ist wie wir mit diesen geistigen,
Inhalten mit Software Inhalten mit all diesen Dingen umgehen und wie man da eigentlich auch eine progressive Politik ganz dringend bräuchte um nicht nur irgendwelchen,
Instagram-Account zu ermöglichen dass sie weiterhin mimisch basteln können sondern einfach um eine Freiheit der Forschung zu gewährleisten das ist ja jetzt auch bei den ganzen Impfstoffen wieder eine ganz.
Private Angelegenheit.
Also dieses Thema Urheberrecht haben sie aber nicht geschafft über,
ihren eigenen Radios ihren Horizont hinaus zu politisieren weil sie gar nicht daran interessiert sind sie waren daran interessiert dass ihr Geschäftsmodell weiterhin Früchte trägt.
Das ist legitim aber man kann das jetzt nicht als einen großen politischen Protest sehen. Das ist jetzt doch ein bisschen übertrieben.
Man bräuchte jetzt eigentlich eine neue Emanzipation von Silicon Valley solche und jetzt gab es im August einengroßen Kritiker.
Jetzt gab es im August einen großen Kritiker. Ich glaube ich werde jetzt sehr überraschend Wer war im August der größte Kritiker des Silicon Valleys Alex K.
Ich glaube ich werde jetzt sehr überraschend Hörer auch Wer war im August der größte Kritiker des Silicon Valleys Alex Karp ist der Chef.
Ist der Chef von Planziel.
Wer jetzt an die Börse und an die Börse geht schreibt man als Chefs und schreiben Man schickt einen Brief mit wo so drinsteht das ist alles in diesem Gebilde und so weiter mit drin aber da ist so ein kleines Anschreiben.
Und er darf ja auch etwas blumig sein ich erinnere mich an den Brief von Daniel Ek damals zu Spotify und er schrieb dass wir doch alle die Musik lieben uns mit den Menschen verbinden.
Alles reinschreiben.
Also so was steht da drin. Ein Wort zum Sonntag.
Und wir hören jetzt mal ein bisschen aus diesem Text.
Ist es wirklich ein bisschen merkwürdig.
In
the,
country.
Entführers Safe.
Building.
Ist.
Er ließ den Text von Alex K.
An die Börse gehen die nochmal sagen Man weiß nicht was man dazu sagen soll.
Sagt man drei Worte noch weil es vielleicht gar nicht so bekannt ist.
Hier ist dieses Unternehmen das vor allem über Peter Thiel so berühmter ist weil er im Silicon Valley nicht im Silicon Valley sondern um das Silicon Valley herum irgendwo eben nicht im Silicon Valley aber mit Silicon Valley artigen Technologie Bezug und so weiter,
herumsitzt und die machen im Grunde Datenanalyse für Staaten oder Unternehmen die ziehen jetzt nicht so sehr auf den Endkunden ab genau die hessische Polizei ist ein großer,
Fan weil da kann man ja so Predictive Policing machen so und hier ist vor allem auch für so eine,
Sache berühmt dass sie nämlich sagen wir bieten euch die Analyse da Analyse als Service an.
Wir müssen uns dafür aber nicht allzu viel bezahlen wir wollen aber eure Daten behalten.
Das hatte Google auch mal. Wir transportieren euch gerne 15 Terabyte von dem Costolo nichts. Wir wollen aber nur eine Kopie davon haben.
Wenn das so wichtig ist dann gibt uns was ab.
Man weiß nicht genau was er so macht wo sie drin hängen. Aber sagen wir mal so Software die Staaten dabei unterstützt und da kommt nämlich auch die Kritik von Alex kPa dass er sagt,
wie de la Porte ist ausnahmsweise vorlas im Silicon Valley sitzen Leute an die Worte outgesourct wie unsere Gesellschaft funktioniert ohne dass sie selber in der Politik stattfinden oder kontrolliert werden oder wie auch immer wir haben eine strikte Trennung zwischen,
Quelltext die die Gesellschaft gestalten und Rechtstexte einsetzen in Washington nur haben keine Ahnung und am anderen Ende des Landes wie er sagte,
machen das halt und es ist ja ich musste so einen Lawrence Lessig der hat ja 999 Code geschrieben und da steckt ja auch diese Unterscheidung drinnen LAN und es gibt Koda Quelltext und Rechtstexte,
und ich habe dann nochmal reingeschaut und,
bei ihm ist ja eine ganz andere 1999 an.
Das war eine ganz andere Welt da gabs noch keinen Facebook und nichts Google war gerade so eine Website irgendwie Nadal dieses cod und andere Gesetze des Cyberspace.
Und damals hat er unterschätzt können wir heute sagen wie wenig der Staat eigentlich beim Code mitredet denn er hat es noch so als der Staat verteidigt ja unsere Grundrechte und das hat er bisher mit Rechtstexte gemacht.
Und das muss er künftig mit Quelltextes machen.
Also braucht er da Kompetenz und weil er und das der Staat aber die Kompetenz brauchte sich aneignen muss und das auch organisieren muss das zu können und so weiter.
Das war für ihn eingepreist Ja klar macht das der Staat wer denn sonst.
Und jetzt plötzlich das Silicon Valley wo man sehen Macht nicht der Staat sondern die Soßen das einfach aus.
Alex Crap Schreber während sich eine interessante Entwicklung klar Die Globalisierung hat nochmal übrigens dass wir in Hessen jetzt plötzlich an der Backe haben und das zeigt ja auch nochmal dass überspannt ja mehrere Rechtsgebiete.
Und da ist dann wirklich einfach Kohtes loja.
Naja wir schenken uns so langsam aus Silicon Valley ein Hirn allerdings kurz und zwar nur weil es auch im August stattfand.
Steve Balloon wurde auf einer 120 Dollar Yacht hops genommen weil er selbst Geld veruntreut hat das er über Bildauswahl irgendwie Kampagnen daher veruntreut hat und so eingenommen hat.
Wir haben mal kurz vor seinem Potthast Wir hören ihn so reden dann kommt eine Eilmeldung rein.
Breaking News.
$ Marke.
Okay so sieht man das. Warum auch nicht. Appell zwei Billionen wäre das erste Mal dass das,
Unternehmen reicher ja nicht einmal wenn man es historisch gewichtet oder so keine Eisenbahngesellschaft kein ölverbraucher war jemals so reich und so mächtig insbesondere nicht.
Und es fällt das Wort immer so ein bisschen übersehen aber das fällt ja auch klar Zusammen mit diesem die Post wird kurz und klein geschlagen Amerikaner hasst Apple steinreich und die Post wird ja gerade aus dem Spiel genommen,
obwohl wir die Post für die Wahl dort brauchen und Apple nicht unbedingt für den Wahlkampf vielleicht aber nicht für die Wahl und diese gigantischen Unternehmensgewinne spielen jetzt in dieser koronare Delle die es gab noch so eine Rolle und da haben wir nochmal kurz Laporte.
Simplify.
Facebook Apple.
Microsoft.
Facebook Apple Microsoft.
Also 500 Silicon Valley Unternehmen wiegen 495 andere und zwar die größten amerikanischen Unternehmen aus diesen haben wir jetzt einen Rekord Gesamtwert.
Allerdings wenn man Silicon Valley herausnahm sind sie trotzdem Crooner Minus. Das ist alles nur Silicon Valley im Plus.
Und jetzt stellt man sich ja wirklich die Frage Okay liebe Republikaner ihr seid an der Macht die haben eine Mehrheit im Senat und den Präsidenten.
Welche Frage klärt ihr gerade er hat hier nochmal das Ansinnen von Trump was er jetzt im August hat er hervorgekramt.
President.
Cameron Trump.
Jusuf.
Das ist.
Trumps Problem Was hat er kann dort niemanden weil er eine öffentliche Figur ist der niemanden aus.
Er muss jetzt allen Amerikanern sprechen darf niemanden auf Twitter blocken mal verboten und es würde jetzt vor dem Supreme Court klären dass ihm der kleine Tastendruck wieder erlaubt wird.
Diesen Republikaner gegenüber stehen die Demokraten und die haben eine Anhörung gemacht.
Demokraten und Republikaner im amerikanischen Kongress vor dem entsprechenden Ausschuss.
Es ist wirklich bezeichnend. Hören zum Einstieg.
Das ist ja irgendwie Sherman der sich dieses Anti Trust,
wie nennt man es Markt Verflechtung Marktmacht Monopolstellung und Kartellrecht genau ums Kartellrecht kümmert.
Vor ihm sitzt beispielsweise der Unternehmenschef von Apple der zwei Billionen Unternehmenswert auf sich summiert oder Jeff Bezos der alleine 200 Milliarden Privatvermögen hat.
Und die Amerikaner haben schon mal einen Unabhängigkeitskrieg geführt gegen die britischen Könige gegen das Königshaus und das ist nicht so lange her.
Im großen Maßstab und wir hören mal auf welche Pointe David Sichtlinie seiner Eröffnungsrede einschwenkt.
Amazon und.
Ebay in.
Form des Kreises sind. Bevor Parensen Investigation,
Axis.
Die Information Marketplace.
Is Kontrakts,
Business.
School of.
Business Activity.
Scharping.
Schrieb.
Heiko Maas.
Von,
Nyborg.
Meint.
Nur.
Die Arman.
Wir haben schon den Unabhängigkeitskrieg gegen die britische König gewonnen und wir wehren uns auch gegen die Silicon Valley Kaisa aufnehmen.
Es ist ganz großartig denn er hat den digitalen Kapitalismus verstanden. Dieser Mann hat es absolut verstanden.
Genau die drei Punkte.
Es gibt dieses sehr gute Buch bei Suhrkamp erschienenen digitaler Kapitalismus von Philipp Staab und da sagt er ja das große Geschäftsmodell ist ja wie wir wissen nicht der Hardware verkauft dass es nur bei Apple relevant bei den anderen eigentlich nicht viel zahlen drauf wenn es um Hardware geht.
Das Entscheidende ist dass die proprietärer Märkte haben das heißt die Märkte die sie beherrschen bei denen sie auch diktieren können wie viel Margen gezahlt werden müssen dass man überhaupt dort vertreten ist und was schreibt Philipp.
Auf denen sie selbst als Teilnehmer noch.
Er vergleicht das mit Landesherrn im Feudalismus die sagen so folgende Richtlinien gibt es hier und das müsst ihr an mich abtreten damit ich hier euren Handel zulasse.
Regeln.
Wunderbar toll dass er das so so in zwei Minuten auf den Punkt bringt.
Ich habe mich geschnitten aber nicht länger als fünf Minuten. Das ist doch eine schöne Einführung.
Ich musste mich auch erinnern der Mund der Kartellamtspräsident aus Deutschland hat schon 2014 damals,
den jährlichen Bericht geschrieben Wir kriegen das Kartellrecht nicht mehr auf die Straße Wir brauchen jetzt das Datenschutzrecht das einfach daneben steht.
Ulrich Kelber hat jetzt auch schon wieder gesagt Ich bin ein großer Fan von Mundt Wir sollten das mal zusammenlegen und so weiter. Aber es ist sehr langsam und man bekommt es öffentlich nicht mit.
Aber diese Leute diese Demokraten Die stehen voll im Saft anders als die Republikaner.
Es gibt ja dann immer so das muss man sich ja teilen.
Also hören wir jetzt im Sensen Brenner der direkt an diese Einführung anschließen.
Facebook.
Wir werden hier in unserem WSB unterdrückt und wir sind aber auch Konsumenten wir Konservative.
Bitte lasst unsere Facebook-Posts ordnen online gruselig.
Dann shared Nadler Wir sind wieder bei den Demokraten der Macht wieder den großen historischen Vergleich und trifft es wieder ganz gut.
Welche Annual.
Transform.
Sehen.
Wollen.
Business.
Fabulierte.
Genauso wie man als Eisenbahn Kun übers Land wird die man da verbindet.
So ist das halt jetzt wieder passt wirklich wunderbar und passt im Monat wo ich meine Eisenbahn spielt keine Rolle mehr aber eben auch nicht mehr.
Jetzt haben einfach Apple und alle da drin.
Kim Gordon ist ein Republikaner und er möchte gerne nicht mehr den Konservativen an die Gurgel geht.
Gogo.
Re Re,
Re Re.
Müsste Jordaan könnte vielleicht auch mal vom Bundestag langsamem demonstrieren gehen.
Das ist ja so ungeheuerlich was die von sich geben.
Bei aller Kritik die wir ja hier am Silicon Valley kontinuierlich äußern.
Man muss ja dann wenn man sich zwei Republikaner reichen ja schon um zu sagen Gott sei Dank ist das Silicon Valley momentan so mächtig dass es das überhaupt noch tut.
Das ist noch eine gewisse Hürde noch denen einbaut dass nicht alles möglich ist.
Man könnte ja einfach sagen wenn jetzt Minister Gordon und Herr Sensen Brander wenn die beiden im Silicon Valley den Vorsitz hätten wäre es ja noch bedeutend schlimmer.
Ja wir sehen gleich noch einmal wo wir denken. Zum Glück sind die nur Politiker und haben nicht wirklich was in der Welt mitzureden.
Naja jetzt beginnen die Statements der eingeladenen Gäste Wir beginnen bei Jeff Bezos Das ist so frech was er sich für ein Eingangsstatement ausgedacht hat.
Das ist so frech was sich wenn Eingangsstatement ausgedachten SPP.
Reni.
Na
Nach.
Überhaupt werden.
Stefan.
Live ist es eine ganz reiche Familie geboren worden. Reich an Liebe.
Das.
Das führt sie so richtig vorne. Außerdem will er noch mitteilen Amazon ist gar nicht so groß wie er mal glaubt.
Reacher.
Heranzulassen.
Amazon ist ja nur vier Prozent des amerikanischen Einzelhandels. Alles zusammen nicht viel vier Prozent.
Fragt man sich ein bisschen aber,
wie genau ist jetzt eine Definition von Einzelhandel einfach alles oder was hat er dann sehr viel später als er nochmal darauf zu sprechen gekommen um hier einen kleinen Einspruch loszuwerden.
Hier sieht man mal die sind jetzt in dieser Kartellrechts Anhörung und hören dann von Jeff Bezos folgendes.
Chef Amazons,
TLC aus Icomos.
Innerhalb.
Der Marke.
Ist.
Ganz.
Online-Handel ist ja gar kein eigener Markt. Das ist ja nur ein Chaney von Handel.
Deswegen kann man zwar sagen Er hat 40 Prozent des Online-Handels.
Aber das sind ja trotzdem nur vier Prozent des Handels auf den es ankommt.
Und wenn die Monopole ein Monopol auf Chanel ist ja es gibt nur auf Märkte Monopole und Onlinehandel ist ja gar kein Thema. Das ist wirklich.
Unglaublich. Sundar Pichai Google Wir helfen doch einfach nur allen Amerikanern.
New.
Dieses.
Erst verantwortlich. Genau.
Das eigentlich alles zur Verfügung wer ein Unternehmen gründet der hat doch nur.
Da muss doch nur bei uns die Services entgegen nehmen und kann er machen und die sind alle kostenlos.
Tim Cook der Chef eines Unternehmens ist zwei Billionen wert ist das bei dem aktuellen Die Rechnung ist immer ein bisschen unklar.
Der Chef eines Unternehmens. Zwei Billionen wert ist das bei dem aktuell Rechnung zu machen ist unklar.
188 Billionen Schuldenstand der Welt also müsste man sagen Apple ist gerade mehr als ein Prozent der ganzen Welt allen Vermögens der Welt alles aufsummiert ist Apple mehr als ein Prozent davon.
188 Billionen Schuldenstand der Welt Also müssen wir sagen Apple ist gerade mehr als ein Prozent der ganzen Welt allen Vermögens dabei alles aufsummiert ist Apple mehr als ein Prozent,
und Monopol wir doch nicht erst.
Und Monopole.
Wieder und habe damit in wenigen Worten.
Business.
Nirgendwo. Samsung verkauft ja noch viel mehr Handys.
Aber keinen proprietären Markt. Samsung irrelevant.
Samsung macht halt einfach Software. Alles läuft mit abgeschotteten Messergebnis.
Wir sehen das ja das sich entwickeln wird das Ahmeds heute nicht thematisiert wird aber eine wichtige Entscheidung hier im September werden.
Apple und Fortner ein großer Streit muss man vielleicht sagen dass es Ford nicht geschlagen aus Gründen sicherlich.
Microsoft hat sich schon auf die Seite von Apple.
Es ist ja so dass Apple mit seiner Plattform vorgibt wie viel mehr man zu zahlen hat an Apple und Ford ein so dominantes Spiel oder,
der Riese dahinter der Spielehersteller dass er natürlich nicht akzeptieren will und jetzt eigentlich in so einen Kampf geht es ist ein Kampf der Giganten und Apple möchte aber jetzt nicht nur,
fort löschen sondern sie wollen auch noch weitere Spiele löschen die mit Software arbeiten die von diesem Unternehmen das verordnet.
Und das ist jetzt erst einmal gestoppt. Das dürfen Sie jetzt nicht einfach vom Netz nehmen das heißt sie Konsumenten werden ja sonst auch um die Spiele gebracht die sie investiert haben die sie gekauft haben.
Und da gibts am Ende September 7.
September oder so. gibts da dann eine Anhörung und dann wird man sehen wie.
Genau da wird jetzt eine ganze Entscheidungs Kaskade irgendwie weil da niemand locker lässt.
Es ist aber auch dieses Kräfteverhältnis. Ich habe auch erst gedacht ich habe auch auf meinem iPad z.B.
Fortner drauf und wenn ich das aufmache so nach drei Monaten mal wieder sei es da wie sie müssten jetzt erst mal neun Gigabyte ABDA jetzt runterladen habe ich da keine Lust drauf.
Und man kann auch nicht auf dem iPad besonders gut spielen. Na gut halt weil die Apple Strategie ist ja zu sagen Wenn du unseren Bildschirm benutzt dann Pling wir vom ersten Jahr 30 Prozent und danach so 10 oder so.
Es wird dann so Nida gestaffelt und haben von Anfang an gesagt Nee wir geben euch nichts ab.
Und da dachte ich so ein bisschen na gut aber man braucht halt auch das iPad zum Spielen nur die Software alleine man muss ja irgendwie mit der Hardware und so weiter.
Ist das nicht eine Dienstleistung die man dann doch mal bezahlen sollte weil es irgendwie dann doch ein Service ist genau so wie die Verlage z.B. auch 30 Prozent.
Wenn man jetzt also auf dem iPad eine aktuelle Ausgabe von der Zeit oder von der FAZ kauft muss man auch 30 Prozent an Apple zahlen.
Nur dadurch sparen sie sich halt auch die Druckkosten und den ganzen Kram. Es ist halt wirklich ein Service der dahintersteckt.
Bis ich dann auch erst rein gelesen habe. Achso es geht aber nicht nur um Fortner als Spiel sondern auch um die Unreal Engine die so als Entwickler Umgebung für und so weiter und die ganzen Spiele die da so entwickelt werden nicht mehr funktionieren.
Und da findet ja wirklich Demokratisierung statt im Sinne von Spiele-Entwickler umbesetzt so leicht dass man doch auch mal mit einem Designer Hintergrund statt mit einem Informatiker in der ein Spiele entwickeln kann.
Wenn das denn alles rausfliegt dann wirds wirklich ein bisschen dann haut sich Apple auch selber ein bisschen ans Fleisch weil die wollen ja dass die Spiele da sind und dass man da präsent ist und so weiter.
Und was ich wirklich krass finde an den Tag als Apple 2 Millionen wert war kam diese Nachricht auch von Matt Mühlenweg der Gründer von WordPress.
Diese Software die fast jeder nutzt wird zum Beispiel auch auf der Seite und die tickern ja auch als Service gehostet der Wordpress Seiten.
Das ist dann WordPress Dot com kostet also ein bisschen was.
Und Apple wollte von allen Verträgen die abgeschlossen werden ein Anteil haben wo man sich wirklich denken.
Aber wenn eine Sache wirklich mal auch aus idealistischer Sicht gut ist dann ist das WordPress.
Einfach eine Open-Source Community gründen die dann sagt Ja und das kann man selber hausenden das mache ich auch seit Jahren und es funktioniert alles super nur für die die dann doch mal einen Service in Anspruch nehmen wollen die können sich sehen lassen weil man da jetzt als zwei Billionen Unternehmen nochmal.
Das Abgreifen muss ja es ist völlig übertrieben aber man muss mal gucken wie das ausgeht.
Mark Zuckerberg war ja auch noch mit eingeladen und erzählt jetzt mal auf alles die digitalen Platzhirsche sind weil er es ja nicht ist.
Tanzgruppe tätscheln.
Ariane Sommer Absturz.
Pepe.
Moss Papierberge Messaging Service. Einerseits,
ist Testtag übers Papier auf Youtube vor allem,
als Plattform Gogo.
Was den Tanzens.
So erzählt sie alle auf.
Ich finde schon dass Instagram genannt hat. Sehr witzig dass er das Unternehmen mitnimmt das auch einen wahnsinnigen Aufstieg hinter sich hat.
Zum Beispiel.
Ich finde es wird sich am Ende nochmal anfügt von allen Werbegelder die gezahlt werden kriegen wer weniger als 10 prozent was kriegen neun komma irgendwas Prozent oder so..
Das.
Vom kompletten amerikanischen Werbemarkt ist unglaublich was so plötzlich alles nicht größer ist.
Wenn man das mal so vergleicht die haben ja immer ihre Investors Carls und wo sie so darstellen wie sie sind und dann sieht man sie hier wo sie genau das Gegenteil.
Wie man sie wieder überall hinterher hängen.
Naja. Mark Zuckerberg hat ja noch seinen kleinen Wunsch an die Politiker jetzt wo er mal mit denen reden kann.
Debate.
Wie in jedem Jahr gibt es,
ein Hax,
wie übertrat.
Aus,
dem Internet.
Das haben wir schon häufiger thematisiert das ist dieser Markt Schließmechanismus jetzt wo sie eingespielt hat mit denen kann man auch mit 50 Anwälten in Washington das alles regeln wie die Gesetze auszusehen haben Hauptsache auch.
In der Hoffnung dass möglichst viele Republikaner da sitzen und man ihnen ein bisschen Free Speech zusichert dann wird das schon alles glatt gehen. Die die es jetzt hören können wirklich froh sein dass sie uns hören dass sie nicht sehen müssen. Es sieht wirklich gruselig.
Genau.
Das ist doch ganz komisch. Weiß es am Ende doch so waren die Vorstellungen.
Kommen wir zurück zu unserem David der Macht hier knöpft sich erst einmal Google vor.
Misst.
Weil,
Google via Google.
Ventures between the,
information weiß ist Google Kibbuz Gurus.
Das hatten wir auch in Europa schon mal Google musste dafür schon Milliarden Es wird jetzt alles juristisch gefochten aber,
es gab schon mal irgendwas Milliarden wirklich sehr viel Geld dafür dass Google eigene Services bevorzugt man macht also eine Google-Suche und dann tauchen erst mal die ganzen Google Services oben auf.
Damals ging es ums Shopping und wie krass das hier ist was er beschreibt dass nämlich Google auf eigene Services verweist und die auch als Werbeplattform anbietet.
Also zum Beispiel YouTube oder so. Man verweist man macht eine Google-Suche nach irgendeinem Lied kommt dann auf eine YouTube Seite und klickt dann dort Werbung von irgendwas serviert und so weiter und diese Grafik hat dann später in dieser Anhörung,
Mela man mitgebrachtes also wenn diese Zahlen stimmen.
Man kann sie auch nur so grob auslesen aber das sind wirklich beeindruckende Zahlen was als Unternehmenserfolg von Google zu werten ist.
Gogols Avenue ist coming from a als on Gogo ans Saids von Websites Trend.
Orbis.
Diese Grafik ist das zentrale Unternehmensziel von Google.
Nämlich so viel wie möglich von dem Werbe Umsatz als werbe Profit auf der eigenen Seite zu holen.
Wenn man nämlich einfach nur Werbung vermittelt die dann aber bei irgendeiner Springer Seite oder so stattfindet klickt man nur einen kleinen Anteil wenn die Werbung über YouTube ausgespielt wird legt man den ganzen Betrag,
ergibt dann ein bisschen aber im Grunde eine als Referenz 2004 mit fiftyfifty die Hälfte der Werbung wurde auf anderen Seiten über Google vermittelt ausgespielt durch Versteigerungen oder so.
Und die andere Hälfte wurde auf Google eigenen Seiten wo Google alles einstreicht haben Sie als Beispiel Google YouTube und so.
Und dann 2019 liegen dazwischen einfach 50 Prozent.
Geht hier von unter 20 wahrscheinlich auf über 80 20 also 80 Prozent.
Ist Google eigenes Property so als hätte man ein Immobilien-Tycoon.
Das ganze Land aufgekauft und 20 Prozent ist noch Jala das du jetzt auch mitverdient.
Das ist wirklich beeindruckend. Dass er dann so da sitzt ja das müsste ich mir dann nochmal genau angucken habe ich nicht im Kopf so als ginge es Google um irgendwas anderes als um die Optimierung dieser Zahlen.
Wenn er diese Zahlen nicht kennen würde dann würde er niemals da sitzen.
Es ist alles wirklich verlogen aber gut so ist es halt weist man andere darauf hin wie bei Google Sie haben sich diesen digitalen Markt frei geschossen.
Abseits.
Südstaat.
Von GoGo.
Gogo.
Sie haben sogar die interne E-Mails wie die Manager miteinander darüber reden wie sie sich niemand den Markt erobern.
Ein Beispiel Wir wissen es steht wirklich für Millionen Beispiele aber hier kommt mal dieses Beispiel Yelp.
Gescannte.
Die Gewerbezone Business.
Kennen wir aus vielerlei Wikipedianer. Die Wikipedia findet es gut dass es diese Praxis gibt aber sie ist im Grunde,
wie ich finde falsch dass man nämlich irgendeinen Namen sucht und dann den ersten Satz des Wikipedia Artikels schon auf der Google Seite angezeigt bekommt weil man sich für mehr sowieso nicht interessiert.
Und genau so geht Google mit sehr vielen Sachen um Flügen zum Beispiel Man sucht nach einem Flug und da kriegt man auf der Google-Seite schon verschiedene Termine und dem kann man direkt Fragen beantwortet der ganze Kram.
Werden beantwortet. Das ist ja auch jetzt etwas was jetzt sehr stark eingesetzt wird. Es hat ja auch nochmal zugenommen diese Funktion plus auch die Markierung hat ja auch nochmal zugenommen.
80 Prozent.
Dass Google schon mehr im Text direkt markiert Gelb was ich gesucht habe.
Also genau sowas. Man wertet die Google-Seite funktional total auf damit man dann nicht weiter klickt und hier mal ein Beispiel.
Es kommt ja auch noch hinzu.
Die machen ja auch die Demokraten arbeiten halt die reden ja auch mit den Leuten die das halt so betrifft und hier ist der Vorbereitung hatte mal so eine kleine Anekdote mitgebracht.
Bei uns heißt es business,
to
Business.
Es ist Hirschi.
Hier sieht man jetzt auch wo es kritisch wird wenn nämlich die dass es völlig egal ist ein Monopol oder ist es ein Markt wenn die Konkurrenz nicht mehr funktioniert.
Also wenn in Amerika das Unternehmertum ausgeschaltet wird durch so etwas dann wird es da kritisch und da müssen sich dann auch die im Silicon Valley etwas ausdenken wie sie damit umgehen weil diese Kritik kann man einfach so wegreden jetzt mit irgendwelchen klugen Antworten.
Aber da gehts dann halt ans Eingemachte weil da auch Rechtstexte.
Das hat ja am Anfang angefangen mit diesen drei Punkten und es betrifft alle Unternehmen und das kann man hier ganz wunderbar zeigen denn alles was er jetzt zu Google gesagt hat,
macht jetzt die Mary's. Gern lernen Nutzer das Argument gegen Amazon,
dass man nämlich einen Markt proprietär selbstorganisiert auf dem man dann wiederum feststellt,
Ich könnte ja wenn ich hier auch noch Teilnehmer bin sehr viel mehr verdienen müsste aber dann andere Teilnehmer aus dem Markt drängen so wie Google und Apple.
Und sie kommt ja mal auf die Basis zu sprechen und hat hier eine Zahl und es ist wirklich erschütternd zu hören wie weit ist Amazon da getrieben hat.
Amazon,
kam in den E-Mails.
Diese Bundeshaushaltes sehr.
Und.
Encoder ergänzt hat der Business bei Tempo.
Stark.
Wie soll.
Statements.
Man.
Amazon.
Romanwelt Nouri.
In
Sein Auto mit Bryson.
Man muss sich vorstellen Da kauft man seine Windeln dann natürlich gleich immer so Aporien weil die wissen ja dann wenn wir Kunden haben jeden Monat eine Windelen geliefert Es geht dann 2 Jahre so oder so.
Und dann haben wir entsprechend Umsatz gemacht und Amazon wollte in diesen Winkel Markt,
und ist mit solchen Kampfpreisen reingegangen das sie in einem Monat allein mit dem Handel von Windeln 200 Millionen Dollar Verlust gemacht haben,
nur um Konkurrenten aus dem Markt zahlen das ist unglaublich.
Aber das ist ja gerade das was wir hier jetzt nochmal besonders erleben da wir ein neues Unternehmen im Dax haben.
Delivery Hero wenn du dir anschaust wie diese ganzen Verteiler funktionieren dann schreiben dir zwar tiefrote Zahlen aber sie setzen eben auf einen solchen Verdrängungswettbewerb um am Ende einen,
Markt beherrschen zu können um dann auch Preise diktieren zu können um dann irgendwann allen Restaurants zu sagen wenn du überhaupt bei uns gelistet sein willst dann geht das nur wenn du mindestens 25 Prozent abdrückt und so lange lange lange tiefrote Zahlen.
Ich halte es ehrlich gesagt für sehr sehr illusorisch zu glauben dass man wirklich mal damit richtig viel Geld verdienen kann.
Das ist aber erst einmal für die Investoren ja gar nicht wichtig denn die warten ja nur darauf dass sich die Aktie gut entwickelt.
Die Hoffnung lange wach bleibt und dass sie es dann wieder entsprechend verkaufen kann.
Man kann ja auf so einer Etappe die irgendwann ins Desaster führt sehr sehr viele Gewinner produzieren.
Allein in den Dax reinzukommen rutschen so viele Indexfonds plötzlich rein so viele Investoren zur Verfügung.
Aber es ist wirklich brutal käme auch ohne die haben es genauso gemacht.
Aber es ist brutal Talia.
Die dann eben irgendwann litten darunter dass es Amazon gibt eben diese Monopol.
Fressen und gefressen werden.
Wir wissen dass das bei Facebook auch so läuft man klaut bei Snapchat Man kauft sich Instagram und WhatsApp und der ganze Kram,
steckt ganz wunderbare Frage an Mark Zuckerberg und er weiß gar nicht wie antworten soll.
Zinsmarge E-Mail-Kommunikation Harmonika dürstet Facebook Gendoping.
Campanile.
Die.
Erstmals.
Kann man schon mal.
Komplett in sein Marketing Modus rein. Aber die Frage wie viele Unternehmen wollen Sie eigentlich noch Raubkopieren 500 50 Er weiß gar nicht mehr.
Ich akzeptiere die Prämisse gar nicht wir machen hier nur das Allerbeste.
Und wenn uns andere vormachen was gut ist müssen wir halt nachmachen Es ist gut.
Gerade auch wieder versuchen mit Real ja sie versuchen Tick nachzuahmen.
Aber das schaffen sie nicht. Sie sind sie erst einmal das hat die Teller und die Theiler Lawrence von den Jugendheime hat ganz wunderbar auf den Punkt gebracht. Facebook ist technisch nicht in der Lage die schaffen es einfach nicht.
Deswegen er das auch so hin. Es wird nicht richtig zurückgezogen aber nicht weiterentwickelt. Sie sind nicht in der Lage technisch Schritt zu halten.
Deswegen Lotter das so hin und es wird nicht richtig zurückgezogen aber auch nicht weiterentwickelt. Sie sind nicht in der Lage technisch Schritt zu halten mit den Chinesen.
Mal gucken wie sich das so weiter entwickelt aber dann scheint es intern bei Facebook.
Sie haben das auch den Influenza angedient das hat man gemerkt dass die Influenza das thematisiert haben dass das jetzt bei Instagram geht aber es waren eigentlich viele Influenza die auch sowas sagten.
Und dann hat man aber nichts mehr davon gehört das haben die mal so drei Tage ausprobiert aber es scheint schon total abzuschleppen.
Auf Twitter gibt es auch den Witz jetzt kann man auch bei Instagram gucken da kann man sie ja sehr einfach runterladen weil man sie ja mal weiterverarbeiten soll und so weiter und jetzt werden sie bei reelles hochgeladen.
Der steht aber immer das Diktat Schild mit unten drin ist eigentlich auch schon so eine Demütigung dass man da so scheitert das finde ich wirklich interessant.
DMX knöpft sich Mark Zuckerberg vor denn Instagram Whatsapp Snapchat und so weiter aber es gibt ja auch noch diesen ganzen Kleinkram den wo so viele Dinge halt gemacht haben im Tagesgeschäft.
Facebook Mai Growing Airborne Facebook ist,
Facebooks Paros.
Facebook,
Open,
Access Facebook.
Facebook,
Pinterest.
Man hat sich halt als Manager Team Facebook genau angeguckt und hat gesagt Message Wir geben uns gegenseitig Nachricht Wir haben einen eigenen Messenger. Das muss mal raus.
Pinterest Netflix lass mal rein reden die dann über die Filme.
Das ist ja toll wie man sich die Landschaft einfach bestellt hat wie man wollte und es wäre so schön wenn es ordentliche Mehrheiten gäbe und weil die stehen ja wirklich alle im Saft.
Tim Cook Meine Frage ist grandios vorbereitet. Es war richtig dank eigentlich.
Erpreßbar.
Peking.
Rpo.
Erguss.
Gartensaison.
Yeah yeah.
Ja jetzt haben.
Yeah.
Wir ja alle irgendwie Weißmehl.
Soweit so gut. Also irgendwelche Eltern haben ihren Kindern iPhones geschenkt wollten aber ein bisschen kontrollieren was sie so machen also haben sie sich immer auf ihr Handy schicken lassen und dann konnte man ein bisschen das begrenzen.
Dann haben Sie gesagt Nee das nehmen wir mal raus weil es geht ja gegen die Datenschutzrichtlinien für das Kind weil dann wird es ja überwacht. Jetzt hat sich eine Nachfrage dazu.
Okay okay so wie.
Es
Offenbar.
Offenbar das Saudi Arabien Gove.
Ergossen sich in Boston.
Sorry.
Also lügt wenn er sagt er weiß nicht was er ist denn es war eine der größten Skandale überhaupt.
Tim Cook lügt wenn er sagt er weiß nicht was Apple ist denn das war einer der größten Skandale überhaupt.
So wie westliche Mütter ihre Töchter überwachen haben nämlich auch arabische Männer ihre Frauen überwacht und diese App wurde von Apple nicht rausgenommen weil dann wäre dieser Markt verloren gegangen. Man hat ja mit der App einfach verdient.
So wie westliche Mütter ihre Töchter haben nämlich auch arabische Männer und diese nicht ausgenommen weil der Markt verloren gegangen.
Man hat ja einfach die Datenschutz Sachen der Frauen die da betroffen waren oder ganze Familien die waren total egal.
Datenschutz Sachen der Frauen die da betroffen waren oder ganzen Familien die Waren Apple total egal.
Da hat sie ganz wunderbar aufgezeigt wie verlogene Seelbach ist nicht Datenschutz der Kinder sondern es ging einfach darum dass man dann sein eigenes Ding auf dem Handy unterbringen wollte und den ganzen Kram alles selber.
Da hat sie es ganz wunderbar aufgezeigt wie verlogen das einfach ist. Natürlich nicht die Datenschutz der Kinder sondern es ging einfach darum dass man dann sein eigenes,
Ding auf dem Handy unterbringen wollte und seinen Family teil und den ganzen Kram hat Apple alles selber an Funktionalität nachgebaut.
Denn überwachung von Kindern und meisterten das ist ja ganz verwunderlich diese Argumentation hat zunächst mal banale.
Es ist völlig Banane dass er sich hier so naja.
Aber es interessiert nicht. Es ist ja kein Skandal hätte jetzt irgendwie was,
gesagt was nicht so politisch korrekt ist dann wüssten wir was passiert dann hätten wir fünf Tage Shitstorm und dann würden alle darüber berichten.
Das ist ja ganz verrückt auch wenn du jetzt von manchen Unternehmen von Bilanzen bei Adidas habe ich dann auch so einen Kommentar gehört.
Das Unternehmen würde zu wenig auf der Börse setzen. Die einzigen Sorgen die solche Kommentatoren haben.
Aber wenn so etwas geäußert wird wo man davon ausgehen kann dass diese App in Saudi-Arabien dazu verwendet wird dass Frauen unterdrückt werden und zwar ganz massiv dann ist das kein.
Würde man so kurz behandelt. Aber es ist wirklich erstaunlich es ist vor allem,
wenn es einmal gebrochen wird eine Anhörung die fand ja auch Widerhall überall aber sowas wo man wirklich mal ein bisschen Politik machen könnte.
Hãngt Johnson und Tim Cook wieder ganz perfide hängt Johnson fragt jetzt mal nach dem App-Store den man ja durchaus rausnehmen könnte um zu sagen alle Apple Apps müssen jetzt,
einem Wettbewerb teilnehmen und man kann nicht einfach sagen wir mal raus rein und Tim Cook wieder ganz perfide.
Steuersünder.
Die.
Nur wie die Kamera funktioniert.
Ich hasse es das ist ja unglaublich.
Das.
Das man sich nicht ein bisschen. Man muss sich offenbar nicht mehr geben. Das sieht man ja nicht unvorbereitet.
Dass man sich nicht ein bisschen mehr. Man muss sich offenbar nicht mehr Mühe geben. Das sieht man ja die kommen ja unvorbereitet hin und sagen sonst Sie wissen es nicht.
Sie wissen es nicht.
Ich weiß es gar nicht so genau. Das heißt die demonstrieren hier auf eine Weise ihre Macht das ist dann wirklich der absolutistischer Herrscher. Dem ist es eigentlich vollkommen egal was die da fragen.
Das heißt sie demonstrieren auf eine Weise ihre Macht das ist wirklich der absolutistischer eigentlich vollkommen egal.
Die wissen genau Die müssen jetzt hier diese Fragen durchstehen Jeder hat immer so es geht auch schneller rum als man glaubt nur noch irgendwie sowas Primaner.
Bei Mark Zuckerberg gibt's immer noch irgendwie so etwas Kindliches das der Primaner wirkt irgendwie vorgeführt wird aber darüber kommt er auch.
Aber auch Da sitzt also ein sehr wie fies Apple tatsächlich ist wird hier nochmal von Lucy Macbeth,
zusammengefasst denn sie hat auch nochmal ein Beispiel und es fallen jetzt zwei unternehmensnahen Apple,
Rande im Haus im Haus ist der größte Buchhändler der Welt der größte Hersteller der Welt und Apple hat einen besonderen Umgang mit solchen Platzhirschen.
E-Books Erbs.
Mit Shevchenko between Random House Web Cunningham,
Renan Random House auf Seite des Jackson,
Random House.
Of business to join.
Ja ist natürlich eine rhetorische Frage an Tim Cook ob das jetzt fair ist. Aber hier ist wirklich diese Grenzüberschreitung. Wenn wie bei Apple.
Wenn man auf einem iPad spielt finde ich es okay wenn man für die iPad Hardware sozusagen als Hersteller mitfinanziert weil wie beim Papier beim Zeitunglesen und so.
Aber wenn Random House es verweigert wird den eigenen E-Reader auf dem iPad zu installieren als App sondern die müssen dann in Apples,
App und damit Apple einen eigenen Store eingebaut hat sozusagen die Kunden rüber zieht von einem Haus zum iBooks.
Und dann ist das diese Grenzüberschreitung wo ich mich wirklich frage Wie kann ein so hochgradig kapitalistisches Land wie Amerika das eigentlich für Unternehmen wie Random hausgemacht ist trotzdem das zulassen.
Also warum ist das 2020 fast Jahrzehnte nachdem das als Problem auftauchte immer noch so virulent.
Da zeigt sich auch diese macht einfach die da dahinter steckt wenn man die Technik so im Griff hat.
Eigentlich könnten sich die neoliberalen wenn sie sich wirklich ernst nehmen würden von ihrer besten Seite zeigen.
Eines wollen sie ja immer in den Vordergrund stellen das ist der Wettbewerb.
Aber hier sehen wir ganz deutlich in all den Beispielen die wir jetzt gehört haben.
Es gibt gar keinen Wettbewerb mehr und da könnte man mit einer,
rein kapitalistischen Argumentation nur aus diesem Freiheits Gedanken heraus sagen Wir müssen die beschneiden damit eben wieder Wettbewerb stattfinden kann.
Mehr müsste man gar nicht einfordern. Das hat nichts mit links zu tun Besteuerung irgendwie boesen an die an die Wäsche gehen sondern einfach nur zu sagen Ja wir sind doch ein freies Land wir brauchen freien Wettbewerb.
Wir sind ein kapitalistisches freies Land das kann doch nicht wahr sein dass sich ihre Bücher nicht verkaufen können.
Ja ja die sollten eigentlich sagen Das ist Planwirtschaft.
Es ist eine unternehmerische Planwirtschaft abgegeben an eine Organisation über die man keine Kontrolle hat.
Johnny Guse ist ein sehr junger Abgeordneter der dann später auch auf dem Platz von dem eröffnete Sherman saß keine Ahnung welche Karriere der Plan,
hat sich abseits dieses ganzen offensichtlichen Themas nämlich bei Amazon werden Sachen verkauft wie,
Amazon sich auf dem Binnenmarkt breit zu machen.
In Deutschland beispielsweise noch völlig übersehen wird Amazon ist ja in Deutschland einfach nur so da liefert Halbzeug nach Hause fast mehr Geld mit irgendwie digital Kram als Sachen liefern das ist ja interessant.
Das Emerson Juz.
Services.
Das.
Team Doing Business.
Business ist.
Also braucht Cheffe Besseres zu tun als hätte er davon noch nie gehört denn das ist ein laufendes Thema unter diesen Experten aus der Politik so dass man nämlich beispielsweise als Netflix oder als sonst irgendwer sich bei,
Amazon den Datenspeicher bucht oder die Rechenkapazität,
Uber z.b.
Und man nicht genau weiß werden wir hier gerade von Amazon ausspioniert.
Im Sinne von gucken die Karte wie gut Windeln laufen und dann machen wir es auch.
Gucken Sie sich gerade bei Amazon an bei Netflix an welche Filme laufen besonders gut und die werden dann bei Amazon Prime Video besonders promotet und so weiter.
Diese ganzen Verstrickungen oder was weiß ich. Welche,
Dienste funktionieren besonders gut im Markt welche könnten wir denn mal nachbauen und dann auch mit entsprechenden Werbebudgets so promoten dass die anderen gar keine Chance haben,
sich da auch mal mein Fokus darauf gelegt und dann versteht man wieder besser das echt weltliche.
Jamie Reski stellt ja auch eine Frage an Jeff Bezos der natürlich wieder keine Ahnung.
Bei,
ärmer seien Barrys so.
Wachse.
Carax.
Ein.
Frustrieren.
Sometimes.
Diese Basics die gibt's überhaupt nur weil Amazon damals auf die Idee kam kommen wir machen in die Waschmaschine.
Diese Basics gibt es überhaupt nur weil Amazon damals auf die Idee kam. Wir machen.
Und wenn man den drückt geht die eine Bestellung los kein Gesuche keine Alternativen nix einfach nur zack da gibts das Basic Waschmittel und Sprachsuche.
Eine Bestellung los die einfach nur alle sagen gibt's ja auch Sprachsuche.
Damit schlägt sich Google seit ewig rum da gibts keine Werbeplätze mehr. Wie soll man das monetarisieren Amazon weiß wie man das monetarisiert man sagt.
Damit schlägt sich Google seit ewig.
Da gibt's keine Werbeplätze aber Das Monetarisieren Amazon weiß wie man das monetarisiert sagt,
Alexa meine Milch ist alle beschied neue Amazon wie ich da haben wir eine Auswahl.
Alexa meine Milch ist alle schickt mir neu und dann kommt Amazon Milch geliefert.
Wenn man es kompliziert da haben wir eine Auswahl muss man halt die Webseite gehen und dann kann man scrollen und so weiter.
Nur diesen Grund Eigentlich nicht.
Aber gut er hat davon noch nie. Es kann sein dass es in Promotions Kampagnen mal passiert ist dass man das bevorzugt das eigene Zeuch.
Es kann sein dass es in Kampagnen passiert ist dass man es bevorzugt.
Wir haben heute auf jeden Fall schon gelernt Geschäftsführer zu sein heißt das haben wir schon bei den Freeport gehört dass man eigentlich gar keine Ahnung hat von dem was so läuft.
Ja genau. Keine Ahnung.
Dieser Satz dieses des Besitzers. Ich bin nur der Geschäftsführer. Das ist eigentlich das was die hier permanent von sich geben.
Ich bin nur der Geschäftsführer.
Es ist unglaublich. Milla Kapperl weiß dass sie hier keine Frage im Sinne von Ich will eine Antwort sondern sie will hier Statements machen und auch nochmal so eine schöne rhetorische Frage an Jeff Bezos.
Und glauben die weiß dass sie hier wollen. Ich will eine Antwort.
Sie hat ja auch noch eine schöne rhetorische Frage.
Uhrwerks ist Dada der Forex,
Piet habees Einschuss bei Study Pricing in Inventory Information Pass in Future Anything.
Labels. Sie müssen bedenken Bei ihnen existieren in den.
Sie müssen.
Engen Nischen,
zu Jugendzeitung.
Goes by.
Wo die Privatsphäre im Besitz des wohlfeiles Manöver.
Die.
Es ist schön es sind auch eigentlich nur noch rhetorische Fragen eigentlich durch die Bank sind es nur noch rhetorische Fragen die dann von den Herrschaften mit irgendwie keine Ahnung weiß oder Vielen Dank konkret beantwortet werden.
Aber jetzt frage ich mal wenn wir uns das jetzt alles angesehen haben hier.
Bestünde Deines Erachtens eine Möglichkeit das so sehr zu politisieren dass sich wirklich eine breite Gruppe von Wählern blicken wir ruhig mal auf Deutschland weil wir es da noch klarer übersehen können dafür interessiert.
Wenn ich jetzt meine letzte Woche bei Twitter Revue passieren lassen was ich dort am allermeisten gesehen habe da war davon kaum die Rede von solchen Dingen und ich folge ja schon eher spezielleren Leuten.
Also gar nicht so jetzt diesen üblichen Kanälen bei denen ich mir sage Gut wenn jetzt die Fernsehmoderatoren und Comedians die immer twittern was Twittern dann kriege ich das ja eh durch die Likes und somit brauche ich nicht selbst zu folgen.
Ich folge eher schon ausgewählten Leuten und ich sehe eigentlich sieben Tage lang nur,
das bald und das dann auch eben diese komischen Leute demonstrieren die aber eigentlich vollkommen irrelevant sind.
Die in Berlin dieses Spektakel feiern.
Das ist ja einfach auch eine riesen Entpolitisierung die durch solche Events stattfindet und auch die Empörung über die Events.
Siehst du eine Möglichkeit darin dass das hier überhaupt eine öffentlichkeit erfährt die dann auch wirklich politisiert.
Na wir hören mal den Abschluss gibt es Demokraten in dem Fall ist das schon ne Grusa wie schon gesagt Der sitzt dann auf dem Platz.
Und die Amerikaner haben es ja schon mal thematisiert bei dem Klima Anliegen wenn die großen amerikanischen Investoren,
nur noch den Markt beschützen und einzelne Teilnehmer dafür opfern würden so und hier sehen wir wieder den bedrohten Markt.
Junge Menschen kriegen irgendwie erzählt er Buch.de schnell bei Amazon hier irgendwie Speicherkraftwerke kann es ja darum rechnen und dann kannst du sowas auf die Beine stellen.
Sie sind dann doppelt gefangen.
Sie können diese Daten nicht wieder aus Amazon raus migrieren weil ihnen Microsoft ein besseres Cloud Angebot macht oder so sind sie bei Amazon gefangen.
Sie wissen nicht was Amazon damit macht. Am Ende werden sie irgendwie keine Ahnung klingen ein tolles Geschäftsmodell die ersten Kunden sind da sie werden irgendwie mit 50 Millionen bewertet oder sowas.
Die ersten Investoren plötzlich schnappt die Falle zu weil plötzlich Amazon das gleiche als Angebot aber steckt da jetzt 250 Millionen Werbebudget dahinter und zack ist man raus aus Markt.
Und das sollte ja doch den einen oder anderen sensibilisierten in Deutschland z.B.
Fehlt tatsächlich so eine liberale Partei die wie die FDP so ganz auf den Markt fokussiert ist.
Aber halt mal vernünftig so weiß ich genau wie er damals so drauf war das sind ja auch so die Innenminister halten sich immer ein bisschen raus bei der Wirtschaft aber.
So wie Gerhart Baum Das wäre wahrscheinlich.
Aber wie er heute ist. Gerhart Baum als liberalen.
Ja auf jeden Fall. Die alte Garde Jünger soll ja nicht die wir jetzt haben die alten Kopfs sondern die alte Garde,
die sich das Problem mal annehmen weil ich glaube man bekäme es unter Studenten und so weiter unter Menschen die dann auch der Handwerksberuf ist ja heute dann doch sehr digital.
Wenn man so als Fliesenleger nun doch erst mal in 3d rendering machen soll für den Kunden.
Es gibt ja sehr viel Innovation ist glaube ich das richtige Wort es gibt sehr viel,
Lücken die noch mit Produkten und Services zu füllen sind die aber nicht gefüllt werden können weil das Silicon Valley lieber Märkte abschließt als Möglichkeiten zu gewähren.
Sagen wir mal so Ich glaube Jahrgang 85 84 keine Ahnung der bringt es ja ganz wunderbar auf den Punkt.
Der Innovation Kurse wie.
Growing.
Stories Wittes Kameraderie.
Pendeln und Bek Technologiefirma sind Kröning in Teams.
Phorms gibt es mit jedem pied.
Er als junger Kongressabgeordneter ist besorgt über die Innovation Killzone Silicon Valley.
Investieren haben wir immer wieder. Genau das Gegenteil von dem wofür es eigentlich steht.
Und die machen halt diese Anhörung. Die fahren dann in ihre Wahlkreise und sehen da so rund um die Universitäten sind da irgendwelche Innovation Hubs und die haben so die ersten Ideen,
brauchen dann Rechenkapazität kaufen die sich nicht selbst als Service stecken dann im Gefängnis kommen zu nichts werden ständig jammern über das Angebot wir kaufen dich jetzt auf weil wir deinen Kopf brauchen und so weiter.
Biographischer erst mal versorgt aber Deine Idee ist trotzdem irgendwie im Arsch.
Und das ist das glaube ich da steckt schon mehr dahinter als jetzt nur eine Anhörung.
Ich glaube da sollte man sich auch als Silicon Valley @Tiku dann doch irgendwie Gedanken machen weil es besteht durchaus die Möglichkeit dass wir in halb Jahresfrist irgendwie Elizabeth Warren als Finanzministerin haben oder so. Sie spielt ja jetzt gar keine Rolle.
Bezeichnend weil das heißt ja wirklich sie steht für. Sonst hätte sie sich jetzt auch anders geäußert.
Die Einsicht ist da glaube ich schon einiges in Bewegung.
Wir wissen ja dass am Ende werden wir amerikanische Interessen beschützt entweder durch Politiker oder durch Finanzinvestoren.
Silicon Valley ist mächtig aber eben auch nur so punktuell ein paar Angriffspunkte gibt es ja da schon wie man da eingreifen kann.
Wir wollen aber auch noch die Republikaner gucken denn was kümmern sich die Republikaner so mit Gates.
Ist der schlimmste asoziales der Politik in Amerika überhaupt den man sich vorstellen kann.
Trat doch jetzt bei Trumps Dingsda groß auf und so weiter werden jetzt mit Gates der amerikanische Dalla Fragensteller.
Facebook gebe es eine American Company American.
Companies American Service,
die Idee.
Alles amerikanische Unternehmen mit amerikanischen Werten.
Schön hat keiner widersprochen dann ist das doch.
Verwendet. Zwei Minuten in seinem Slot Crack Stoiber hat auch mal eine Frage.
Sex.
With my Campaign. Marc Janko für die Agentur in.
Washington D.C. In My Name.
Is
My name.
Er will beide nur rechts und links irgendwie ich weiß eigentlich der Politiker fragen Wieso landen meine Mails im Ordner und dann sagt der Google-Chef Ich kann Ihnen versichern im Algorithmus steckt keine politische Ideologie Ich,
denke ich kann doch nicht wahr sein.
Wird die Zeit wieder sinnvoll verwendet um wirklich kritische wichtige Fragen zu stellen.
Es ist unglaublich Buck stellt nicht nur eine Frage.
Man fragt sich eigentlich noch kommt jetzt noch gleich Du hast ja ein paar kommt jetzt noch gleich jemand der sagt Ich habe vorgestern was bei Amazon bestellt das sollte eigentlich schon gestern da sein wo ist es dann her.
John McCain hat ja mal Tim Cook gefragt wieso es nervt mich jedes Mal manchmal installiert.
Wir hatten ja mal keinen Bock Der fährt jetzt die ganz große politische Linie.
Gogo. In China kamen erstmals auf sauf.
Wir sind.
Mausoleums in.
Nicht.
China.
CCP.
Sie sind wie normale.
Ist ja durchaus ein kritisches Thema. Aber auf diese Art und Weise,
weil Trump ja gerade im Wahlkampf ist und es nicht auf diese Lager da zuzuschneiden sondern auf die CCP und so. Sie machen doch irgendwas mit der Kommunistischen Partei.
Wieso arbeiten Sie als Google mit der Kommunistischen Partei zusammen. Was.
Und nochmal Free Speech also in Form von C kooperieren mit China und die unterdrücken ja die freie Rede in Hongkong.
Also wird das Dania uns auch drohen.
Genau machen Sie das Sensen Brenner den wir schon kennen. Stellt die beste Frage überhaupt an Jeff Bezos.
Wobei er,
ja
Auch.
Ein.
Schön,
verfließen da ist aber selbst verwundert dass er jetzt da eigentlich gerade so ein Lob bekommt.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Es ist.
Was würde der Amerikaner nur tun wenn es Amazon nicht gäbe.
Dem Amerikaner geholfen wenn er kein Wohnstube mehr hätte sondern da die Milch kauft und da seine Bücher.
Schirme Sensen Brenner hat eine Frage an Marc Zuckerberg es geht um Clockwork.
Das ist ja dieses tolle von Donald Trump.
Kurze Zwischenfrage mag hier weil ich das in einer,
Dichte hier von mir präsentiert bekommen wie mir das noch nie so bewusst war,
ist das bei vielen noch einfach Perfidie oder ist es einfach auch reine Dopheide weil manche sehen ja hier auch Gesichtsausdrücke wo man jetzt.
Beide.
Sind doof und perfide weil die machen bewusst nicht Politik.
Sie halten sich bewusst raus Die kriegen von diesen an die sie ja die Frage stellen das Geld in Arsch geschossen damit sie dort keine Fragen stellen.
Und so ist das halt auch hier.
Er
Cissé.
Sowas und sowas gibt's es daher dass Trumps klare Queen's Scheisse bei seinem Sohn auf Facebook gesperrt wurde.
Naja Cragg Stoiber dem wir gerade auch schon gehört haben mit seinen landet alles in Ordnung das kann ja wohl nicht sein da der anderen eine Frage.
Welches,
soviele,
Supermans.
Euro-Landes.
Casey Newton hat ja mal ein Text darüber geschrieben weil er als erster Einblick hatte in diese Contento Moderationen,
die da stattfinden und dieses Bild ist ja da arbeitet man quasi in einem Thönnes Flugbetrieb hat so ein 5 seitiges Manual nach dem man entscheiden soll ob man die Vergewaltigung den Mord oder was man noch immer gerade da vorgelegt bekommen wie man das einzuteilen hat,
auch nach einem halben Jahr sind die alle danieder und Braum psychische Hilfe von Facebook nicht bekommen und außerdem haben sie auch nur 1000 Dollar Monat dafür verdient.
Und der Cragg fragt jetzt so sind das eigentlich alles ihre ihre politischen Handlanger mit denen sie gegen uns arbeiten.
Also es ist so Outer Space da einfach 1:1 zu zählen. Der Sensen Branagh schießt ja auch nochmal den Vogel ab.
Instagram wurde gekauft von Facebook das sehen wir heute problematisch. Wer ist eigentlich daran schuld.
In Obamas Amtszeit ist das alles okay.
Die Demokraten in Obamas Schuld. Obama.
Oder Obama ist schuld.
Am Ende hat eine Frage gestellt Wir hören seine Frage nicht sondern wir hören nur wie anschließend Mary Scandlines darauf reagiert.
Von Pennsylvania.
Bases.
Er hat aus irgendwelchen Podesta Emails irgendwas. Das war schon echt hart und sie macht diesen kleinen Kommentar total aus.
So ähnlich ging es auch am Anfang schon los. Wir hören mal eine Minute aus dem Anfang. Die Republikaner haben den Ton von Anfang an so gesetzt wie wir jetzt schon gehört haben denn das ist kleiner Kim Gordon einstieg. Diese ganze Szenerie.
Ramazan.
Bis zu hundert Milliarden Bratwürste eingeladen bis zugeschaltet. Das ist eine Begrüßung.
Und die machen dieses Affentheater.
Die Republikaner machen Politik Sabotage Das ist keine politische Partei.
Und das muss man auch noch mal ganz deutlich sagen. Gerade aus dieser europäischen Sicht die Demokraten machen jetzt Wahlkampf und da muss man nicht die ganze Zeit.
Die haben ja wieder die Linken herausgedrängt und hier und da Nee das ist halt einfach eine Plattform und da setzt sich irgendwie mehr durch und das wird dann intern ausgekungelt und öffentlich ausgetragen.
Manche wie diesen öffentlichen Wumms mit dem sie da eingehen.
Andere versuchen es dann hintenrum. Am Ende sind die Resultate so entscheidend ohne dass wir als Publikum vorher sehen können wie das so entsteht.
Ja es ist jetzt das Silicon Valley mit Pamela Harry's auf dem Vizeposten Wir wissen gerade Vizeposten ist nicht so entscheidend.
Entscheidend ist dann was weiß ich wer wird Handelsminister Wer wird Finanzminister wer wird Wirtschaftsminister das entscheidet sich aber erst nach der Wahl.
Also muss man jetzt erst mal abwarten und so. Man kann jetzt kein großes Urteil über Cobains Kandidatur irgendwie fällen.
Es ist nur ganz wichtig dass die Demokraten einfach mal regieren das ist auch für uns Europäer entscheidend weil die Republikaner machen so was Trump macht seit vier Jahren so eine Politik hier einfach keine Politik.
Verklagt Twitter vor dem Supreme Court weil er wieder Leute blocken will.
Bei den Demokraten ist einfach Sachverstand und kämpfen das so aus In solchen Szenarien wo keiner hinschaut und so weiter.
Ich meine das sind eigentlich klaren Strukturen. Man kann sagen Das sind eigentlich die Handlanger von Clans die jetzt entsprechendes Theater dort aufführen.
Ja genau.
Man kennt das aus Mafia filmen wenn es dort zu Gerichtsverhandlungen kommt dann sind die ja ähnlich.
Galan denkt heute gibt es eine Gerichtsverhandlung für mein Gallwitz da gehe ich doch nur hin und melde einen kleinen Beitrag an.
Ja
Der Richter dann so was melden sie ja an das gibt's nicht.
ja ja.
Gehen Sie mal wieder. Genauso,
schlimm aber auch je nachdem wenn die Demokraten da mal wieder regieren und sich auch ein bisschen durchsetzen können.
Schlimm aber auch je nachdem wenn die Demokraten mal wieder regieren und sich auch ein bisschen durchsetzen können die demokratischen Mehrheiten in den Parlamentskammern werden jedenfalls überwältigend sein das hat man glaube ich in der Welt noch nicht gesehen.
Wer weiß die demokratischen Mehrheiten in den Parlamentskammern werden jedenfalls überwältigend sein das hat man in Amerika noch nicht gesehen die letzten hundert Jahre.
Was das jetzt im November bedeutet diese Wahl.
Und wir bleiben digital. Wir gehen auf die Games kommen 2019 sind 370 000 Menschen nach Köln gekommen das war jetzt wegen Coruna verständlicherweise nicht möglich.
Stattdessen hat man sich jetzt aber überlegt man könnte doch auch die Games kommen da man es doch mit Online-Spielen oder mit digitalen Dingen zu tun hat mit,
Spielkonsolen mit allem was im Internet anzutreffen ist. Doch gleich dahin.
Kann man nicht stattfinden lassen.
Wahrscheinlich wäre das die Idee schlechthin gewesen man hätte sie dort stattfinden lassen nein man hat also einen eigenen Parcour im Internet aufgebaut Man hat quasi so eine Online Messe kreiert man kann da über die Stände gehen.
Tagesschau beitragsfreien wo es um diesen Rundgang geht.
Unterwegs auf der virtuellen Gamescom im Sitzen von zuhause aus. Letzte Tests in Hamburg bei den Entwicklern. Sie haben die virtuelle Welt kreiert innerhalb von vier Monaten ist so eine digitale Messe entstanden. Zu welchem Stand wollen wir gehen.
Überall sind echte Besucher. Das heißt Die Leute können miteinander chatten können miteinander reden das was die meisten gerade aktuell am meisten fehlt der Austausch. Freunde finden sich sich treffen sich über Spieler unterhalten man kann die developed die Entwickler auch selber hier treffen im Spiel.
Ja du verdrießt schon ein bisschen die Augen und es gab im Handelsblatt einen größeren Artikel darüber über dieses Konzept und man will das eigentlich auch so als ein Zukunftskonzept für Messen sehen.
Noch war das kostenlos bis auf solche reinen Aussteller Plattform dies da auch dann zu,
betrachten gab da musste man nur zahlen aber sonst war das alles kostenlos und man hat dann auch überlegt ob man dann vielleicht in Zukunft daraus auch ein großes Geschäft machen kann.
370 000 Leute vor Ort das ist ja schön aber man könnte doch vielleicht auch 100Millionen hieß es da hundert Millionen Zuschauer anlocken die dann online zwei Dollar zahlen und dorthin gehen.
Nun ja du und ich wie Messen funktionieren. Man geht ja auf eine Messe in aller Regel nicht um sich zu informieren.
Das tut man nämlich am besten wenn man zu Hause bleibt.
Du warst wahrscheinlich auch schon auf der Frankfurter Buchmesse. Ich war auch häufig da.
Man geht ja nicht dahin weil man mal wissen will was es eigentlich bei Diogenes Hanser oder Suhrkamp erschienen.
Dann geht man zu Amazon wenn man es wissen will.
Wenn man das wissen wir oder man liest vielleicht Rezensionen sondern man geht dort hin.
Wenn man jetzt ein reiner Leser ist reines Publikum ist weil man irgendwie einen Star sehen möchte weil man irgendein Buch vielleicht signiert haben möchte.
Sagen wir mal so.
Man will den Hype haben die Branche geht dorthin weil dort Geschäfte gemacht werden aber nicht eigentlich auf der Messe sondern das Entscheidende ist Was passiert abends im Frankfurter Hof.
Man geht dahin weil da auch andere sind und man schon weiß wer sich überraschen lässt. Deswegen fand ich die Idee wie man sie jetzt so Anklang an den Messestand sind schon welche mit denen kann man einen Schatten.
Ja da sind schon welche aber die sind ja nicht wirklich da und deswegen ist auch die eigene Anwesenheit so ein bisschen.
Das nenne ich wirklich.
Und man kann das Chatten und so. Naja ich bin dann doch erschüttert darüber dass man so sehr daran glaubt dass man glaubt etwas ersetzen zu können was ja nur funktioniert dadurch dass man überhaupt einen solchen Hype kreiert.
Mir wurde das dann auch gesagt von Leuten die früher auf der Gamescom waren naja Games kommen sieht dann für die Fans vor allem so aus dass man irgendwo drei Stunden lang ansteht um,
ein Mörsch zu kaufen den man sonst nirgends bekommt und der dann Messe exklusiv verkauft wird.
Oder man kann irgendein Spiel dann testen nur damit man mal ganz kurz Der erste war.
Aber es geht überhaupt nicht darum jetzt in einen Warenaustausch zu treten was sich auch daran zeigt,
was sie ja dann eben noch angeboten haben was bei YouTube abrufbar ist nämlich an dieser Art Konferenz einem Format bei dem Politiker interviewt werden Entwickler und so weiter und man schaut mal auf aufruft zahlen.
Wir hören jetzt einen Beitrag der am häufigsten aufgerufen wurde und da sprechen wir von 2000 aufrufen.
Das ist nämlich jetzt unser Minister Heiko Maas der wird da interviewt denn auch das Auswärtige Amt hat sich gedacht Gamification da sind wir dabei.
Effiziente Außenpolitik Auswärtige Zusammenarbeit mit Russland und Deutschland Agentur entstanden ist und das Ganze wurde vom Auswärtigen Amt. Was genau soll das Spiel.
Augmented reality game das in Zusammenarbeit mit dem Art Directors Club für Deutschland und der Agentur Artificial Rome entstanden ist.
Und das Ganze wurde vom Auswärtigen Amt gefördert. Was genau soll das Spiel denn vermitteln oder was war zumindest die Idee.
Deutschland hatte in der zweiten Hälfte dieses Jahres die Ratspräsidentschaft innerhalb der Europäischen Union und deshalb ist Europa für uns.
Erfahrung ist nicht schlecht.
Heiko Maas Was soll denn das Spiel was. Da muss man schon ein paar Knoten im Kopf irgendwie.
Ein großes Thema. Und wir glauben fest daran dass die jungen Menschen die Zukunft Europas entscheiden aber auch Europa über die Zukunft von jungen Menschen entscheidet.
Ich glaube dass es da ganz großes Interesse gibt bei vielen jungen Menschen.
Aber es ist manchmal schwer zu verstehen was in Brüssel geschieht.
Und du weißt die jungen Menschen warten auf nichts sehnlicher als auf das große erklärt Wasserspiel.
Heiko Maas.
Der Europäischen Union oder was wir machen in der Ratspräsidentschaft und deshalb versuchen wir mit dem was wir mit personelles auf den Weg gebracht haben das was Europa ausmacht auch jüngeren Menschen näherzubringen.
Denn es gibt viele die all das was unser Leben schön macht dass Demokratien leben in liberalen Rechtsstaaten.
Dass es so etwas wie Reisefreiheit gibt das hat alles was mit Europa zu tun.
Und das wissen wollen wir versuchen auch mit Spaß nämlich beim Gamen zu vermitteln.
Wenn man jetzt zu viel sagen würde Wir möchten gerne so ein richtig fettes Blockbusters Spieler mehr Tiefgang haben.
Im besten Fall weltweit erfolgreich sein.
Es wird jetzt Ihnen überlassen. Das Setting können sie selber auswählen so je nachdem welches Land welches Universum und die wichtigsten Mechanismen des Spiels könnten sie auch bestimmen wie sehr ihr Spiel aus.
Ja das ist jetzt sehr sehr spannend denn er wird ja jetzt eigentlich gefragt. Machen Sie mal eine Utopie.
Machen Sie mal eine Utopie wie sähe Euro nicht nur ein Spiel aus sondern Wie sähe Europa aus. Wie könnte dann auch eine Politik aussehen hinter der jetzt Heiko Maas alleine steht der entwickelt das jetzt.
Und jetzt kommt die großartige Antwort von Heiko Maas.
Ist es ein bisschen schwerer Wer nicht Experte genug um das so etwas aufzubauen.
Aber es müsste internationalen Charakter haben es müsste ich interkulturell sein.
Glaube so wie wir im Moment auf der Welt alles geschieht es müsste auch irgendwie interreligiöse sein.
Das glaube ich viel erklärt wie Menschen funktionieren Es kann auch um Gewinnen und Verlieren gehen finde ich auch dass diese emotionale Komponente des Schließer wie auch das Spielen der Leute zusammen gegen andere die sich zusammengetan haben.
Das finde ich alles spannend aber es muss vor allen Dingen irgendwie immer Grenzen überschreiten Grenzen die es auf der Welt gibt zwischen den Ländern gibt vor allen Dingen die die wir in den Kopf haben denn da,
gibt es noch viel zu viele und bedauerlicherweise gibts ja auch politische Kräfte in Deutschland in Europa überall die nichts Besseres zu tun haben um diese Grenzen wieder aufzubauen und Menschen gegeneinander auszuspielen.
Die unterschiedliche Herkunft haben unterschiedliche Religionen.
Dagegen muss man etwas tun und das geht nur wenn man Grenzen überwindet in allen Beziehungen und alle Spiele die dazu einen Beitrag leisten.
Die traurigste Antwort der Welt die man da geben kann.
Aber Hammer. Er tut mir auch richtig leid man spürt so richtig wie er lieber einen Termin bei Lawrow hat als sie hier Oger hat Saisonspiele entwickeln dass er Grenzen überwinden und alles unter.
Ist.
Es ist ganz ganz grausam wie die Politik versucht sich irgendwie an diese Gaming Branche anzubiedern.
Dann aber auch nicht in der Lage ist das vernünftig zu tun. Und ja wir hören aber noch weiter denn er war nicht der einzige Politiker sondern auch an die Scheuer und Dorothee Bär,
waren zu Gast und haben auch so Entwickler-Team besucht.
Da gibt's so Videos wo man dann mal schnell durch einen Korridor läuft und dann erstaunt auf den Monitor blickt solche Sachen Man kann sich vorstellen und würden jetzt erst an die Scheuer.
Heute startet die zweite Phase der Gams Förderung des Bundes mit mehr Geld für die einzelnen Projekte und einem schnelleren Verfahren.
Heute startet die zweite Phase der Games Förderung des Bundes mit mehr Geld für die einzelnen Projekte und einen schnelleren Verfahren.
Die Europäische Union hat ihr Okay dazu gegeben. Wir können jetzt Computerspiele mit Beträgen in Millionenhöhe fördern.
Die Europäische Union hat ihr Okay dazu gegeben.
Wir können jetzt Computerspiele mit Beträgen in Millionenhöhe fördern.
Insgesamt stehen uns dafür bis 2023 jedes Jahr 50 Millionen Euro zur Verfügung und damit können Entwickler und Studios ihre Ideen ab dem 28.
Insgesamt stehen uns dafür bis 2021 jedes Jahr 50 Millionen Euro zur Verfügung.
Damit können Entwickler und Studios ihre Ideen ab dem 28. 50Millionen.
50 Millionen. Ein wenig Geld.
September einreichen. Eine Förderung von bis zu 50 Prozent ist möglich.
Ja ganz genau von bis zu 50 Prozent.
Kinder Jugendliche wachsen ganz selbstverständlich mit Games auf.
Kinder Jugendliche wachsen ganz selbstverständlich auf aber auch auf Smartphones auf die meistens auch sehr intuitiv.
Kinder Jugendliche selbstverständlich auf Smartphones auf Konsolen nutzen die meistens auch sehr intuitiv und natürlich.
Smartphones Games denn auch Tablets auf Konsolen nutzen die meistens auch sehr intuitiv und natürlich auch das durfte man lange nicht sagen aber ich bin schon von Anfang an dafür gewesen dürfen Games auch Spaß machen weil wir eine ganz hohe Motivation.
Natürlich kann ich nicht sagen ob ich von Anfang an auch Spaß.
Auch Schwarz zu Weiß. Das durfte man nie sagen vorher.
Das durfte man nie sein.
Waren meine Güte natürlich mit diesem Spiel einhergehen und diese Motivation natürlich auch nutzen.
Erreichen können die natürlich mit diesen Spielen einhergeht. Und wenn wir schon diese Motivation hat dann muss man es natürlich auch nutzen um diese entfalten zu können.
Natürlich mit diesem Spiel einhergehen und diese Motivation natürlich auch nutzen um diese entfaltet.
Deswegen brauchen wir ganz dringend auch noch eine ganz andere Lehrerinnen und Lehrerbildung dass sie auch entsprechend ausgebildet werden dass Spiele in den Unterricht nicht nur integriert werden können sondern meines Erachtens auch integriert werden müssen.
Deswegen wir auch noch eine ganz andere da sie auch entsprechend ausgebildet werden dass Unterricht nicht mehr werden können sondern wir müssen.
Deswegen brauchen wir ganz dringend auch noch mal eine ganz andere sie auch entsprechend ausgebildet werden Spiele im Unterricht nicht nur sondern meines Erachtens auch.
Integriert werden müssen.
In den Unterricht.
Sie sehr intuitiv jetzt müssen sie in den Unterricht integriert werden weil man so vieles damit vermitteln kann.
Darüber ist dann natürlich auch alles selbst auszuprobieren und zieht dann eine Brille an und versucht einmal in einen Beruf einzutauchen lässt sich dann filmen wie sie dann da rennt und,
sie kann damit nämlich in einen Beruf eintauchen und sich alles viel besser vorstellen.
Spätestens nach meinem Ausflug in die virtuelle Realität steht auch fest dass ich denke ich als Elektrotechniker vielleicht nicht ganz ganz schlechte gegeben hätte.
Wenn man dann weiß nicht nur wie so ein Schaltkreis funktioniert sondern weil man gleich noch eine ganze Raumstation brechen kann dann motiviert es natürlich doppelt und dreifach da ist das alles viel nachvollziehbarer.
Die Zusammenhänge sind klar zwischen der Theorie und Praxis und es kann meines Erachtens irgendetwas analoges überhaupt nicht leisten.
Deshalb freue ich mich jetzt schon auf die Gamescom 2020 und auch auf den jüngst vom aufbläst.
Als da ganz viele praxisnahe Workshops auch für Lehrerinnen und Lehrer gäbe es jetzt schon im Unterricht einzusetzen weil Bildung ganz spielerisch in die Zukunft überführt werden kann.
Zum Nutzen nicht nur diejenigen die es beibringen sondern ganz besonders natürlich auch für die Schülerinnen und Schüler.
Also hier setze sich eindeutig irgendeine Lobby Gang durch.
Das kennen wir auch von Microsoft Idealisierung muss in die Schule aber nur die die auch dem Standard entspricht.
Wir wissen alle Office Microsoft Office ist DER STANDARD Also muss Woerth ins Klassenzimmer.
Diese Idee dass das Klassenzimmer in die Spiele wandert also das was sich Heiko Maas irgendwie die EU erklären will anhand eines Spiels okay von mir weil das kann man einfach ausschalten. Da ist kein Zwang dahinter nichts.
Der umgedrehte weg ist hochproblematisch also das Spiel ins Klassenzimmer zu bringen. Denn,
Unterricht findet ohne Bildschirm statt sondern es ist kein Unterricht Es ist Halligalli und so das kann man alles. Die Kinder haben genug Bildschirm,
wenn man in eine gute Schule geht dann sagen die Lehrer schon Na ja wir verwenden dann auch mal das Smartphone weil das ist nun mal den Computer den man dabei hat.
Aber so ein Spezial Unterrichts Digitalisierung erzeugt ist alles Zeitverschwendung.
Entweder ist das aus dem echten Leben dass dann das eigene Smartphone oder es ist nicht aber sowas hier.
Da zeigt sich wieder CSU. Das ist wieder klassisch CSU kam wieder.
Republikaner die sich hier eigentlich zeigen.
Ja genau da kam wieder irgendwelche Lobbygruppen ins Klassenzimmer kannst du uns das mal aufschliessen Nee wir haben aus Gründen keine,
Getränkeautomaten und ich Süßigkeiten Automaten auf den Gängen und habe auch keine Spiele der Klassenzimmer. Aber Götte.
Getränkeautomaten und sich Süßigkeiten Automaten auf den Gängen und.
Und das ist ja auch ein vollkommen falsches Verständnis von Bildung denn Bildung bedeutet ja dass man abstrahieren kann dass ich nicht überall,
durchrechnen muss sondern dass ich mir vorstellen kann wie dieses Problem zu lösen wäre oder wie es sein könnte wenn ich in einer solchen Situation bin dann geben wir es zu auch mit Brille,
bin ich immer noch von der Wirklichkeit sehr weit entfernt und ich habe mir das angesehen was sie da macht er läuft an irgendeinem Raumschiff rum das hat mit Elektrotechnik nur sehr sehr wenig zu tun was die da ausführt.
Und zugleich muss man eben auch erkennen dass nur mit Abstraktionsvermögen überhaupt sinnvoll Politik und Gesellschaft zu gestalten ist.
Ich kann nicht alles sein ich kann weder der Familienvater gerade sein genauso wie der 90-Jährige ich nicht sein kann und was weiß ich.
Es ist sowas von furchtbar und auch ist es furchtbar dass hier das Spiel ja vollkommen zweckentfremdet wird bzw. es wird einem Nutzen unterworfen.
Es gibt ja diesen berühmten Satz von Schiller aus den Briefen über die ästhetische Erziehung des Menschen dass der Mensch nur dort im vollen Sinne Mensch ist wo er spielt und,
er spielt aber nur dort wo er im vollen Sinne Mensch ist.
Und diese ästhetischen Briefe beginnen damit dass Schiller erst einmal abwarten.
Leute wie Scheuer Bär und Maass die sagen Wir ziehen jetzt mal nutzen drauf. Wir würden uns jetzt mal den Schiller an.
Der Lauf der Begebenheiten hat dem Genius der Zeit eine Richtung gegeben die ihn je mehr und mehr von der Kunst des Ideals zu entfernen droht.
Diese muss die Wirklichkeit verlassen und sich mit anständiger Kühnheit,
über das Bedürfnis erheben denn die Kunst ist eine Tochter der Freiheit und von der Notwendigkeit der Geister nicht von der Notdurft der Materie,
will sie ihre Vorschrift empfangen.
Jetzt aber herrscht das Bedürfnis und beugt die gesunkene Menschheit unter seinen tyrannische Joch.
Der Nutzen ist das große Ideal der Zeit dem alle Kräfte frönen und alle Talente huldigen sollen.
Auf dieser groben Waage hat das geistige Verdienst der Kunst kein Gewicht und aller Aufmunterung beraubt verschwindet sie von dem lärmenden Markt des Jahrhunderts.
Selbst der philosophische Untersuchungs Geist entreißt der Einbildungskraft eine Provinz nach der anderen und die Grenzen der Kunst verengen sich.
Je mehr die Wissenschaft ihre Schranken erweitert.
Erwartungsvoll sind die Blicke des Philosophen wie des Weltmarkts auf den politischen Schauplatz geheftet wo jetzt wie man glaubt das große Schicksal der Menschheit verhandelt wird.
Sehr schön dass er hier deutlich macht was eigentlich Kunst soll.
Und wir haben ja die Debatte jetzt auch wieder bei der Gamescom haben wir gleich noch einen kleinen Auszug.
Sind denn Games Kunst. Ja rechtlich gesehen und Kulturgut wie geht man damit um.
Aber dann muss man auch sagen ja die Kunst muss aber nicht immer.
Oder muss gar nicht einem Nutzen dienen muss nicht dafür eingesetzt werden.
Und dann diese Idee der Kritik die Schiller Da äußert die können wir eigentlich auch sehr schön übertragen nämlich dahingehend dass man dann immer irgendwelche Studien hervorkramen denen man sagt ja.
Die Studie beweist es doch wenn man die Kinder nun genug Computerspiele lässt dann erweitert sich dies und das Denken das ist ja auch ein eigenartiger Positivismus.
Na da hat ja die Corona Zeit jetzt die Corona Zeit hat uns ja sehr reduziert auf den Nutzen.
Ist es denn systemrelevant. War das Zauberwort. Dann hat man ja relativ früh die Schulen zugemacht und dann gabs auch alle Erklärung Karl Lauterbach wurde ein Jahr lang keinen regulären Unterricht geben und die Kultusministerkonferenz hat dann gleich entschieden bis zum Impfstoff keine Schule und so,
kam zum Beispiel der Tweet von Lauterbach Es wird keine Schulschließungen geben.
Also wir können zwar den zweiten Lockhart vermeiden aber es hat keine Schulschließungen.
Und das habe ich dann mit Thomas Parkas damals noch behandelt der ja auch Lehrer ist.
Als der loggt dann losging hieß es Schule ist ja dafür da Mathe Deutsch Englisch zu lernen und es können die Kinder ja auch zu Hause Wir gehen in die Bücher und so weiter und dann kriegen das alles hin und dann nach drei Monaten lock down Was ne ganz andere Diskussion.
Da war plötzlich nicht mehr Mathe Deutsch Englisch und so.
Sondern dann hieß es Die Schule ist ja auch ein wichtiger Ort für Begegnungen außerhalb der Familie und so weiter und die ganzen sozialen Komponenten wurden plötzlich aufgezählt die auch am Anfang schon wichtig waren aber nicht thematisiert.
Und das ist wieder die Diskussion geht los mit der setzt eine Brille auf ihnen zeigen wir wie Elektrotechnik funktioniert aber was lernt man eigentlich wirklich in dem Spiel gerade in diesen neuen sozialen Spielen würde ich ganze koordinieren musste und so weiter.
Jedenfalls nicht irgendwo ein materielles Handwerk sondern da wird das ganze andere Zeug gelernt was vielleicht auch mal von Bedeutung ist.
Das wird aber dann so schön übersehen dass der Schiller das damals schon jeder wusste dass man nutzen vielleicht.
Im Zuge der mit Blick auf Frankreich geschrieben. Französische Revolution und Schiller war da ja doch sehr skeptisch ob man das einfach mal so politisch alles durchdrücken kann ob man nicht erst so etwas wie eine ästhetische Erziehung braucht.
Eine.
Genau. Man muss es. Man geht nicht ohne Grund 12 Jahre in die Schule und nicht nur die letzten drei weil man braucht ein bisschen Fundament.
Man muss,
ja die letzten drei.
Eines weiß ich auch nicht ob das immer übersehen wird aber das ist halt CSU und so hat man es halt anders.
Nun bin ich bekanntlich kein Gamer und habe mich bei der Gamescom dann mit vielen vielen Dingen dort beschäftigt aber auch schnell den überblick verloren was ist da eigentlich wichtig was zählt.
Mir fiel irgendwie auf dass da auch gar nicht viel Relevantes passiert ist.
Ich habe dann mit einem Gamer gesprochen mit Florian Reichs Land mit dem ich lange geübt.
Den findet man bei Twitter dem sollte man da folgen weil der wirklich interessante Dinge auch selbst macht der hat nämlich einen Youtube-Kanal mit Freunden der heißt Akim wo Videospiel erzählte mir dann ebenso einiges über die Games kommen.
Er war da auch schon zu Gast und war jetzt virtuell dort unterwegs und hat sie wenn er sie als Gast besucht hat dann wahrgenommen mit diesem ganzen Hype und jetzt nicht.
Und dann habe ich ihn auch gefragt wie er das dann einschätzt jetzt 50 Millionen Games Förderung und so.
Dann hab ich ihn doch gebeten dass wir uns doch mal kurz in einem Clip zu fassen.
Er hat das dann nochmal eingesprochen für mich für uns.
50 Millionen Euro. Das hört sich nach ganz schön viel Geld an die da in die Entwicklung von deutschen Computerspielen gesteckt wird.
Aber ist das wirklich viel Geld für die Videospiel Industrie. Das Online-Portal Statista schätzt die Konsumenten Ausgaben für Videospiele in Deutschland für das Jahr 2023 auf zirka fünf Milliarden Euro.
Aktuell wird mit dem Verkauf von Videospielen in Deutschland ein Umsatz von zirka einer Milliarde Euro erzielt.
Jetzt könnte man davon ausgehen dass sich die Umsätze bis 2023 um zirka vier Milliarden Euro steigern werden.
Wichtig ist jedoch worin sich diese Umsätze aufschlüsseln. Konsumenten Ausgaben sind keinesfalls das Gleiche wie die Verkäufe von Videospielen.
Der Umsatz der mit Verkäufen von Videospielen erzielt werden kann ist seit 2008 ein rückläufiger Trend.
2008 betrug dieser Umsatz 1,6 Milliarden Euro in Deutschland während er im Jahr 2019 nur noch zirka eine Milliarde Euro ausmachte.
Ganz anders sieht das bei den illegalen Verkäufen bekannt als Micro Transaktionen aus.
Im selben Zeitraum von 2008 bis 2019 hat sich deren Umsatz explosionsartig gesteigert während 2008 lediglich 53 Millionen Euro mit Micro Transaktionen umgesetzt wurden konnten sind es 2019 2,2 Milliarden Euro.
Und das allein in Deutschland klar wird an der Betrachtung dieser Zahlen dass womit Geld gemacht wird in der Videospiele Industrie ist nicht der Verkauf von Computerspielen.
Womit wirklich Umsätze in Milliardenhöhe erzielt werden sind Micro Transaktionen die Spielern den Kauf von unterschiedlichen Gegenständen ermöglichen.
Diese Gegenstände können zum Beispiel ein neuer Skin für den Lieblingswörter oder ein zeitlich befristeter Zugang zu einem stetig belohnten Fortschritt System bekannt als Battle Pätz sein.
Die vorgestellte Förderung ist ein Tropfen auf den heißen Stein der den kleinen Studios im Kampf um die begehrte Aufmerksamkeit der Spieler und Spielerinnen kaum eine wirkliche Hilfe sein wird.
Das Bundesinnenministerium für Verkehr und Digitales unter Andreas Scheuer lässt sich für die verhältnismäßig späte Begeisterung für Computerspiele bejubeln.
Die Förderung ist im Verhältnis zu den Umsätzen der Videospiele Industrie ein schlechter Scherz.
Wirklich interessant sind dagegen die Beiträge im parallel stattfindenden Gamescom Congress.
Der Deutschlandchef von Electronic Arts schlägt zum Beispiel Herrn miteiner vom Bundesinnenministerium für Verkehr und digitale Infrastruktur vor.
Deutschland solle sich doch mehr ein Vorbild an Kanada nehmen.
Die Kanadier wären Pioniere in der Senkung der Unternehmensbesteuerung unter den G7-Staaten.
So schön die Förderung und Anerkennung von Spielen ist das worum es wirklich geht ist nicht die Kunst sondern die Umsätze wie die durch Micro Transaktionen.
Diese lohnen sich besonders wenn die Unternehmen nicht so stark besteuert werden.
Wer jetzt also ganz außer sich ist vor Begeisterung für Andreas Scheuer der schaut wohl nur.
Wir haben einen extremen Markt bei diesen Miko Transaktionen und das ist auch so,
programmiert muss man sagen dass dort junge Leute oder auch ältere Leute geradezu süchtig werden nach diesen Spielen und aber um weiterzukommen.
Eben solche Transaktionen tätigen müssen von zwei drei fünf Euro um das nächste Level zu bekommen um dann aber auch ein Upgrade zu bekommen um andere Gewänder tragen zu können andere Figuren spielen zu können.
Er war einer derjenigen die am meisten dafür Geld ausgegeben haben. Heinz-Christian Strache.
Stimmt ja genau das waren Unsummen.
200 000 Euro im Monat für Candy Crush oder irgendwas eine andere Zahl das habe ich gestern erst gelesen.
Ja ja ja und eine andere Zahl ist mal nicht sogar Fortner hat er nicht gefunden.
Da hat sie diese Handyspiele irgendwie aber bei Fortner. Es werden jeden Tag mehrere Zehntausend oder einen Monat weniger sein. Jedenfalls sehr viel Accounts immer hin und her Getreidegasse.
Aber bei Fortuna es werden jeden Tag mehrere Zehntausend oder illegal sein jedenfalls sehr viele Accounts.
Und dieser Gesamtmarkt an hergestellt werden beläuft sich auf eine Milliarde Dollar im Jahr.
Und dieser Gesamtmarkt an Hausjell hergestellt werden beläuft sich auf eine Milliarde Dollar im Jahr.
Einfach nur dass man soweit hoch gelächelt sagt meine Kohle rüber.
Zack schiebt man Kohle rüber. Mit der Figur weiterspielen die man sich erarbeitet hat. Unglaublich.
Mit der Figur weiterspielen.
Das heißt man kann doch davon ausgehen dass das viele Klick Worker gibt. Im Prinzip die das machen um das dann zu verkaufen.
Du hast ganz Bangladesch und so weiter. Das war damals bei World of Warcraft.
Keller voll von Leuten die einfach nur den ganzen tag zocken um die Dinger dann auch relativ zügig wie es geht. Anders als die Nobis die.
Die Dinger wissen dann auch relativ zügig wie es geht als die Rubys die gerade ihr Album geschenkt kriegt.
Nicht wissen wie sie weiterkommen erarbeitet.
Die müssen ja noch ein bisschen was für die Schule tun damit sie auch noch Anwälte werden dann bekommen sie aber trotzdem die Ausstattung die kann man sich dann kaufen.
Das ist mega Business.
Ganz erstaunlich. Man hat aber auch erkannt von der Gaming Branche dass man mit Werbung doch viel machen kann dass man da die eigenen Kanäle nochmal ganz anders nutzen kann.
Wir hören jetzt mal in einen Talk rein da geht es um KitKat Die haben nämlich in League of Legends geworben das ist so ein Competitiveness Spiel.
World of Warcraft. Man muss sagen.
Man muss sagen Dashboards sind ganz ganz wichtig im Games E-Sport Games sind ganz wichtig was man darunter nicht verstehen soll ich ein bisschen Einführungen manche werden.
Was man darunter nicht verstehen soll.
Mich belächeln die Gamer sind also Dashboards meinen nicht dass man irgendwie FIFA spielt,
oder sowas sondern es gibt kann das auch sein aber das meint eben dass es wirklich eine Art Sport ist das zu spielen.
Sondern auch.
Grundsätzlich spielen muss kein Sport Spiel sein.
Das heißt Es gibt Spieler die kompetitiv einem sehr viel abverlangen die nicht einfach nur eine schöne Geschichte erzählen sondern die in erster Linie daraus bestehen dass man schnell.
Sowohl Tastenkombinationen als auch kognitiv reagieren kann mit einer großen körperlichen Anstrengung verbunden werden.
Sowohl Tastenkombinationen als auch kognitiv auf etwas reagieren kann.
Mit einer großen körperlichen Anstrengung ist das auch verbunden. Hören wir gleich jemand. Und League of Legends.
Und das ist auch Mannschafts Mannschaftssport da muss ganz strategisch miteinander aufeinander eingespielt sein.
Wie und wo die Fans oder die Community miteinander kommuniziert.
Und hier hatten wir hatten wir einen Punkt gesprochen Gemma Spotts Fans lieben z.B.
MIPS nimmt sind Bilder die halt wirklich von Fans erstellt werden.
Und wenn Ihnen manchmal die richtigen Worte fehlen um ihre Gefühle auszudrücken sind nehmens die perfekte Möglichkeit um Situationen und Gefühle zu beschreiben ohne jetzt vielleicht eine ausgefeilte Sprache zu verwenden.
Das heißt mim sind sehr einfach und zugänglich bedeutet aber auch ein bisschen über sich selbst lachen zu können.
Und das macht mir halt so authentisch. Dann haben wir gedacht Okay hier kann KitKat doch perfekt ansetzen und das passt wie angegossen weil die DNA von KitKat,
von Anfang an die Richtung links vorgab KitKat ist unprätentiös smart und kommuniziert mit einem selbst.
Und kommuniziert auf Augenhöhe.
Und dann haben wir halt die Idee entwickelt die Georg gerade auch gesagt hatte Avi Brake heißt Jeder Schirmchen das bist du halt in dem Fall braucht auch mal eine Pause.
Dann haben wir Konzepte für Videos entwickelt und diese dann umgesetzt. Das haben wir tatsächlich.
Da haben wir die Grundidee von Mehmets herausgezogen und Situationen aufgezeigt die Geimer nur sehr sehr gut kennen vom eigenen Spiel in denen sie zum Beispiel getriggert sind oder Tilt spüren oder soll die sind.
Und unsere Botschaft ist mache eine Pause gern der gönn dir ein Kitkat.
Lade deine Batterien wieder aufkomme zurück und gewinnen eine neue Perspektive Genau.
Ja wir dachten uns jetzt mal im ersten Schritt kommunizieren wir auf KitKat als Marke jetzt im Bereich Gaming und Dispatch.
Naja ich werde bei Twitter schon jede Stunde von Twitter den Hinweis im Chat Streams jetzt seit einer Stunde Trink doch mal was und so kann man ja auch alles Product-Placement mäßig.
Diese Versuche die man so machte wie.
Und sie haben das jetzt erst einmal gemacht das fand ich ganz interessant sagt von.
Sie vermitteln dass der Herr von KitKat sagt Sie haben jetzt erst einmal versucht die Marke präsent zu machen bei einer jugendlichen Zielgruppe.
Sie haben jetzt erst einmal versucht die Marke präsent zu machen.
Natürlich kann man sagen KitKat kennt ja jeder aber es sei dann doch so dass man eben so eine Marke auch wach halten muss bei jungen Leuten und dass man dann im nächsten Schritt sich auch vorstellen könnte dann einzelne Produkte zu bewerben die besonders ein jugendliches Publikum.
Natürlich kann ja jeder aber doch so dass mal eben so eine Marke auch wachhalten was bei jungen Leuten und dass man dann im nächsten Schritt sich auch vorstellen könnte einzelne Produkte zu bewerben die besonders.
Interessieren könnte aber auf jeden Fall etwas.
Interessieren könnte.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall etwas was.
Vermehrt stattfindet und es ist im Prinzip ja wie bei dem.
Im Prinzip hier bei den üblichen Sport.
Üblichen Sport dass gerade solche Marken dann dort vertreten sind.
Gerade solche Marken über Memes sonst ist immer schwierig es offenbar dazu angeregt haben dass die Leute selbst.
Das man kennt man ja vom Fußball und sonst was.
Was dann noch gesagt wurde ist offenbar dazu angeregt haben das die Leute selbst mit KitKat basteln und dadurch ein bisschen viral wird.
Basteln.
Inwieweit das jetzt tatsächlich funktioniert.
Wenn ich den Unternehmen einmal sagen Mach Bandenwerbung stellt in Fortner irgendwelche Dinge auf oder so.
Ich glaube auch dass es sinnvoller ist außerhalb.
Diese ganzen verdrehten Sachen über Memes außerhalb des Spiels was man dann in Social Media teilt das ist immer schwierig.
Das ist auch ganz schwer zu kanalisieren. Man kann aber auch anders Geld verdienen und es gab einen,
Podcast von Funk mit NO2 For You gesprochen das ist ein bekannter E-Sport klar gewesen und der ist jetzt vor allem,
Streamer und der erzählt aber jetzt erst einmal ein bisschen was von dieser E-Sport Zeit wie das so war.
Aber heißt das Es würde dich reizen es nochmal kompetitiv zu probieren.
Ja wir sind aktuell tatsächlich an der Planung. Es ist natürlich der E-Sport ist natürlich wesentlich professioneller geworden.
Wenn man sich zurückerinnert als ich angefangen hab da hat man ja die Reisen selber gezahlt und wenn man Glück hatte hat man irgendwie eine Maus gewonnen oder eine Tastatur,
oder man hat zwei Tage am Stück für 20 Euro Sachpreise oder sowas gespielt als die solche verrückten Sache und jetzt mittlerweile in den Zeiten von Esc.
Da hat man es dann schon langsam gemerkt die Teams ziehen an Ja es werden professionelle Strukturen um die Spieler gebildet.
Du hast Gaming Häuser etwas Trainingscenter und dann ist es ja jetzt immer weitergegangen das heißt für jemanden wie mich jetzt der nicht wirklich die Möglichkeit hat vier bis sechs Stunden am Tag zu trainieren,
ist es natürlich leider nicht möglich in den obersten Ligen mitzuhalten.
Ich habe erst gemerkt wie.
Wir haben dann eine vollkommene Professionalisierung die da stattgefunden hat im Bereich das heißt man macht das nicht mehr nebenher sondern man muss sich dafür entscheiden das dann auch zu werden.
Als Publikum das sieht man übersieht aber finde ich wenn er sagt trainieren und spielen Computer.
Ein riesen Publikum.
Das bleibt auch so. Nur weil dann Leute zuschauen ändert sich dieser Charakter nicht.
Deswegen würde ich immer so von diesen trainieren finde ich ist so ein Wort das ist so reserviert für andere Sachen.
Mir wurde mir wurde gesagt die trainieren tatsächlich verschiedene Dinge die können nicht mehr gestreamt werden weil es nicht beim Stream ist so dass die spielen aber die reden ja die reden ja dann und sagen So wenn du.
Gut.
Trainierst bist du so darauf konzentriert dass du nicht nebenher was erzählen kannst du musst das ganz verfolgen das heißt dass es für,
Streaming Publikum wieder vollkommen uninteressant das zu machen genauso wie wir auch nicht dabei sein wollen wie irgendein Leichtathletin,
irgendwo versucht ein paar Gewichte zu heben,
und wieder abzustottern.
Ich habe damit trotzdem immer noch irgendwie.
Das ist ja auch alles,
unglaublich anstrengend sein. Ich sehe natürlich auch eher so jemanden dort gemütlich auf dem Sofa sitzen mit einem Hand oder einer Tastatur ein bisschen herumdrücken.
Aber wenn man sich anschaut wie diese Wettbewerbe stattfinden da ist ja eher noch Marathonlauf was für mich.
Wenn ich so.
Etwas spielen. Klar das sind so manchmal. Wahrscheinlich steckt da auch Taktik dahinter.
Ich finde es auch faszinierend wenn ich jetzt auf Twitter aus Langeweile mal jemanden gucke. Mich interessieren die Let's Plays dann mehr.
Ich sehe aber auch dass wenn man Twitter anmacht und es läuft gerade irgendwo so ein richtiges Spiel also Mannschaft gegen Mannschaft da gucken dann nicht zwei oder 3000 Leute zu wie bei dem was ich dann immer gucke sondern das sind dann 60 70 000 Leute die dann weltweit das gerade gucken.
Man muss sich dann aber auch in das Spiel rein Fuchsien auch das ist so als sollte man zum Baseball gehen. Man muss die Regeln kennen man muss das Spiel kennen und muss es vielleicht sogar selber spielen wie beim Fußball. Und dann kommt man so langsam ins Gucken rein.
In der Hinsicht ist das mir immer so ein bisschen verschlossen. Aber ich finde es auch interessant wie solche Leute wie er dann darüber reden was es auch für ihn bedeutet was ich mit ihm macht.
Ihr wie strapaziert es sein kann Player zu sein.
Ich bin ein Mensch der nicht besonders gut mit Druck umgeht. Und wenn man Streamer ist Man kann sich alles selber gestalten.
Man nimmt seine welches Spielmanns in welche Arbeitszeiten oder extreme Zeiten man verwendet.
All diese Dinge Du hast keinen Druck Du machst dein eigenes Ding.
Aber ist es nicht quasi auf Dauer auch ein bisschen stressig oder kommt der Druck beim Streaming nicht von außen von der Plattform.
Wenn du Ich kenne jetzt keine genauen Zahlen aber ich habe jetzt schon öfter von verschiedenen Schiemann gehört dass wenn du irgendwie mal eine Woche Urlaub machst dass dann die Zahlen massiv einbrechen und,
du quasi dazu gezwungen bist letztendlich 365 Tage im Jahr zu streamen. Wie ist das bei dir oder wie siehst du das.
Das liegt ja praktisch Marktführer stimmen konnte und ich meinen YouTube Gaming ist auch sehr sehr groß darf man nicht vergessen.
Aber Twitch arbeitet ja über das Titz Prime Subsystem.
Das heißt man kriegt praktisch wenn man Amazon Prime Kunde ist kriegt man eine kostenlose Subskription jeden Monat und diese werden aber nicht automatisch verlängert.
Das heißt wenn du mehr Sky du immer da bist dann kriegst du mehr Subskription weil du dann bessere überschneidungen mit den Leuten die diese Prime Abos haben.
Das heißt Es ist tatsächlich so Wenn du wenn du eine Woche nicht da bist dann verlierst du bestimmt 15 prozent deiner Subscriber,
ungefähr für den Monat meistens Couverts dann wieder und baut sich wieder auf aber es macht einem natürlich trotzdem enormen Druck im Ersten.
Im ersten Moment und stresst sich das noch oder ist es mittlerweile so dass du denkst.
Dass der Erfahrungswert der vergangenen Jahre und Monate gezeigt hat dass dann nicht plötzlich alles auf einmal vorbei ist sondern dass erstens die SAPs wiederkommen und dass zweitens noch genügend SAPs übrig bleiben dass sowas auch mal leisten kannst.
Also ich selber mach eigentlich fast nie Urlaub.
Das ist eines meiner großen Erfolgsrezepte ist dass ich seit fünf Jahren ungefähr durchschnittlich sechs Stunden am Tag sieben Tage die Woche Stream.
Sieben Tage die Woche. Fünf Jahre lang sechs sieben Stunden.
Ich denke ja immer es muss ja auch wirklich Leute geben die es gucken.
Und das scheint der Fall zu sein und dem Herrn geht es eine schlechte erwähnt es dann auch in dem Gespräch dass er ein Haus für sich gekauft hat in München und noch ein Mietshaus hat und auch in Aktien investiert.
Er wird ganz gut über die Runden kommen aber es ist ja wirklich.
Klingt nicht nach einem guten Lebenswandel.
Ja aber es muss ja ein Publikum dafür geben. Das ist ja erstaunlich.
Klar aber guckt man halt Bienen zu.
Mir ist aufgefallen bei Twitter ist gar nicht so entscheidend wer da gerade spielt. Ich habe so ein damals gehabt dort habe ich gerne zugeguckt. Aber im Grunde macht das.
Mir ist aufgefallen bei Fritsch ist gar nicht so entscheidend zu spielen. Ich habe so ein damals gehabt habe ich gerne geguckt.
Weil ich ja auch Leute sechs Stunden zumacht.
Leute sechs Stunden so. Man guckt mal Man nimmt sich mal eine halbe Stunde oder lässt sich berieseln.
Offenbar gibt es ja genügend die das gucken und es würde sich finanziell nicht lohnen und doch gibt es ja auch Konkurrenz nicht nur innerhalb dieser Community sondern es gibt ja auch Konkurrenz von außen,
nämlich die künstlichen Intelligenzen die können natürlich auch spielen und da gab es einen Vortrag von Jörg Müller,
der sich mit künstlichen Intelligenzen und Games auseinandersetzte.
Vortrag und eine Anekdote eher noch in Erinnerung haben.
Bewiesen hat dass sie auch Gams nutzen kann um sich selber weiterzuentwickeln.
Nun könnte das der Fall sein. Lasst uns mal reinschauen wenn wir relativ schnell merken.
Ich weiß nicht wer von euch gerne Dota spielt aber Echtzeit-Strategiespiel Fünf gegen Fünf.
Ein typisches Spiel im letzten Jahr sagt Ja wir kommen ganz nah an die Realität dran hat Open-Air an ein Projekt von Opfern Elon Musk mit unterstützt wird Dota 2 Champions geschlagen in San Francisco.
Das war eigentlich nicht denkbar warum.
Weil DotA als eines der komplexesten Strategiespiele gilt.
Damit das funktioniert musste man tatsächlich ein bisschen reduzieren Einerseits wurde für die Cahill reduziert von 112 auf 17 Charaktere das heißt etwas das die Komplexität gesenkt worden war.
17 Charaktere dann doch deutlich weniger berechnen zu lassen erfordert 912.
Umgekehrt musste aber auch für die Menschen die KI damit sie fairerweise überhaupt gegen die Menschen spielen konnte reduziert werden.
Insofern dass die KI fünf Spieler gleichzeitig simuliert die sich nicht absprechen dürfen müssen fünf KI Bots autonom handeln.
Stelle ich mir vor die können sich abstimmen hat der Mensch keine Chance weil die einfach viel viel schneller sich abstimmen können als wir wenn beispielsweise sprechende oder Kommandos geben.
Und tatsächlich wurde auch die Geschwindigkeit zugunsten der Menschen verlangsamt das ist natürlich ein trauriges Spielchen.
Das heißt also die KI dürfte nicht so schnell rechnen wie sie rechnen kann weil der Mensch schnell verarbeiten kann und dann das Zugverhalten einfach.
Ja wir haben hier nochmal ganz deutlich die Vorteile der KW.
Aber wenn du nicht zugucken kann weil es zu schnell geht das ist ja so als würde man Börsenaufsicht beim High Frequency Trading sein alles passiert innerhalb von Sekunden.
Aber 112 verschiedene Figuren gibt ja das muss man auch alle kennen wenn man zuschaut sonst macht es wenig Spaß.
Man versteht dann nicht was passiert wenn sie es blitzen und.
Na ja das hab ich mir jetzt auch nochmal erklären lassen von Florian reißend und zwar ist es ja so dass man nicht.
Zwar ist es ja so dass man nicht so wie man im Kino ist es so ich jede Woche in meinem Film oder dann habe ich vielleicht Paintings Regisseur.
So wie man im Kino ist es so Ich gehe jede Woche in einen Film oder dann hab ich vielleicht paar Lieblings Regisseure aber es ist ja beim Spielen oft so dass manche die Treue halten einem einzigen Spiel.
Aber es ist ja beim Spielen so dass manche die Treue halten. Einer spielt.
Das heißt es ist nicht so dass die alle zwei Wochen neues Spiel kaufen wie wir ja erfahren haben diese Micro Transaktionen sind auch das entscheidende deshalb sondern man spielt fünf sechs Jahre das Spiel und dann kennt man noch die 122.
Na ja.
Es stimmt Manche sind ja auch so gefesselt von so Browsergames die ja wirklich super unterkomplex sind.
Folgendes heraus dass das System viele viele viele Spiele gespielt hat in der Summe so viel wie 10000 Jahre.
Ich sage nur 10000 Jahre wie die KI im Grunde genommen Trainings Daten gesammelt hat und aus diesen 10000 Jahren spielen sich mal vorstellen 10 000 Jahre Spiele müssen.
Da konnte dann die KI alle Muster lernen und diese Muster umsetzen in einen entsprechenden Algorithmus der dann in einem Fünf gegen Fünf die Helden geschlagen.
Was wenn man das wenn man das jetzt nochmal weiterverfolgen waren viele Berichte in den Medien.
Dann könnte man sogar feststellen dass es bis zu der bis zu dem Punkt am Anfang wurde nur ein 1:1 gewonnen.
Das ist inzwischen bedeutet dass man wenn man wenn man es gelesen hat nach Angaben der Betreiber die KI in zehn Monaten Trinkens Partien durchgeführt hat.
Ob dieses Modell und auf das Duell gegen die Menschen sich vorzubereiten.
Mit fünf und vierzig tausend Jahren Spielerfahrung 45000 Ja.
Es müsste ja mal klar machen wieviele Spiele könnte man in 45 000 Jahren spielen. Der Mensch kann ja nicht 24/7.
So ist es halt.
So ist es halt. Jetzt kann man aber sagen kann der Mensch sich damit zufriedengeben einfach nur Mensch zu sein.
Braucht nicht auch jemand wie NO2 For You ein kleines Upgrade und.
Wir hatten ja vorhin diesen Text wo die Haka der Text,
geschrieben war von einem Text Generator ehrlich sagt Wenn du zwei Teams hast die verlangsamt aber normales Fifa gegeneinander spielen warum sollte man da nicht interessiert zuschauen.
Ehrlich sagen wenn du 2 Fifa Teams hast die langsam aber normales Fifa gegeneinander spielen. Warum sollte man da nicht interessiert zuschauen.
Solange doppelte Kontingenz im Sinne von Der eine weiß nicht was andere tun halten sich alle gegenseitig überrascht.
Solange doppelte Kontingenz und der eine weiß nicht was der andere tut hatten sich alle gegenseitig zugelost und auch noch überrascht.
Solange das gegeben ist genau das was man sehen will.
Solange das gegeben ist ist ja genau das was man sehen will.
Es gibt keinen Sieger Partie weil man rastet nicht aus für einen Computer.
Es gibt kein Sieger Partie weil.
Da muss dann schon ein Mensch dahinter stecken aber ansonsten nicht.
Aber es gibt natürlich auch die Möglichkeit sich selbst zu optimieren und zu sagen Naja ich kann jetzt 6 Stunden,
streamen Ich möchte aber gleichzeitig auch noch Wettbewerbe machen aber bin ich überhaupt so gut hab ich diese Geschwindigkeit kann ich vielleicht die Geschwindigkeit die man braucht kognitiv motorisch noch erhöhen und da könnte helfen.
Wir hatten ja im letzten Salone das Buch von Slavoj žižek Hegel und Elon Musk auseinandersetze und sagt warum das alles so nicht sein kann was auf jeden Fall jetzt geschehen ist.
Elon Musk vor wenigen Tagen vorgestellt hat wie weit man inzwischen ist man hat jetzt also Chips,
einbauen können die jetzt darauf reagieren dass kann dann ausgewertet werden man kann diese Chips auch wieder entfernen und danach immer noch glückliche Schweine.
Danach gab es auch Fragen gestellt werden und die Moderatorin gibt jetzt eine Frage weiter an einen Entwickler,
und dann an den Entwickler nämlich eine Frage wurde besonders häufig gestellt.
Kann man das dann auch gut einsetzen wenn man Gamer ist.
Kemer.
Also.
Warum nicht. Der Maßstab ist dass man irgendwann mit Neuberliner.
Der Maßstab ist dass man irgendwann mit Neuro Link kann es schaffen kann dass ein gelähmter Starcraft spielen kann.
Es schaffen kann dass ein gelähmter.
Das ist sehr schön diese Argumentation zu verfolgen denn die wiederholt sich den ganzen Tag über.
Man hat sich offenbar vorher darauf geeinigt Wir sagen natürlich nicht dass man damit den Menschen optimieren kann sondern wir helfen Menschen die krank sind blind sind die irgendwelche Schwächen hat das zieht sich wirklich durch diese ganze.
Gut ist.
Durch die ganze Präsentation durch und hier geht es natürlich auch nicht darum dass man sagt Ja klar damit kann dann der Streamer 24 Stunden am Stück,
agieren oder ist dreimal so schnell sondern man sagt ja auch der gelähmte ist dann motorisch in der Lage nur durch seine Gedanken das Ganze zu steuern.
Aber.
Wenn man diese typischen Gaming also vor allem diese Ego-Shooter findet ihr auf der Tastatur,
und dann mit der linken Hand auf den Buchstaben macht man den Rest und,
man sieht ja schon dass sie so dasitzen und die Hände nun wirklich nur noch als Verlängerung des Gehirns zu brauchen ist völlig automatisiert abläuft und bei der Frage Warum kann man Fortner nicht so gut auf einem iPad spielen weil es halt keine Tasten.
Man muss halt immer genau zielen mit der Hand genauer drücken treffen und so. Das muss man ja alles nicht man hat.
Ich kann mir schon vorstellen dass es da einen großen Anreiz gibt zu sagen Wir spielen also Bildschirm reicht und der Rest wird dann halt nicht über eine Tastatur sondern ein anderes Interface gemacht.
Also eine hohe Attraktivität kennt jeder wenn man plötzlich wieder mal was Längeres tippen muss oder sogar dann hängt man sein Handy und quält sich dadurch.
Man kann natürlich diktieren auch schon wieder ein anderes Interface beim Spielen ja warum nicht.
Ich kann das nachvollziehen dass Menschen diese Frage.
Und die politische Relevanz haben wir am Anfang schon besprochen jetzt kommen wir aber nochmal auf die kulturelle Relevanz zu sprechen. Und zwar wurde von Tagesschau 24 Olaf Zimmermann interviewt vom Deutschen Kulturrat.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen einem Computerspiel und beispielsweise einem Roman oder einem Spielfilm die er ganz selbstverständlich als Kulturgüter angesehen werden eigentlich eigentlich gar nichts mehr. Wenn wir mal ehrlich sind.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen einem Computerspiel und beispielsweise einem Roman oder einem Spielfilm hierbei ganz selbstverständlich als Kulturgüter angesehen werden.
Eigentlich gar nichts mehr den Unterschied zwischen Buch und Film hat sie in der Frage schon verwischt und.
Noch etwas Gefühltes und einige werden sagen Ja ist das denn wirklich Kultur.
Einige dieser Kultur aber eigentlich keinen Unterschied mehr.
Aber eigentlich gibt es keinen Unterschied mehr.
Es ist einfach eine neue Form und wir haben immer auch eine Debatte gehabt wenn neue künstlerische Formen sich entwickelt haben erinnern Sie sich wie die Comic Skulptur aufgekommen ist da haben auch ganz viele gesagt Na ja ist das denn wirklich.
Es ist einfach eine neue Form. Wir haben immer eine Debatte gehabt wenn neue künstlerische Formen sich entwickelt haben erinnern Sie sich wie die Skulptur aufgekommen ist.
Wie gesagt wirklich so Kultur wie in diesem Jahr schon das Thema.
Kultur und so gab wie vor vielen vielen Jahren Jahrhunderten schon das Thema der Romane aufgekommen ist da haben auch ganz viele gesagt.
Ist auch Kultur und ist natürlich auch gefährlich.
Ist das denn überhaupt Kultur und ist das nicht auch gefährlich können wir nicht in eine Welt in eine virtuelle Welt abdriften.
In einer virtuellen Welt,
ja alles Kultur. Aber da muss man dann nicht forschen.
Das ist ganz ganz eigenartig dass bei dieser ganzen Debatte um die Frage,
dass Computerspiele auch als Kunst zu begreifen dass es,
eine rechtliche Geschichte das heißt wenn man das als Kunst ansieht dann fällt es unter die Kunstfreiheit dann kann dort etwas passieren innerhalb eines Spiels,
was sonst nicht geht das ist ja immer diese heikle Geschichte dann auch z.B.
Bei Performancekunst die im öffentlichen Raum statt einer Schnittstelle.
Wo haben wir es da mit Kunst zu tun oder wo müssen wir sagen da gelten jetzt wieder andere Regeln.
Ganz historisch ist eigentlich dieser Prozess gegen Jonathan Meese der ein Performancekünstler ist auf einem Podium sitzt einer Journalisten,
journalistischen Veranstaltung beim Spiegel und dort den Hitlergruß macht aber er macht ihnen dann als Performer sagt er.
Das Gericht hatte ihm ja auch Recht gegeben dass Jonathan Meese auftauchte.
Ich habe mich an einen Vorfall erinnert bei Jonathan Meese dass er auch reingekommen ist bei Remagen und hat dort auch den Hitlergruß gemacht und dann hat ihn aber ein Passant erwidert.
Und der wurde dann selbstverständlich von der Polizei geschnappt.
Das sind diese Schnittstellen aber generell kann man sagen dann gilt das eben für die Kunst mit dem Kulturbegriff ist es wieder was anderes.
Der Kulturbegriff ist ja einer dem man erst einmal ganz weit fassen kann dann ist alles irgendwie Kultur.
Die Eisdiele ist genauso Kultur wie das Schwimmbad ist Kultur gehört zum kulturellen Leben der Mittelaltermarkt weiß ich nicht was der Flohmarkt und da gehört dann auch die Buchkultur die Theater Kultur dazu.
Wenn man jetzt aber Kultur einführt man sagt Man muss jetzt über Qualität sprechen dann gibt es ja doch eben diese große Frage Was wird dann da unter Kultur oder Hochkultur gezählt.
Und dann würde ich sagen fällt da ganz ganz viel bei Computerspielen Weg wie wir ja auch nicht sagen würden.
Ja Fifty Shades of Grey Das ist aber Kultur.
Das Kunstkritiker Urteil das dann eigentlich kommen muss und jetzt muss es selbstverständlich.
Aber auch wenn so ein Interview geführt wird auch um die Ego-Shooter gehen.
Besonders umstritten sind aber nach wie vor sogenannte Ego-Shooter spiele nur kurz zur Erklärung heißt wenn ein Spieler aus der Ich-Perspektive mit Waffen anderer Spieler,
bekämpft und auch tötet da hat nun Innenminister Seehofer zum Beispiel gefordert nach dem rechtsradikalen Terroranschlag,
auf die Synagoge in Halle im vergangenen Jahr die Gamer Szene stärker in den Blick zu nehmen weil der Attentäter nachweislich solche Ego-Shooter spiele gespielt hatte.
Wie gefährlich sind Ego-Shooter Games.
Ich glaube wir müssen. Ich habe ja schon gesagt auf den Jugendschutz achten.
Aber es gibt in jeder Kunstform gibt es Gutes und Schlechtes Ich spiele keine Ego-Shooter.
Mich langweilt das auch auf Menschen zu ballern und ich kann auch nicht den wirklichen Sinn darin erkennen aber ich muss das ja auch gar nicht. Es gibt.
Dann sind sie leider der falsche Ansprechpartner. Muss man eigentlich sagen mir.
Muss man eigentlich sagen Florian hat mir das auch so gesagt. Ego-Shooter sind wahnsinnig innovativ und interessant zu spielen.
Da würde ich auch Sport Akzeptieren im Sinne von Sport das muss man trainieren weil das ist auch wirklich.
Ja viel viel mehr gute Spiele als schlechte Spiele.
Viel viel mehr gute Spiele als schlechte Spiele.
Deswegen haben wir in unserem neuen Handbuch Lebenskultur.
Deswegen haben wir in unserem neuen Handbuch auch einen Vorschlag für einen Kanon gemacht da kann man sich mal anschauen was man denn als Einstieg in den Computerspiele Bereich spielen kann ohne solche.
Auch einen Vorschlag für einen Kanon gemacht da kann man sich mal anschauen was man denn vielleicht als Einstieg in den Computerspiele Bereich spielen kann ohne solche negativen Spiele spielen.
Negatives.
Negative spiele.
Das heißt wir wollen jetzt positive spiele. Wir hatten jetzt beim Mars schon Positives spielen der machte uns eine grenzenlose Welt.
Wir hatten ein positives.
Konstruktives Spiel.
Ein konstruktives Spiel. Dabei vergisst man ja dass es bei den meisten Spielen in irgendeiner Weise um Gegnerschaft geht mitunter auch geht es um Feindschaft.
Dann wollten wir die Nutzen orientierten Spiel von Scheuer und Bär natürlich nicht vergessen.
Und jetzt haben wir hier positive Spiele die uns gezeigt werden und dann denke ich mir wie weit kann eigentlich so ein Funktionär,
von der Wirklichkeit entfernt sein dann gibt man jetzt ein Handbuch raus und hat dort jetzt eine Kanone Bildung also eine lange Debatte ja in der,
Literaturkritik brauchen wir brauchen wir ein Literatur.
Ich denke schon.
Und das macht man jetzt da man eben nicht man will dass es Kultur ist.
Man Welt aber jetzt nicht nach ästhetischen Kriterien denn ich bin mir sicher auch wenn ich mich wenig auskenne.
Bin ich mir sicher dann müssten Ballerspiele darunter sein weil sie innovativ sind weil sie eine wahnsinnige ästhetik haben.
Macht man aber nicht sondern man sucht dann wahrscheinlich eher so ein Spiel aus wie Heiko Maas es gefallen wird. Wir bauen uns ein buntes Europa.
Ja wenn man mal vergleicht dieses Liegeflächen ist total also da wo du diesen diese Pooh Vogelperspektive von Omars und fünf gegen fünf gespielt wird.
Das ist nicht ästhetisch ansprechend. Da sind keine Details. Das ist einfach nur ein Spielfeld und Plazierungen und dann halt Action die da stattfindet im Vergleich zu diesen ganzen was ich Hello,
Call of Duty vielleicht nicht so sehr das ist dann doch ein sehr reduziertes Geballer.
Destiny ja solche Spiele die wirklich ein Erlebnis wo auch die Größe des Monitors eine Rolle spielt.
Zu präsent ist in dieser Welt das Spiel der ästhetik. Da geht es ja nur darum Wie sieht eine post apokalyptische Welt aus und der ganze Kram. Wie sieht es im Weltraum aus.
Umso mehr als in diese Richtung geht. Da spielt dann wirklich nur abschiessen eine Rolle.
Umso weniger kann man da diesem Argument folgen dass es nicht ästhetisch zugeht. Außerdem wird ja dieses Kälin sowieso völlig missverstanden.
Das ist ja einfach nur dieses Finale ok. Erfolg eingestrichen dann gibts in positiver Richtung nicht alle Spiele laufen jemanden abwerfen getroffen oder nicht das ist halt sehr binär.
Dieses beziehen was aus dem Gürtel raus eine Fahne oder so dann haben wir ist auch sehr Binär und dieses okey hat den Kopf getroffen die Spieler fällt um Ja oder Nein.
Wenn man jetzt eine positive Richtung sieht wie Heiko Maas Wir bauen hier eine EU ja wie werden dann drin gepflanzt im Sinne von Jetzt haben man den Plenarsaal fertiggebaut oder sowas.
Das finde ich bei bei Fortner oder auch bei,
meinen Krafft so interessant dass man dann doch so dieses gestalterische Element drin hat das die Welt noch nicht fertig ist sondern man baut sie erst aber das ist super aufwendig da dann Erfolgsmensch da unterzubringen weil es unendlich bauen nähernde ist ja auch das Prinzip der Sache,
dass man das so übersieht dass es in diesen Spielen dann dann auch mal auf diese Momente dass man so von Kill zu Kill sozusagen sich vorarbeiten.
Und dass das nun wirklich relativ wenig mit Töten zu tun hat im Sinne von Töten Ich habe das Wort jetzt auf Deutsch übersetzt Nee sondern diese situative Erfolgserlebnis gibt.
Aber das ist ein typischer Politiker reden darüber. Das ist so frustrierend.
Das sind die typischen reden die man aber genau so in den 80er Jahren über Action Horror und Western Filme erleben konnte und man kann sich ja eigentlich nur davor fürchten.
Wahrscheinlicher.
Aber es ist als würden die in der DDR Beatmusik Redner auf diesem Niveau.
Ja ja ja ja ganz exakt so und ich hab mir dann noch mehr auf der Gamescom angeguckt hatte aber dann irgendwie diesen Verdacht da geschieht ja gar nichts Relevantes dann wurde,
der dritte Trailer von einem Spiel vorgestellt bei dem der erste Trailer schon im Dezember da war und dann auch.
Was ist eigentlich mit den Konsolen die zu Weihnachten kommen. Da gabs dann so gut wie nichts Neues.
Und dann hat Florian Reisernte mir das alles nochmal so erklärt dass eigentlich das Interessante bei dieser Gamescom war dieses laute Schweigen das man da gehört hat das ebenso wenig wirklich passiert.
So irrelevant ist. Und Florian fasst das jetzt nochmal zusammen wie er die Gamescom jetzt erlebt hat.
Das worauf bei Messen wie der Gamescom in Köln und der I-III in Los Angeles geblickt wird sind die Neuerscheinungen sowohl am Beispiel der Spiele als auch der neuen Konsolen lässt sich beobachten wie die großen Unternehmen der Branche einen eigenen Weg gehen.
Dieses Jahr erscheinen reihenweise großer Titel da normalerweise das Sommerloch sein soll.
Neben dieser Verschiebung tut sich etwas im Vertrieb von Spielen während Sony weiterhin einen Schwerpunkt auf die Veröffentlichung von exclusiv Titeln setzt die eben nur auf der Playstation gespielt werden können.
Geht Microsoft einen anderen Weg. Spiele von Microsoft werden direkt mit Erscheinen im Abo Dienst Gamepads veröffentlicht.
Der Xbox Gamepads ist ein Abo Dienst vergleichbar mit Netflix.
Die Spieler und Spielerinnen bezahlen einen monatlichen Beitrag von zirka 100 Euro und haben dafür die Möglichkeit Spiele wie den Flight Simulator der in der Standard Edition 69 Euro 99 kostet direkt zu spielen.
Sony bietet neben den exklusiv Titeln einen ähnlichen Dienst an der PC heißt jedoch weit weniger populär ist der Gamepads lässt sich aktuell auf dem PC sowie auf der Xbox Konsole benutzen.
Microsoft hat angekündigt dass es in Zukunft möglich sein wird die Spiele auf mobilen Geräten zu streamen.
Interessant ist dabei wie sich der Krieg der Konsolen hin zu einem Konflikt der digitalen Plattform verschiebt.
Dieser Kampf ist um die Plattform Bindung der Kunden. In Zeiten des digitalen Kapitalismus bestimmen Plattformen in Form von Abo Diensten die Macht Herrschaft größer als die Hardware der Konsolen.
Konsolen sind für die Unternehmen bisher ein kostspieliges Unterfangen gewesen welches sich erst durch den Verkauf der Spiele lohnte.
Bisher überstiegen die Hardware Kosten der Konsole die des Kaufpreises.
Ein digitaler Abo Dienst ist gegenüber einer zirka 500 Euro teuren Konsole auch schon deswegen deutlich interessanter für Sony und Microsoft.
Da der monatliche Beitrag von 100 Euro eine viel geringere Einstiegshürde für neue bisher unerschlossene Konsumenten ist dass auf dieser Gamescom weder die Playstation 5.
Noch die Xbox Series X ausführlich präsentiert wurden konnte so auch als Ausdruck dieser Verschiebung zu sehen sein an der diesjährigen Gamescom lassen sich vor allem durch die Entwicklungen die nicht gezeigt werden viele Einblicke in die Zukunft des Gaming gewinnen.
Zum einen verlieren große Messen wie die Gamescom zunehmend an Bedeutung da Unternehmen Neuerscheinungen auf eigenen Events präsentieren.
Zum anderen wandelt sich der Product Kreislauf der Videospiel Industrie schleichend von einem physischen zu einem reinen digitalen Markt.
Gut sichtbar ist das an der Entscheidung von Sony die kommende Konsole auch ohne ein Laufwerk für physische Datenträger anzubieten.
Wer sich darüber wundert wieso die Konsolen und Spiele nicht in aller Deutlichkeit präsentiert wurden der muss sich im Klaren sein dass digitale Giganten wie Microsoft und Sony gerade äußerst vorsichtig eine neue Zeit des digitalen Gaming erschließen.
Was dann auch erklärt warum Microsoft jetzt gerade Fortner zur Seite springt und gegen Apple agitiert weil sie natürlich ihren Gamepads.
Microsoft hängt da ganz schön tief drin. Xbox Minecraft Fortner EPIC und das ganze Zeug.
Das ist alles so mega. Dann geht das so wenig. Ich hab jetzt auch so eine Xbox 360 und ne wie aber das reicht mir völlig.
Steffan überlegt man,
aber überlegt man der Markt. Wir sprechen da von einem Jahresumsatz 2009/10 weltweit von 15 Milliarden. Das ist wesentlich mehr als die Filmbranche.
Es ist unglaublich.
Dass sie jetzt bei Playstation diesen Weg gehen das komplett ohne Laufwerk auszuliefern. üblicherweise hat man ja immer noch so stapelweise die grünen Dinger da rumstehen jetzt wieder Xbox und. Das ist schon finde ich schon.
Da sieht man schon eine gewisse Richtung. Man wird jetzt richtig.
Aber es ist halt ich weiß nicht das ist für andere Leute.
Obwohl ich Max Payne oder so. Aber das ist ja wirklich wie so ein Film beschäftigt man sich ein Wochenende damit dann hat man es durchgespielt Man ist aber auch gut und dann kommt vielleicht in drei Jahren mal das nächste was mich interessiert oder so..
Spiele.
Zum Schluss möchte es so ist noch zum Lachen bringen.
Ja wir müssen über Lisa Eckhart trennen dachte ich mir. Denn Lisa Eckhart ist ja nun dadurch dass sie irgendwie beim Hamburger Kulturfest ausgeladen war oder so keine Ahnung.
Kurze Zeit. Der Veranstalter glaubte daran dass sie bedroht sein könnte obwohl es gar keinen Hintergrund gab man hat nur irgendwie antizipierte Es könnte ja sein dass da linke Gruppen demonstrieren.
Oder so. Und dann hat man sie ausgeladen dann gab es eben diese.
Debatte bis sich herausstellte naja so ist das ja gar nicht.
Da gab es gar keine akute Bedrohung oder was und jetzt ist sie ob sie kommt oder nicht ist egal und dann entzündete sich auch nochmal neu so ein Auftritt der schon eine Weile her ist.
Ich weiß du hast mit Weinstein und Woody Allen und Roman Polanski dieser Antisemitismus Vorwurf der da kam.
Das war insofern interessant als diese Debatte um einen Auftritt von Lisa Eckhart bei dem sie sich auf Meteo bezog.
Und dann sagte Harvey Weinstein Woody Allen Roman Polanski und dann spielt sie sowohl mit dem antisemitischen Stereotyp vom Juden der über Frauen,
hermacht als auch das antisemitische Stereotyp vom geldgierigen Juden und dann versucht sie mit diesen Klischees ein Comedy Programm zu machen und das wurde ja jetzt im Nachhinein.
Nochmal anders ausgeht bzw.
Beim ersten Mal ist es gar nicht so bemerkt worden dass es unter dem Radar gelaufen ist dann gab es jetzt eben die Interpretation dass es eigentlich antisemitisch sei.
Andere sagten nein sie greife doch nur den Diskurs auf. Ich hab mir denen dann jetzt als du dass wir sprechen über Lisa Ecker zum ersten Mal angesehen diesen Auftritt und was ich sehr merkwürdig daran finde es erst einmal so ein,
eigenartig Glucksen des Publikum das da immer sitzt und auch nicht so richtig weiß wie ihm geschieht.
Und dann tut sie so als seien diese beiden Diskurse also.
Die Juden und das Geld Juden und die Frauen als seien diese beiden Diskurse präsent gewesen während der Debatte und das ist ja nicht der Fall.
Kein Mensch hat das in irgendeiner Weise so rezipiert Kein Mensch hat gesagt Harvey Weinstein Das ist ein Jude der wurde nichts.
Das wurde nicht so rezipiert sondern es ging um diese Vorfälle die es da gab und es gab ja auch viele viele andere,
Täter die überhaupt gar keinen jüdischen Hintergrund haben.
Und sie unterstellt da etwas um dann noch ein weiteres antijüdischen Klischee mit rein zu nehmen um dann damit irgendwie zu spielen und das alles im Vagen zu lassen.
Und da würde ich sagen Das geht so nicht wenn das jetzt ein Diskurs gewesen wäre der stattgefunden hätte und sie hätte das jetzt noch einmal persifliert.
Dann kann man sagen Okay da versucht die kommen die Szene auf etwas hinzuweisen was im Diskurs sonst nicht da war.
Aber hier war es doch eher so dass sie das sich selbst aufgebaut hat.
Und wenn man sich dann selbst zwei Klischees aufbaut um dann mit denen zu jonglieren dann ist man schon in einer sehr sehr eigenartigen Ecke.
Es ist sehr eigenartig Ich weiß gar nicht wie ich auf das Thema gekommen bin. Ich habe natürlich Lisa Eckhart und so weiter.
Irgendwas Hamburger Kultur blabla eingeladen ausgeladen Antisemitismus und so weiter.
Nun wir machen es ein ganz eigenes Bild denn ich habe dann auch wirklich nur punktuell rein geguckt und war aber auch ein bisschen bestürzt ehrlich gesagt,
was da so vor sich geht im Kabarett oder wie es heute heißt und wir beginnen mal bei einem kleinen Interview das sie 2018 gegeben hat wo sie ihren Lebensplan kurz darlegt.
Es wird insgesamt vier Programme geben die auch thematisch abgesteckt sind. Jetzt habe ich gerade das zweite wo die sieben Todsünden behandelt werden.
Dann kommt das dritte mit den Tugenden und dann als viertes eine große Abschiedstour unter dem Titel Herren Mensch.
Die Suche nach einem großen Abschlussfilm.
Und damit werde ich mich dann von der Bühne relativ verabschieden.
Sie möchte das große Publikum gern nutzen weil es lukrativ ist und macht dann so viel Programme Herrenmenschen Todsünden Laster keine bisschen over the top würde ich sagen.
Joy.
Also insgesamt so eine 27 jährige österreicherin die irgendwie den deutschen Markt erobert.
Aber gut das sei ja unbenommen. Allerdings Es gibt diesen einen Auftritt die Vorteile des Lasters könnte durchaus sein dass Jugendprogramm es so als das zweite oder dritte vorgestellt hat.
Jedenfalls tritt sie damit auf und Sie hören es erst mal an schätzen wir das mal ein.
Ich habe das ein bisschen zusammengeschnitten aber nicht verfälschen sag mal so.
Dann geht es natürlich gleich um österreich Frau Eckhardt Wie lebt es sich so im Faschismus.
Wie arrogant und überheblich es in Deutschland besser werden ihre rechten die laufen ja völlig unkontrolliert und frei herum.
Wir konzentrieren sie weniger in der Regierung.
Ihre rechten auf den Straßen zerrissene Jeans dreckige Schurz unrasiert drei Tage Haar,
ihre rechten,
wie die Linken. Das hat er sicher nicht gewollt.
Aber bitte tun Sie mir einen Gefallen Nennen Sie diese rechten darf den Straßen nicht andauernd Nazis.
Ich will nicht dass man diesen lauten Pyromanen Mob in einen Topf mit meinem Großvater wirft.
Klar jeder Nazi ist Rassist aber nicht jeder Rassist ist ein Nazi so wie jeder österreicher ist. Aber nicht jeder ist reicher Ungar.
Ich meine er wäre nicht weinend durch die Straßen gezogen sich klammern dann die Deutschlandfahne um jeden Syrer an zu jammern.
Das ist unser Land.
Er hätte die Fahne genommen wer nach Syrien gegangen und hätte gesagt dass Salan echte Nazis haben keine Angst vor der Islamisierung des Abendlandes.
Echte Nazis fordern die Arisierung des morgen nicht Pegida sondern Pegida.
Da fände sich etwas spritziger.
Auch wenn man das ganze Programm guckt bleibt es bei der Aussage Die Neonazis sind ja zu schlecht angezogen und zu wenig ambitioniert.
Da kommt jetzt nicht noch irgendwie in Minute 17 ironischer Bruch oder sowas sondern sie ruht sich genau darauf aus darüber lachen zu.
Schade dass Deutschland keine Völker mehr überfällt sondern sondern sondern sie nur noch verprügelt auf der Straße. Sie glauben.
So irgendwie,
genau. Es könnte ja sein dass sie glaubt es gibt so ein tiefer liegenden Wunsch ich jetzt mal raus und ich schafft es aber mit einer tollen Pointe irgendwie wieder einzufangen oder so..
Ja
Fähigkeiten.
Aber da muss ich sagen reichen ihre Fähigkeiten nicht sondern sie macht es halt über diese ästhetische Schiene.
Nicht sondern.
Diese Sätze und so weiter und wie sie da auch so setzt.
Das ist ja jetzt auch Humor befreit. Es ist eigentlich genau nicht ausgeschlossen. Man darf ja.
Es ist vor allem deswegen nicht lustig weil wir uns über diesen Humor eigentlich verständigt haben in Deutschland. Wir haben Hitler nicht ausgeschlossen.
Man darf durchaus Hitler Witze machen so wie Harald Schmidt immer mal wieder diese kleinen Sprüche und so weiter gemacht hat.
Ständig Komödien ohne Ende.
Genau das geht durchaus aber eben auch so einer inhaltlichen Ebene.
Sie macht das ja so Sie ist ja wirklich fasziniert von der Figur Hitler als physische und auch ästhetische Gestalt und versucht dann das,
in ihren Möglichkeiten Apparat physisch zu adaptieren irgendwie ja und auch so auf der Bühne zu stehen mit großer Geste.
Ich finde da gibt es in Deutschland tatsächlich. Das hat auch Harald Schmidt nie gemacht.
Harald Schmidt hat sich einmal mit einem Hitlerbärtchen und Hut und Mantel wie ein Soldat dann als Hitler hingestellt.
Aber nur für eine Botschaft nämlich folgt nicht diesen Leuten und so weiter. Also um es genau zu brechen und genau das nicht zu machen was sie hier machen.
Ich finde hier muss man dann entweder man machts gar nicht oder es gibt schon eine laufende Debatte wie Du meinst an die man irgendwie anschließt aber die man dann auch einen Mehrwert liefert.
Aber die müssen dann auch da sein Königsklasse.
Genau das ist aber Königsklasse. Man bricht es selbst.
Man nutzt die Stunde die man hat vor Publikum selbst um das zu brechen.
Das ist einfach zu dumm. Das darf man so überhaupt nicht machen.
Mir scheint das jetzt eher so eine Image Beratung für die Identitäre Bewegung.
Im Grunde ist es leider bleibt das übrig am Ende.
Rasiert euch mal legt euch mal die Haare wieder vernünftig wie wir das früher hatten und tragt mal wieder die Mäntel von damals.
Ja so als ob das Problem an Sellner wäre dass ein Schlappschwanz ist.
Statt Jeans.
Ja ja ja.
Ist ja viel zu schlauere zu klein. Ob das so auf die Ebene macht die das. Und damit meine ich nicht.
Ja es gibt gute Beispiele wie man sich durchaus mal.
Es gibt in Deutschland ja das gute Beispiel wie man sich durchaus mal mit Hitler dann auch eine Stunde lang beschäftigen kann.
Das ist halt Serdar Somuncu der einfach sagt Okay wir lesen das jetzt inhaltlich und so genau dazu mit türkischem Hintergrund.
Kindisch hatte Mein Kampf gelesen.
Mein Kampf vor Publikum gelesen und hat es dann eben gemeinsam diskutiert.
Gemeinsam diskutieren. Aber dass man jetzt Hitler noch nochmal.
Aber dass man jetzt Hitler nochmal für ein Statement über Menschen die man aktuell auf der Straße sieht als maßgebende Figur einfach präsentiert und sagt Ihr seid ja lächerlich weil ihr seid nicht wie Hitler.
Lächerlich.
Das geht nicht das finde ich. Ich weiß auch nicht wo der Antisemitismus herkommt.
Ich kenne diese Ausschnitte nicht. Wahrscheinlich scheint es mir alles gerechtfertigt zu sein wenn ich nur.
Es gibt doch noch einen anderen Beitrag. Samira hatte eine Kolumne darüber geschrieben hat nichts gefunden und zwar hatte sie auch irgendwie gesagt dass sie als deutsche Germanistin in Paris ist.
Da verglich sie ihre Situation mit Juden die BWL studieren.
Da machte sie auch wieder diesen Diskurs Juden und Geld.
Ich dachte das ist,
an den Haaren herbeigezogen bzw. sie sucht das was sie ist sie greift sich ihre eigenen stereotyper heraus die offenbar über ihr präsent sind und dass es so kommen die muss eigentlich reagieren auf das was,
gerade im Zeitgeist ist und nicht irgendwie.
Ich gucke mal ob ich damit irgendwie ein Publikum da verschrecken kann das ja zum Teil auch schon Rentner da unten ist.
Na ja Sie nennt sich ja auch selbst so geriatrische Figur sie hat ja irgendwie lange bei ihren Großeltern gelebt 79-Jährigen und vielleicht,
projiziert sie sich einfach gerne in eine Zeit in der nun mal Hitler Kanzler war und dass sie das irgendwie verwechselt oder die Dimension unterschätzt oder sowas keine Ahnung. Jedenfalls.
Klamotten sie da trägt was das ist die Marke.
Weiß ich nicht dass sie jetzt schon so ein bisschen asiatisch aussieht.
Sie trägt sagt dass.
Sie legt sehr viel Wert drauf.
Sie sich sehr viel wert sind aber ich würde sagen es ist fast alles was sie trägt scheint mir besage zu sein.
Ja sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Naja jedenfalls ein bisschen anders nochmal in Interviews Das entschuldigt allerdings nicht davon dass wir sie jetzt einfach hier auch disqualifizieren müssen.
Es ist trotzdem ganz interessant wie sie über ihr eigenes Schaffen dann nochmal redet beispielsweise Was fasziniert Sie eigentlich so auf der Bühne und da fragt man sich ja auch Na ja wenn wir jetzt so das deutsche Kabarett beispielsweise Urban Priol,
von der Anstalt oder sowas die setzen ja wirklich voraus dass das Publikum schon informiert ist und dann nur noch mal so eine Pane bekommt und das Publikum so ein bisschen mitarbeitet ihr Blick aufs Publikum ist ein bisschen anders.
Es birgt alles was ich mir jemals erträumt habe gehört zu werden absolute Dominanz über eine Ausgelieferte Masse die eigentlich ihre Menschenrechte,
an der Bühnen Tür zu saugen abgibt und dann mit ihnen immer wieder.
An der Tür zusammen auch und wieder in einem Haarkleid Verhältnis konspiratives Gemeinschaftsleben.
In einem Herr Knecht Verhältniss und dann einem konspirativen Gemeinschaftssinn zuarbeiten das finde ich wahnsinnig spannend. Das hört auch nicht auf mich zu fasziniere.
Sie hat kein konspiratives Verhältnis mit dem Publikum so wie ich das mitbekomme sondern sie möchte es möglichst abgedunkelt. Sie sagt dann auch das macht für mich erst ab 100 Leute Sinn.
Es darf nicht zu klein sein es muss um Masse sein aber.
Aber das ist ja auch wieder so eine faschistoide Idee von Publikum.
Es kommt noch dazu.
Ja ganz bewusst. Damit spielt sie bewusst ist es auch wahnsinnig plump. Spielen kann man das nicht nennen.
Ja ich bin der Diktator oder Ich bin so Goebbels nach Goebbels Manier und fasziniere das Publikum. So versucht sie das ja jetzt zu offerieren.
Und ich soll jetzt auch dann als so Hohoho machen werde ich mich heute Abend ausliefern. Zahle ich dafür 37 Euro Ahja.
Dann.
Hat,
der Satiriker sein.
Ich weiß dass ich Satire mache. Aber ich bin mir immer unsicherer was die anderen da eigentlich veranstalten Mitbewerber oder Satiriker oder Humoristen.
Wer sich nicht konstant dieser Angst ausgesetzt fühlt der muss sich doch fragen ob man nicht vielleicht was falsch macht.
Diese Gefahr ist immer gegeben wenn man uneindeutig spricht wenn man Ambivalenzen übrig lässt.
Und das ist ja wohl das Mindeste was Kunst leisten sollte nicht irgendeine eine eine Haltung an den Tag zu legen und so und so Botschaften to go.
Das möchte ich nicht so wirklich.
Ich weigere mich so sehr gegen das Vorurteil dass mein Publikum strömt.
Ich kann es Dinge vervollständigen lassen auf ihre Art wie sie das wollen auch was ich nicht zu Ende gedacht habe oder nicht kann.
Einfach Dilemmata und interessante Widersprüchlichkeiten. Ich glaube sehr wohl dass ich sie damit allein lassen kann.
Hier sieht man mal dass es jetzt 2020 da ist sich schon im Foyer sozusagen von 2018.
Sie macht sich halt wie sie mir gefällt. Ich brauche die stumme Masse also Nini das Publikum denkt ja mit.
Und das ist auch die eine oder andere Gefahr in die ich mich begeben habe für mich aus.
Wobei der ja hier sagt richtig ist. Also wir kennen ja auch genau diese Nerv Comedy die uns jetzt sagt Hey ich erzähle jetzt mal drei Minuten was über Feminismus und du weißt Okay das weiß ich aber alles schon.
Wer das noch nicht weiß der ist auch nicht mehr zu helfen mit dem Comedy Format. Das ist ja auch ganz ganz furchtbar.
Ja
Eigentlich wollte ich eine Kolumne schreiben aber mit Comedy verdiene ich viel mehr Geld.
Genau.
Aber wenn man die Grenze sucht die man eventuell überschreiten kann das entscheidet sich dann erst später Man ist eine Gefahr eingegangen.
Ja
Das muss nicht immer die Grenze nach rechts sein zu Hitler. Es gibt da viele Grenzen Man kann sich auch mit anderen Mächtigen anlegen und so weiter. Das ist dann auch zu einfach.
Nee.
Ich glaube schon.
Sie zum Thema will sie einfach nur provozieren oder.
Sie Thema will sie einfach nur provozieren oder.
Letztlich ist das der Anspruch des Künstlers beim Zuschauer Zuhörer etwas auszulösen etwas auszulösen provozieren nicht.
Letztlich ist ja das Redler Angebot das ein Zuschauer zugearbeitet etwas auszulösen ja provozieren.
Aufzulösen.
Das ist mir tatsächlich zuwider und das finde ich unangemessen wenn man mir das unterstellt dass ich provoziere um zu provozieren. Das war niemals mein Anliegen das finde ich ästhetisch nicht wertvoll so etwas zu tun.
Das ist mir tatsächlich zuwider und das.
Das wäre.
Produziere.
Ästhetisch nicht.
Ich nicht mehr. Alles und mag es auch noch so Abwägungsprozess erscheinen wird aus einem tiefen Amtsbeginn geboren und.
Alles und mag es auch noch so abwegig und grotesk erscheinen wird aus einem tiefen anliegend geboren.
So abwegig.
Und das ist sicher nicht das der reinen Provokation.
Gut glaube ich kein Wort.
Kann man behaupten aber wenn das Anliegen nicht erkannt wird. Sie könnte dann ihre.
Aber was soll das jetzt für ein Anliegen sein wenn wir uns jetzt diesen Beitrag da,
Früher sahen die Nazis noch besser aus ansehen oder auch das andere was ich jetzt erwähnt hatte mit Weinstein und Co,
dann kann ich ja jetzt nicht sagen dass das mich auf irgendeine andere Ebene nochmal bringt sondern es kann eine Provokation im besten Falle noch auslösen dass ich dann sage hohoho.
Und dann kann ich das aber für mich selbst wieder einhegen aber davon abgesehen ob ich mich davon provozieren lasse oder nicht.
Dann kommt ja nichts noch sonst irgendwie dabei heraus. Also ich lerne ja auch nichts über mich dabei.
Es ist ja nicht wie ein Loriot der,
Hinweis auf meine kleinbürgerliche Existenz auf die ganzen Widrigkeiten des Alltags die wir alle kennen die mir sagen okay du bist auch ein bisschen Hoppenstedt.
Nudel im Gesicht.
Vor allem wenn sie sagt Es hat ein tieferes Anliegen. Und wir unterstellen ihr Image Beratung für die Identitäre Bewegung.
Dann müssen wir ja Schlimmstes befürchten.
Dann kommt sie in so eine Verteidigungsrede in macht es dann auch keinen Spaß als Publikum sich mit ihr auseinanderzusetzen. Was will sie jetzt machen wenn sie uns jetzt erklären Nee ich habe das so und so gemeint.
Was ist Ihr Ausweg aus dieser Situation. Sie nennen sich ja nochmal eine schöne Gegenüberstellung 2018 2020 2018 sprach sie über Shitstorms so.
Man sagt mir dann wenn irgendein Artikel erscheint und innerhalb einer Stunde gibt es 200 Menschen die sich echauffieren und mir die Pest an den Kragen wünschen dann sagte man mir Du bist auf dem richtigen Weg.
Sind sie lustig 2020 mitten im Shitstorm heißt es dann plötzlich.
Ich glaube dass man sich da auch einig war. Selbst jetzt Kritiker dass Kunst alles darf man wälzt es nur auf uns. Die Künstler ab. Der Künstler darf.
Ich glaube auch sicherlich ist es heute auch gut möglich Mit irgendeinem Thema einen Shitstorm loszutreten Man muss aber auch immer wieder sagen Bei diesen Shitstorms,
sind gewisse Blasen in denen sich diese Shitstorms ereignen und die sind,
oft vollkommen irrelevant.
Das heißt es empören sich manche kleinen Grüppchen dann darüber und dann ist das auch wieder gut oder man hat jetzt hier einfach nur,
sehnsüchtig darauf gewartet dass man in irgendeiner Weise ein Verbot hat dann spielt ja die Springer-Presse immer in besonderem Maße mit weil die jetzt gerade,
wissen dass sie von rechts überhaupt noch Leute finden können die ihre Blätter lesen und vielleicht sogar so ein Abo abschließen.
Man muss das jetzt mal so sagen sie hat jetzt einen Roman geschrieben in der Regel wenn man nicht Günter Grass oder Martin Walser ist.
In Deutschland sind den Deutschen und der deutschen öffentlichkeit Romane scheißegal.
Man muss es so sagen dass sie jetzt mit diesem Roman mit dieser Lesung eine solche Aufmerksamkeit erhalten kann ist ja nur dadurch möglich geworden dass man diese,
Kaskaden auch gegenseitig nach oben getrieben hat.
Twitter das perfekte nervöse Medium dafür dass man das ebenso beschleunigt.
Es verdeckt diese Lautstärke verdeckt die große Irrelevanz.
Auch 2018. Es ist ja in ihr angelegt dieses Anderssein wollen vor allem anders als das Publikum für das man spielt und daraus auch so ein bisschen was zu generieren.
Und da hat sie hier auch so eine. Ich würde sagen das ist dann tatsächlich so eine stromern Sache bei der man schon weiß wie es ausgeht denn sie ist dann in so einem Shitstorm kommt jetzt nachdem wir das jetzt hören,
so Zuspruch von Dieter Nuhr dann weiß ich schon in welche Richtung das so geht wenn sie das aufrechterhalten will und so weiter.
Und dann ist sie im Grunde diese alte weise Männer Falle getappt hier nochmal 2018.
Ich kann nicht sagen wer damit angefangen hat ob der Künstler plötzlich diesen widerwärtigen drang entwickelt hat sich sich einzuschleichen irgendwie in das Rektum des Publikums zu kriechen und sich zu einem von ihnen zu machen.
Oder ob das Publikum begonnen hat diesen diesen Schrei nach Authentizität laut werden zu lassen dass sie gar nicht mehr dass sie es gar nicht mehr akzeptieren können etwas Fremdes zu sehen und zu schätzen.
Aber das ist natürlich auch ein Ding unserer Zeit Wir annektieren alles was wir zu allem gesagt auch immer dieser Ausspruch selbst.
Wenn wenn wenn linke Flüchtlingspolitik betrieben wird dann gesagt wird Das sind Menschen wie du und ich.
Das ist ein Satz der mich wahnsinnig macht. Wieso können wir nicht Menschen akzeptieren unter der Prämisse dass jemand anders ist.
Wieso können wir eine andere Kultur nicht als solche akzeptieren. Warum müssen die immer wieder auf das rekurrieren. Das ist eigentlich dasselbe.
Da zeigt sich eigentlich in nur gutem Willen. Ich weiß dass sie es gut meinen.
Aber doch eine Xenophobie eine Angst vor dem Fremden und die spiegelt sich in ihrer Rezeption zur Kunst wider in der Politik wo sie einfach versuchen alles auf ihre Ebene zu ziehen weil sie sonst unfähig sind mit etwas zu kooperieren.
Das ist total Banane. Wenn wir sagen wir retten Menschen im Mittelmeer dann machen wir das weil es Menschen sind und keine anderen Argumente werden dann gebraucht.
Das ist der Bezug auf die Menschenrechte und die gehen davon aus die sind aber auch nicht davon befangen welche kulturellen Unterschiede sind hört er auch gerne Klassik oder.
Genau hier unterstellt das eine linke Debatte so geführt wird dass man sagt Wir retten die weil sie Menschen sind wie du und ich.
Damit hegt man schon mal ein Mensch wer wie der andere dann würden wir es nicht machen und dann diese Haltung die sie den andichtet Xenophobie unterstellen.
Das ist schon über drei Ecken zu viel gespielt und sich gerechtfertigt.
Dafür gibt es auch das Wort perfide weil so kann man nicht wenn man Programme schreibt und die dann da so vorträgt. Am Ende ist da so eine Sache dabei.
Das geht nicht. Das ist.
Sie machte aber so eine interessante Verschränkung denn sie beobachtet ja erst einmal etwas sehr Richtiges dass es eine Tendenz gibt dass man die Kunst nicht mehr als Kunst auf der Bühne sein.
Wir hatten das ja auch bei den Computerspielen sondern dass man sagt ja was hat das dann für Nutzen und das soll mich aber jetzt auch ganz konkret ansprechen.
Und wenn das mich nicht konkret anspricht wenn es mich nicht da abholt wo ich stehe um einmal diese fürchterliche Formulierung zu gebrauchen dann bin ich beleidigt dann bin ich auch eingeschnappt Warum muss eigentlich Christopher Nolan seinen Film so kompliziert man doch mal linear erzählen können.
Ja
Wirklich platt.
Ja das gibt es jetzt macht sie nur folgendes Erst einmal muss man unterscheiden zwischen der Kunst und dem Künstler.
Ich würde.
Ich würde erst mal sagen der Künstler interessiert mich nicht sondern mich interessiert eigentlich nur das Werk.
Es war in Bayreuth lange Zeit.
In Bayreuth lange Zeit sogar üblich dass die Schauspieler oder Sänger nach der Vorstellung nicht vorbeugender.
Sogar am Wiener Burgtheater üblich dass die Schauspieler oder Sänger sich nach der Vorstellung nicht verbeugen durften die kamen nicht auf die Bühne es gab auch keinen Applaus.
Es gab Applaus.
Applaus in Bayreuth nur für das Werk und,
im Burgtheater gar keinen Applaus.
Im Burgtheater gar keinen Applaus. Irgendwann wurde das eingeführt von Helmut Zilk damals Bürgermeister.
Irgendwann wurde das hineinführt in Wien von Helmut Zilk damals Bürgermeister von Dagmar Koller und anderen hat man aber auch irgendwann hat man gesagt Gut die dürfen sich jetzt da verbeugen kommen.
Dagmar Koller und dann hat man aber in Bayreuth auch irgendwann hat man gesagt Die dürfen sich jetzt da verbeugen kommen.
Denn man wollte nicht die Eitelkeit der Sänger dort ausstellen sondern man diente dem Werk Das Publikum war auch nur da um dem Werk zu huldigen.
Denn man wollte nicht die Eitelkeit der Sänger dort ausstellen sondern man diente dem Werk Das Publikum war.
Das heißt natürlich zu.
Jetzt ist es natürlich etwas sehr anderes wenn man jetzt eine,
Performancekünstlerin oder Comedian ist wie sie dann ist natürlich Künstler und Werk in Form der Kunstfigur schon einmal ganz anders präsent.
Aber ich glaube ihr gar nicht so sehr dass sie sich hier so als die Kunstfigur verstellt sondern sie präsentiert ja permanent ihre Kolumnistin Meinungen die sind nur andere als die die mir jetzt weiß ich nicht wer,
aus der Comedy Szene sonst so präsentieren würde.
Aber eigentlich unterscheidet sie sich bis auf eben diese Kleider die ihr gewiss gut stehen kaum eigentlich davon.
Es ist hier nicht denn das haben wir ja durchaus im Comedy.
Eine reine Kunstfigur die hier steht also ich würde das auch sehr bezweifeln.
Denken wir an zwei Comedians die uns hier mal ja einfallen die wirklich diese Künstlichkeit so starke Figur sind.
Wir haben keine ernsthaften Interviews mit Otto Otto sitzen nicht irgendwo ja da hatte ich schlimme Depressionen und so weiter. Der macht immer seine Späßchen.
Atze Schröder ist sogar verboten ihn zu fotografieren und sein bei seinem Namen zu nennen wie er eigentlich heißt.
Also bleibt man dieser Figur haben wir in der Comedy Szene sehr häufig. Wir haben uns nicht.
Sie lehnt das auch komplett sie häufiger diese Frage Ist es eigentlich eine Kunstfigur stöhnen sie darüber. Nein.
Häufiger diese Frage ist es eigentlich ein.
Das ist das echte ich während sie gleichzeitig die Kunst und die Künstler.
Zitat mag sie gar nicht weil man fragt Ja was denn nun.
Sie arbeitet sich und das finde ich gut wenn sie so gegen den Selfie waren die sozialen Medien und so weiter das kann ich alles machen.
Aber der muss sie nicht in einem Halbsatz nochmal den Linken irgendwas unterstellen was sie dann wieder klar provoziert einfach.
Sie hat hier noch einmal diesen Spruch über Diversität das klingt auf wenn man sie erst einmal hört. Das ist klug aber es ist halt einfach nur blöde.
Man hält immer hoch Diversität. Das finde ich ja schön aber nicht im Individuum.
Aber nicht.
Und das ist das perverse Sie wollen Diversität in allem aber das Individuum hat authentisch zu sein. Und da halte ich es immer mit Rambo Ich ist ein anderer.
Das ist das Pavia.
Aber das Individuum hat auch Helwig. Da halte ich es im Raum wo ich ist ein anderer.
Und das sollten Sie sich mal auf die Fahnen schreiben.
Und das sollten Sie sich mal auf die Fahnen schreiben,
ja was soll man mit so einer Aussage machen.
Individuum und Authentizität widersprechen sich ja nicht. Ich bin nun auch kein Anhänger des Konzepts der Authentizität. Gemeint ist ein anderer ist ganz anders zu deuten.
Aber es wirkt so als sei es klug. Ich glaube das reicht für das Kabarett Publikum noch allemal.
Man kann das wenn man sich so ein bisschen interessiert. Man kann man mal links liegen lassen weil die sind einfach gut.
Diese Interviews dann mal bei Volle Kanne ZDF.
Dann macht man sich so Sachen wie ich dann schaue ich mir das ja alles in eine Playlist und höre das dann in doppelter Geschwindigkeit durch.
Das heißt ich habe dann so drei Stunden Material aber alle 20 Minuten geht es wieder von vorne los.
Sie langweilt sich dann selber. Das ist ja wirklich. Sie wird dann gefragt Ist das eigentlich eine Kunstfigur.
Eigentlich wollte eigentlich Lisa Eckhardt eigentlich eine Kunstfigur oder sind sie immer so.
Das ist natürlich die beliebteste Frage schon mal jemand gefragt die Frage wirklich.
Ich habe in zwei Stunden an der Frage ungefähr gefeilt. Ich hätte Angst um meine Finger wenn ich jeden Journalisten verprügeln würde. Diese stupide Frage stellt. Nein natürlich ist es keine Kunstfigur.
Sie sind auch im normalen Leben so. Natürlich haben sie Freunde. Nein.
So wie sie genervt ist von der Frage die Sie immer bekommt ist das eigentlich eine Kunstfigur kennt man dann auch ihre Antworten zum Thema Social Media und zum Thema Selfie.
Und es gibt ja bei manchen Leuten ist das ja so Die kommen so auf eine eigene Art und Weise wieder rüber dass die Interviews egal wo sie mit wem geführt werden.
Wer die Fragen stellt immer auf den gleichen Zweck einlaufen und das ist bei ihr als hätte sie so ein Magnet irgendwie eine junge Frau die aber nicht Social-Media mitmacht sondern dagegen wettert.
Es ist so ein Programm bloggt er findet dann wie in geschriebenen Programmen in jedem Interview so sein Ding wie er will und am Ende sind wirklich die Antworten von ihr die darauf lenken weil man muss dann so nachfragen.
Also Selfies Gibt's von Ihnen nicht. Da nimmt Nuzzi dann eben auch die Gelegenheit und wird dann halt ihre Pointen los. Wir hören dass jemand zum Beispiel.
Sie machen sie das Spiegelbild. Da stehen sie.
Ungefähr.
Das ist.
Eine Figur die der Republik wunderbar funktioniert weil die haben keine Ahnung von Social Media.
Ich finde es auch blöd das ganz wunderbar. Die sitzen ja echt vor einem Lagerfeuer vor dem Fernseher Lagerfeuer und reden darüber dass das ein bisschen Banane.
Ja das ist die nachmittags Sendung vom MDR er.
Selten dass jemand auf den ersten Blick so interessant erscheint und dann so schnell und einfach weil die Wiederholung dann doch sehr hoch ist.
Selten jemanden auf den ersten Blick so interessant so schnell.
Ich hatte mich ja auch vorher mit ihr gar nicht beschäftigt. Und auch jetzt soll das Interesse wieder verloren.
Eine schöne eine schöne Pointe hat sie dann trotzdem nämlich zum Thema und das hast du ja auch schon häufiger mal gehabt.
Eigentlich will ich zum,
Thema.
In fünf sechs Jahren werde ich glaube ich nicht mehr den Zug besteigen wollen jeden Tag und mich dann entflohenen.
Mit diesen Filz sitzen in der Bahn des erdet nicht so sehr.
Dass er nicht zu sehr.
Eher nicht zu sehr. Dann kommen sie immer wieder dieses Gefühl von Menschlichkeit auch.
Dann kommt immer wieder dieses Gefühl von Menschlichkeit auf das ich so nach und nach von mir.
Auf.
Manche haben so diesen Drang. Manche wollen noch reinwachsen manche wollen erwachsen werden manche wollen gerne das Menschliche ablegen.
In der Tat.
Ist das Menschliche das klingt jetzt wieder so das Alltägliche das Alltägliche das liebe ich nicht so sehr und versuche das möglichst von mir fernzuhalten.
Und das ist mitunter sehr anstrengend das zu tun.
Aber es macht auch großen Spaß und es ist aber auch eine gewisse zivilisatorische Kraft liegt darin dass man sich das alltägliche selbst vom Leib hält und dass man es auch anderen nicht zu sehr zumutet.
Denn das ist eigentlich ja gerade die Pointe die wir sehen können.
Bei diesen Masken Protesten die wir jetzt überall haben.
Das sind eben Leute die nicht in der Lage sind die ihre öffentliche Rolle einzunehmen sondern die permanent sagen Ich bin jetzt hier wie in meinem Wohnzimmer. Ich möchte so sein wie ich bin.
Da muss man einfach sagen genau das ist ein Authentizität der für jeden anderen eine Zumutung ist.
Da ist sie ganz auf einer Linie. Weshalb zieht man sich eigentlich gut an,
auch für den anderen um ihn zu entlasten.
Auch für den anderen.
Sie werden nicht da ich bin ja nicht wirklich wenn der Alltag am besten wäre meine Frau mir am Wochenende diese.
Ich bin ja da ganz anders gestrickt Ich finde der Alltag am besten wenn meine Frau mir sagt Am Wochenende kommt Besuch muss ich kurz durchatmen bevor mich interessiert wer kommt.
Durch. Mich interessiert mehr. Ja.
Ich will da lieber Alltag. Deswegen bin ich auch froh dass die Schulen wieder offen sind.
Nee Alltag finde ich. So finde ich auch gut dass es immer alles schön gleichförmig verläuft das mag ich auch.
Ich mag ein gleichförmiger leben.
Sehr gut.
Damit ich beschließe aber den August haben wir natürlich nicht abgehandelt.
Beschließen wir heute den August Wir haben ihn natürlich vollumfänglich abgehandelt verweisen auf den Salon.
Wir haben schon einen ersten schriftlichen Kommentar zum Thema Hegel und die Philosophen behandelt.
Wenn wir das heute öfter machen. Ich möchte dass ich die Einleitung des Buches von Markus Gabriel mitbringen werde.
Heute könnte das öfter machen ich möchte hier ankündigen dass ich die Einleitung des Buches von Markus Gabriel mitbringen werde.
Es ist das schlechteste Buch das ich jemals.
Ich kann mir nicht kann mich wirklich nicht erinnern.
Habe. Sein Interview im Deutschlandradio gelesen in dem er sich zu Bertolt Brecht und seinem Marxismus auslässt und ich musste wirklich denken das kann ja gar nicht hier passieren einem erwachsenen Menschen.
Es ist ja unfassbar.
Dieses Interview war für mich der Zweck mir das Buch im Urlaub runterzuladen.
Ich konnte es nicht glauben deswegen kündige hier an.
Müssen es zerreißen es ist nicht weiter als gelesen ich habe noch ein Kapitel rein geguckt wo er nochmal betont die Regierung hat alles richtig gemacht.
Es war ein moralischer Fortschritt der geleistet wurde im ersten Halbjahr 2020 in Deutschland kann man so urteilen ob man als Philosophieprofessor in Bonn irgendwie mit 19 Jahren Professor wurde.
Nochmal Dank an Angela Merkel im letzten Amtsjahr als Buch und Standardwerk der moralischen Fortschrittlichkeit publiziert ist eigene Sache.
Je nachdem wo man hin will. Das kann sein das ist unglaublich. Ein großes Rätsel.
Das kann sein dahinter ist. Es ist unglaublich ein großes Rätsel auch ich werde ausführlich daraus zitieren und wir müssen uns dann gemeinsam die Frage stellen Wie ist das möglich weil wir nicht einmal das Land der Dichter und Denker ist alles verloren.
Ausführlich zitieren ist das üblich waren wir nicht einmal das Land der Dichter und Denker ist jetzt alles verloren.
Das ist die Frage der Einsicht.
Wir bleiben der Philosophie treu.
Ansonsten können diese Sachen eine sehr große Auswahl.
Diese Sachen waren sehr sehr.
Ehrlich gesagt manche Monat ist ja ein bisschen eng aber diesmal August war ganz gute Ernte will ich sagen was Texte angeht.
Eng aber es war,
bei mir auch ein bisschen Wirtschaft gehen. Es wird auch um Literatur und Arbeit wird es ein wenig gehen und es gibt jetzt ein Unternehmen ein Unternehmens Porträt über Instagram ein Buch.
Das habe ich auch. Ich habe die erste Hälfte gelesen genau da drüber reden.
350 Seiten über Instagram. Ich habe die erste Hälfte gelesen.
Das ist doch ganz schön historisch aufgearbeitet wie das so losgeht mit limitierten Fähigkeiten dann doch noch etwas tolles großes zu zaubern einfach sehr gut.
Das ist prima für ein historisch aufgearbeitet losgeht doch noch so etwas Großes zu zaubern.
Sehr gut hier vertagt uns dann im Salon natürlich alle bucht Wir können auf die Gästeliste schauen Da wird fleißig eingeteilt.
Dann sind wir hier vertagt und melden uns dann im Salon den wir natürlich alle auch auf die Gästeliste schauen Da wird fleißig eingeteilt.
Wir haben jetzt 30 Mitgliedschaften und die Hälfte davon ist jetzt im August Juli August gekommen.
Wir haben jetzt 30 Gast auch schon die Hälfte davon ist im August in die Abguss gekommen sind wir das sehr gut dass das funktioniert ansonsten gerne direkt buchen.
Wir haben es sehr gut dass das funktioniert ansonsten gerne direkt buchen.
Wenn euch das finanziell möglich ist denn das unterstützt uns ja auch hier den Kopf frei zu räumen für Lisa Eckert und die Republikaner in Amerika.
Wenn euch das finanziell eigentlich ist das Unterstützungs.
Leider macht gut.
Intro/Outro